foreign
for your website SEO or search in your
optimization is the key to skyrocketing
your online presence by strategically
integrating relevant keywords throughout
your website and securing high quality
backlinks you will capture the attention
of search engine and soar up the ranking
however SEO is not solely about
algorithm it revolves around delivering
an exceptional user experience from
lightning fast loading speed to
captivating mobile friendly designs SEO
enhances every aspect of your website
with the rapid advancement of technology
and the exponential growth of website on
the internet the demand of SEO
professional is sovereign speaking of
salaries and entry-level SEO
professionals can earn around 45
000 to 90 000 per year and as you gain
more experience the potential for higher
earning in this field increases
so if you are looking to become an SEO
professional then look no further than
simply runs postgraduate program in
digital marketing gain in-depth
knowledge of search engineer
optimization with this course you will
also learn content marketing web
analytics keyword management and
research website optimization and more
unlock a whole two blocks of skills
including SC ranking HootSuite Facebook
Instagram LinkedIn YouTube Twitter
Google ads and Keyword Planner so don't
miss out on this opportunity Find the
course Link in the description for more
information here success story from our
satisfied Learner in their own words
change is inevitable but growth is
optional
for me both came hand in hand
I successfully changed my career from
software development to digital
marketing and simply learn present at
the perfect route hi I'm rimajraf from
Dubai and I have completed the pgp in
digital marketing from Simply learn with
Purdue University when I shifted to
Dubai from Sri Lanka in 2015 I joined a
group of company as a software engineer
but my interest in content creation
attracted me towards the marketing
industry intrigued by the marketing
functions I decided to take up a
challenge that would change my life
forever I aim for a career change as
risky as it was the rewards were truly
overwhelming even though the journey
wasn't easy the pgp in digital marketing
with Purdue University acted as not only
a catalyst but a game changer for my
career change with no profiling
certification in marketing domain it was
difficult for me to transition and
change my career towards completely
so I decided to upskill with the
professional certification program
I just simply learn because of its
tremendously High waiting to be rated as
one of the best Education portal online
worldwide is surely promising not only
were the ratings I but also the courses
were economically charged the modules
were very informative and amazing I
still refer to those while in the final
stage of my course I told my Superior
about the certification program I was
doing and then it offered me a digital
marketing role in the marketing
department as a digital marketing
executive this that's how smooth it was
after working for a few years in the
same company as a digital marketing
executive I switched to a new role as a
digital marketing manager with this my
skill upgraded my salary increase and my
self-confident Boost alongside numerous
other positive outcomes I had a chance
to take a challenge and change my career
domain all together
and I took it So currently I'm pursuing
masters of Masters program from Simply
learn where I would complete eight
Masters program including artificial
intelligent cloud computing and devops
and many more growing requires moving
out of our comfort zones
keep learning unleash the magic of SEO
and witness the floodgates open as your
website attracts a tidal wave of organic
traffic and enjoy unrivaled success in
the digital Ram so let's get started
with Rachel is a baker who runs her own
Bakery to expand her business she
decided to create an online presence by
first setting up a Blog she began
posting on her blog regularly however
even after regularly posting on the blog
there were barely any visitors showing
up deciding not to give up Rachel began
searching for a solution on the internet
that's when she came across SEO or
search engine optimization a term she's
never heard before
so let's take a journey together and
help her learn about SEO search engine
optimization is a method that could
improve the quality and quantity of the
audience coming to Rachel's website from
search engines it could increase brand
awareness attract local customers and
build credibility and trust and all of
this is possible without having to spend
a single penny to bring visitors to our
website Rachel would have to take
advantage of the two types of SEO
on-page and off-page SEO Rachel first
decides to tackle on-page SEO and get
that sorted on-page SEO involved Rachel
optimizing her website both in terms of
content and the technical aspects
including the HTML source code schema
meta Tags and More she started off by
using tools like Google AdWords allref
and semrush to identify popular Search
terms associated with the recipes she
planned to publish on her blog she began
to look for Search terms related to the
broader area of baking cooking and
related topics once she found these
Search terms she began to incorporate
them into her recipes she started off by
providing an introduction to the recipe
with this she could provide an engaging
beginning to her story like how the dish
reminded her of her childhood and
enabled her to naturally include the
Search terms into the blog she also
included these keywords in the actual
recipe as well additionally she added
pictures videos time lapses and more to
increase credibility and engagement for
her content and subsequently persuading
search engines to show her content more
people
after this she moved to the website
metacontent that search engines display
when her blog appears in search results
she optimized The Meta tax alt tags
header Tags and More this completed the
on-page aspect of SEO thanks to this she
saw a significant increase in the number
of visitors coming to her page having
done all she could on her web page she
now decides to explore what could be
done off page to improve her Page's
visibility on search engines off-page
SEO involved Rachel doing things outside
her site page to help increase its
search engine rankings
making optimizations outside the site
would improve the site's popularity
relevance trustworthiness and Authority
this is possible with the help of
reputable websites vouching for your
content with backlinks social media
marketing guest blogging linked unlinked
brand mentions influencer marketing and
much more
Rachel also understood that for her
content to reach people she would have
to promote it on social media platforms
like Facebook Twitter and Instagram as
well as Niche platforms like quora
Reddit and medium
these could help her achieve greater
reach for her website by sending
stronger social signals to search
engines leading to the page being shown
as highly relevant for related searches
and audiences and Eve
Eve after understanding and implementing
all of this Rachel had just scratched
the surface of what was possible with
SEO Rachel decided to take up
simplylearn's digital marketing
certification with classes covering just
about everything she needed to know
about SEO it was only a matter of time
before Rachel began to implement her
learnings on her website and see a
massive uptick in the number of viewers
coming to her website in time she could
even earn money off the site by setting
up an online shop and with that we've
covered an introduction to the concepts
of SEO and the possibilities it can open
for you so let's start with the why we
would do keyword research so Jesse is
planning to publish a Blog of pizza
recipes so she was doing pizza recipe
step by step piece of recipes with
sausage homemade pizza toppings pizza
dough recipes thin crust pizzas she's
doing a lot of different topics on pizza
recipes well what Jesse needs to do is
understand what's going to drive traffic
to these blog posts if she's writing
about you know different topics around
pizza recipes so she's Unsure how these
blogs are going to drive traffic so she
really needs to understand that hey you
need to choose the right keywords to
drive traffic so the question is if
you're writing a blog post about recipes
with sausages is pizza recipes with
sausages or recipes for free the best
keywords he is maybe maybe not so you
need to take uh care and shoes in the
queue words to align with your content
so that's really the idea of why we
would do keyword research because some
of the issues with keywords that are
poorly chosen are they can have low
search volume for example you may choose
a keyword that just a lot of people
aren't using to search for or they can
be highly competitive so if you choose a
keyword that's very broad or popular it
can be very competitive and take you a
long time to be found for that keyword
or you could just make the mistake of
choosing a keyword that isn't aligned
with your content or you can choose
keywords but use them incorrectly with
your content so these are some of the
issues that you can encounter if you
just go about choosing keywords randomly
without due diligence without the proper
research so low search volume will lead
to less traffic High competition you may
not even rank at all okay if somebody
finds you for a keyword that's not
relevant to the topic they're just going
to leave the page and if you're not
using the right keywords and or if you
are using the right keywords and not
using them correctly in the content then
your pages may not even be found in
organic search so you really have to
take care and choosing the keywords to
me that's the most important step with
SEO is keyword research so we're going
to talk about the types of keyword
research then so we have short tail
keyword and we have long tail keywords
so if you write a blog post about pizza
recipes well what are you going to
choose a short tail or long tail so
let's talk about short tail keywords
first so short tail keywords are
keywords that are usually three keywords
and a phrase or shorter in some cases it
may be two key words in a phrase or
shorter so shortcut keywords usually
have high search volume which means
likely means higher competition but what
it also means it could be lower
conversions because short tell key words
like for example pizza recipes could be
considered a short tail keyword but
maybe somebody's looking for homemade
pizza recipes or pizza recipes from
their favorite Italian restaurant so
short taking words may not be as
relevant so if we compare it with long
tail keywords chances are you're going
to have lower competition that's one of
the benefits but you're also gonna have
lower search volume but with longer tail
keywords the key word is probably going
to be more relevant with the content
you're right writing about so therefore
the conversion rates likely going to be
higher so that's really the difference
between short-term keywords and long
tail keywords if you want to look at
simplistically short tail keywords are
Broad in nature it's going to capture a
lot of eyeballs but those eyeballs may
look at your content as not relevant
versus long tail K words that may be
very relevant but not as many eyeballs
on them so short tail keywords the
characteristics they're not as specific
usually they're less than three words
they have high search volume and high
competition so if you just choose pizza
recipes could take you a while to rank
for that keyword but when you rank
you're going to get the traffic but
again it may not convert because the
keyword is Broad in nature so pizza
recipes is a short tail keyword that may
not be exactly what you're writing about
in your blog post so it may draw a lot
of traffic but the traffic may not do
anything so the longer tail keywords are
very specific they consist of more than
three words in in the search query they
have relatively low search volume
competition so the chance of you ranking
higher faster for that long take word is
probably going to be greater because not
many other websites are trying to rank
for that same keyword and so the benefit
of that is if you have let's just say
homemade pizza recipes with mushrooms
that's a long tip key word but if
somebody's looking for that type of
pizza recipe then you know you're going
to track the right traffic and chances
are that traffic is going to engage or
convert based on the type of conversion
you have in place so example would be
homemade pizza dough recipes that'd be
another example more than three key
words in the phrase very specific we're
talking about homemade pizza dough
recipe so we're not talking about just
pizza recipes so it's a little bit more
specific in nature longer tail so these
keywords are used for targeted Pages
including blog posts if you're writing a
blog post specifically about pizza
recipes with homemade dough then this is
the key word you likely would want to
use versus just pizza recipes so let's
look at an example between a short tail
keyword and a long tail keyword and to
accentuate the differences we're going
to use Google's Keyword Planner tool so
Google's keyboard Planner tool is
located in Google ads the Google ads
platform and when you're in the Google
ads platform you can simply click on
tools and then Keyword Planner and so
what Keyword Planner allows us to do is
get a sense of the type of volume that a
particular keyword has so what Google's
Keyword Planner does is they show you
the average monthly searches this is the
average monthly search volume of a key
word over the past 12 months and so in
this example we're going to choose pizza
recipes and homemade pizza dough recipes
so one short tail and one long tail so
we enter those keywords in we're gonna
click get results and what Google's
going to do is going to show us the
volume of those keywords so for pizza
recipe we could see the average monthly
search volume is 33 100 for pizza recipe
so note that pizza recipe and pizza
recipes are closely related keywords and
so what Google does is they consider
that a close variance so meaning if
somebody ties a piece of recipe then
they're also in Google's eyes looking
for pizza recipes so it's a close
variance and so for the keyword pizza
recipe which is short tail we could see
on average over the past 12 months this
keyword received 33 100 queries and so
if we hover over the graph we could see
basically the volume of the average
volume per month so here I could see for
this particular keyword here the volume
per month is 33 1000 and then I can see
the actual volume over the past 12
months and then for the long long tail
keyword I can see homemade pizza dough
recipe again close variants homemade
pizza dough recipes I can see over the
past 12 months with the search volume is
for this on average it's 2400 but I
could see here in December the volume
went up to 3600 but for example in May
it was 1900. so it's gonna fluctuate a
bit over the past 12 months but on
average is about 2400. so shorter tail a
lot of more volume longer tail not as
much volume but nonetheless there is
volume here and so these are the
difference between a short tail and a
longer tail and so well Google's Keyword
Planner also does is allow us to get a
sense of what the competition is and so
here I can see the competition is low
for both of these keywords fair enough
so we now know that if we want to
optimize or choose the keyword homemade
pizza dough recipe for our blog post we
know for rank points on page one of
Google even in the top spot we can
expect about 2400 search queries for
that keyword now whether you get all
2400 clicks for that keyword remains to
be seen chances are you're not going to
get all 2400 you're going to get a
Lion's Share of those clicks but you're
going to at least get some volume on it
so even the longer tick keywords have a
lot of Promise because there is some
search volume here for this keyword how
to do a proper keyword research so we
looked at Google's Keyword Planner tool
in Google ads and we typed in two
keywords and we were able to get a sense
of what the average volume is so we
definitely want to choose keywords based
on the following factors we want to
choose it based on search volume search
volume is a good indicator of the
potential traffic we can obtain so again
for the keyword homemade pizza dough
recipe we know that it averages 2400 a
month in search volume again we may not
not get all 2400 but we're gonna get a
line share of that we also need to look
at competition and so Google's Keyword
Planner gives us a high medium or low in
terms of the competition but if you're
somebody who wants to get a better sense
of what the competition is and you
should because competition is a key
component in choosing keywords and so
what I want to do is get a sense of how
many people are actually optimizing for
that keyword so Google's Keyword Planner
tool is going to give me a low medium
high really what I want to do is get a
better sense of that numerically so what
I can do is go into Google search and I
could type in pizza recipes and I could
see there's about one billion results
that's a lot of results however that
means that every potential web page out
there on the internet that mentions
pizza recipes is going to be included in
this number here and so I want to get a
better sense of who's optimizing for
pizza recipes so I'm going to put in the
all in title syntax and so what that is
going to ask Google to do is tell me all
the websites that have pizza recipes the
keyword pizza recipes in the title tag
so if I do all entitle colon space then
pizza recipes my result drops down to
336 000. so what that tells me is that
there are 336
000 results with the keyword pizza
recipes in the title tag now if I want
to focus in on my other keyword if I
choose uh my other keyword was a longer
tail keyword homemade pizza dough recipe
so if I type that keyword in the
homemade pizza dough recipe or recipes
remember close variance and I just click
enter or type the keyword in hit my
Enter key I'm gonna get 35 Million
results but again is that really an
indicator of the type of competition I
have no because every listing that
matches homemade pizza dough recipes is
going to be including the search results
so I'm going to type in my all in title
colon space and then I'm going to get a
better sense of how many websites have
the keyword homemade pizza dough recipes
in the title tag and I get
2160 different results so here I can see
the first result in the title tag
homemade pizza dough recipe second one
homemade pizza dough recipe so these are
sites web pages that have that keyword
in the title tag so now I have a
numerical number to work with and so the
thing you have to understand about SEO
specifically about keyword research is
you need to do research on a few
different keywords not just one or two
so what we want to do is have a
spreadsheet the spreadsheet is going to
contain keywords that we can potentially
want to optimize for choose as keywords
to optimize for SEO and so my
recommendation is you come up with a
theme first so that theme for us in this
exercise is pizza recipes and so that's
our theme so we chose the keyword pizza
recipes so the close variance here is
pizza recipe what was the volume well we
know the volume was 33 100 for pizza
recipe so what are we going to do we're
going to put that number in in our
volume column what was the competition
well if we go back and type in pizza
recipes it was 683 000 so I'm going to
type in 683
000. what was our next keyword well it
was pizza or homemade pizza dough
recipes so if I go back for this
particular keyword is 2400 so I'm going
to put 2400 in under my volume column
and then what was my competition well my
competition was I typed that keyword
back in
2160. so I'm going to put 2
160. so now I have an idea of what kind
of volume and what kind of competition I
have now now you want to do this for a
number of different keywords and when
you do it for a number of keywords what
you do want to do is obviously choose a
relevant keyword that has high volume
and low competition so another way of
saying it is the volume or ratio of
volume to competition and so basically
what we could do is take volume divided
by competition if I make that a
percentage I can see it's 0.35 percent
is the ratio between volume and
competition if I do the same for my
longer tail keyword 2400 divided by 2160
I can see that 111 so this just kind of
proves the point that yeah I'm still
going to get some volume but I have a
better chance of ranking for this longer
tail keyword homemade pizza dough
recipes so you want to be able to do
that for number keywords and examine the
volume the competition and the ratio
between volume and competition for your
themed keywords in this case pizza
recipes so relevancy you want want to
choose keywords that are very relevant
to the content that you're writing and
then again commercial intent what
keywords are going to drive more
conversions and revenue for the business
so when we talk about commercial intent
we're talking about you know are you
choosing keywords that are going to get
somebody to do what you want them to do
so we could say You Know download pizza
dough recipes so somebody's typing in
the keyword download pizza dough recipes
then chances are they're going to find
you come to your site and take action by
downloading that pizza dough recipe so
you want to be able to also think about
the intent of the keyword is it going to
help you drive conversions and revenue
if you're an e-commerce site so search
volume is the average monthly search
volume made for a particular keyword and
phrase so we can get that number using
Google's Keyword Planner tool in the
Google ads platform we want to Target
keywords with high search volume that
will help bring traffic to the website
we want volume but we want to take into
account seasonality as well so that's
where the Google's Keyword Planner tool
comes in place because if we go back
again we can just hover over we can get
a sense of any particular Trend going on
or season out so for example if I saw
large growth in the winter months and
not much volume growth in the summer
months then that might indicate to me
that this keyword is more popular during
the winter time so pay attention to the
grass that you know the Keyword Planner
tool gives you use them to your
advantage to take into account
seasonality so a good example would be
funny Halloween costumes well we know
that for Halloween you're going to have
a spike probably towards the end of
September all the way through October
and then it's going to drop after
October 31st which is Halloween so
that's an example but in the case of
pizza recipes you know you may find that
more people are are choosing to search
for pizza recipes during learn maybe the
summer months versus the winter months
so pay attention to seasonality it will
affect search volume so competition
based on our example it's one of the
most important key metrics you don't
want to choose a key word that's highly
competitive because if it's competitive
then it's going to be harder to rank
number one or even on page one of Google
depending on competitive it is so high
search volume low competition in other
words the ratio between the two is the
ideal combination so going back to the
spreadsheet recommend you have that
spreadsheet handy put your theme in
place okay theme pizza recipes we use
Google's Keyword Planner tool to find
the volume we use the all entitled
syntax to find the competition so we
entered both of those numbers in and we
get our ratio and so when you have these
numbers for a number of different
keywords you want to be able to choose
that ratio of high volume low
competition but always relevant see
always trumps ratio so always go with a
key word that is going to be relevant to
your content don't choose a keyword
that's not relevant if you choose a
keyword that's not relevant it's not
going to bode well for user engagement
so the difficulty of a keyword ranges
from 0 to 100 and Google's keyword tool
so it's going to be easy it's going to
be medium it's going to be hard but my
recommendation is also to get the
numerical factor and that's the all in
title syntax and again relevancy is what
drives the traffic to your website and
keep the traffic there on your website
and also not only will keep the traffic
on your website but hopefully get that
traffic to engage and convert so that's
the key about relevancy you always want
to choose keywords that are relevant to
your content even if it's sacrificing
volume relevancy again trumps volume and
competition so always choose relevant
keywords first so when you do do that
you're always almost guaranteeing that
at some point somebody's going to find
your content because somebody out there
might be looking for it and if they do
you're going to get found and then the
engagement is going to be better so
understand your business find keywords
that are relevant to your business and
then focus on those keywords that'll
help you with getting the right traffic
to your site always keep in mind the
commercial intent so these keywords are
more specific and result in conversion
rate for example buying is a good
commercial intent keyword so if you
really want somebody to come to your
website and buy then focus on those
types of keywords in the case of the
pizza recipes maybe it's download could
be our commercial intent keyword again
there may be low search volume but those
are the type of keywords you want to
focus on because that's the type of
traffic you want to drive to your site
so some other examples a commercial
intent keywords or discount deal your
coupon shipping you don't don't be
afraid to use some of these keywords and
part of your longer tail keyword phrase
again the volume may not be high but the
traffic quality is probably going to be
better so keyword research is the
foundation for SEO so if you have chosen
your keywords properly then if you do
get ranked for those keywords then it's
going to lead to better engagement with
some conversions and so when we talk
about keywords we also want to talk
about our primary and secondary keyword
so every page should have at least a
primary keyword and then a second carry
keyword to work with so primary keywords
are really defining the nature of your
content the secondary keywords are
relevant to the primary keyword so why
do we choose a primer and secondary
keyword because you may choose a keyword
as a primary keyword that is relevant to
the content but may not necessarily rank
very high or have a lot of volume that's
secondary keyword is also relevant to
the primary keyword but also relevant to
content and you may May rank for that
secondary keyword so you always want to
go with two keywords versus just one
keyword you want to give your yourself a
chance to rank for at least two
different types of keywords of relevant
nature so for web page there can be
several secondary keywords but only one
primary keyword so your primary keyword
is always going to be relevant to your
content secondary keywords can be
relevant to the keyword but and you may
have multiple secondary keywords but
it's also going to be related to the
content and it gives you a better
opportunity to be found between both the
primary and secondary and search Okay so
let's take a look at another example of
how to use primary keywords and
secondary keywords when choosing
keywords so if a primary keyword is
healthy diet plan remember healthy diet
plan is directly related to the content
so that's what we're talking about but
the secondary keywords are also related
to content and play off the primary
keyword and so what we want to do is go
to cool Google's Keyword Planner tool
and get an idea of the volume for
healthy diet plan and then also the
volume and competition for some of these
secondary keywords like healthy diet for
weight loss healthy diet food low carb
diet healthy meal plans and diet plan
weight loss so if I go in to Google's
Keyword Planner and type those keywords
in I'm going to choose get results and
now here I could see healthy diet plan
keyword I'm focusing on is my primary
keyword has an average monthly search
volume of 9900 and then some of my
secondary keywords healthy diet foods
diet plan weight loss low carb diet you
know Google will give me a number of
different keywords to work with so I'm
going to look at the search volume of
those as well and so ideally what I want
to do is be able to then look at the
volume and then look at the competition
so healthy diet plan to go into my
keyword analysis here that's my theme so
that's my keyword what what's my volume
for healthy diet plan nine thousand nine
hundred what's my competition so my
competition is seventy four thousand
seven hundred and that's going to give
me a ratio of volume the competition of
13 so that's what my content's about
that's a considered a short tail keyword
because it has a lot of competition and
so my ratio is 13 and what I want to do
is I want to be able to put these other
secondary keywords in here as well maybe
even go to a little longer tail because
I want to be able to find two key or at
least two keywords I want to be able to
find my primary keyword that's relevant
to my content and then I want to be able
to find my secondary keyword which is
again related to the primary keyword
which is also related to the content and
so I want to be able to choose two
keywords basically and I want to choose
two keywords that are relevant that have
good ratio between volume and
competition so that's the whole idea
again I'm how to do keyword research you
want to be able to find your keywords
use the tools available to you and get a
sense of what the volume is what the
competition is look at the ratio between
the volume and competition and then
based on the content choose that primary
keyword and then again based on the
keyword you chose choose some secondary
keywords as well because you want to be
found for not just one keyword but
multiple keywords okay let's look at
some alternative suggestions to keyword
research so for doing keyword research
we want to take into account LSI
keywords we could take into account
other platforms that host a lot of
content like quora or Reddit we can use
Google suggestions in the keyword search
bar we can use popular platforms like
Wikipedia and we can use social media
bookmarking like Reddit so there are
lots of suggestions that we can obtain
from various sources so let's start with
LSI keywords and LSi stands for latent
semantic Insight indexing and so
basically what it is it's just keywords
that are linked to your primary keyword
and so when you're choosing keywords you
always want to choose that primary
keyword and then secondary keywords that
are similar to the primary keyword and
usually those are LSI or latent semantic
indexing type keywords so they're used
to drive relevant traffic to your page
so if you focus in on one keyword we
want to have other keywords that are
similar to increase our visibility on
the search engine result pages so we
could find latent semantic indexing
right in search so if we use the term
healthy diet if we go to Google search
for example if I type in healthy diet in
Google search all I need to do is scroll
to the bottom of the page and I can see
searches related to healthy diet so
healthy diet menu healthy diet essay
what does a healthy diet look like
notice at the top Google's also given me
some other suggestions here so they're
saying low-fat diet veganism gluten-free
diet so there's lots of different
suggestions right in Google search bar
so all of these are LSI related keywords
so if you're optimizing a page for a
healthy diet then you could choose
low-fat diet as a secondary keyword you
can use gluten-free diet as a secondary
keyword it really depends on what the
content is but you always want to
support your content with as much LSI
keywords as possible so you can be found
for as many different keywords as
possible in Google search so it's
important because if you have a Blog
that you know talks about python so how
do the search engines know if the
website python is about the programming
language or the snake so Google for
example uses LSI keywords to understand
what the page is specifically focusing
on so if you're just focusing on Python
and your content you want to support
that with LSI keywords and so that will
allow your web page to better
communicate with Google also to have the
visibility to show up on search so they
can certainly improve your search
positioning and featured Snippets as
well so if you have a keyword that
answers a question you can certainly
find for feature snippet for example
maybe you know healthy diet recipes if I
type that in you can see here there's a
featured snippet so if I'm talking about
recipes that's a key word I may want to
use and if I use that then Google has an
opportunity to see what my content's
about and place my information at the
top in this featured snippet you can
also again see what some of the
questions are being asked what males are
good for weight loss what is a good
healthy diet plan all of these can be
keyword phrases that you can use so the
answers are right here in Google so core
is a great platform because core is a
platform that people go and ask
questions in a community response with
answers or responses to that particular
question or topic and so the great thing
about core is it's a good eye is a good
place for you to go to get some ideas
about a specific topic so if we're
talking about healthy dieting so we can
find keywords with high search volume
writing quora so the whole idea is you
can look at you know the top five
questions for specific topic like
healthy dieting and find relevant
keywords to healthy dieting so if you
just type in that particular keyword in
quora you're going to probably get some
responses to questions or responses to
somebody else's question and so if we
take a look at core for example so if I
just type in healthy dieting what I'm
going to do is I'm going to get some
responses to the the topic healthy
dieting so what's the best diet for
Healthy Living what are the top five
tips for a healthy diet habit so all of
these could be keyword phrases that you
could take away with for your own
content and so the benefit here is
you're getting kind have an idea of
what's trending what people are talking
about and if you use tips for a healthy
diet habit for example and you optimize
for that well again that could turn
around and bode well for you because you
could be featured in Google as a
featured snippet at the top here you can
also turn around and use LSI related
keywords for healthy diet habits and you
can simply just look for those LSI
keywords right in Google remember at the
bottom or at the Top If I scroll down I
could see some related LSI keywords at
the bottom so writing Google as well you
could see in the Google search bar that
Google provides some LSI related
keywords to your query so if I go back
here and type in healthy diet recipes I
can see here Google's suggesting some
other related keywords healthy diet menu
healthy diet for man healthy diet foods
healthy diet for women so these are all
LSI related keywords that you can use to
support your primary keyword in the the
content you're writing about so we've
talked about LSI keywords where to find
them so they're found right here they
can be found at the top of Google and
they can be found at the bottom you can
also then go to core as well and get
some ideas for the types of questions
they're being asked so if you ask a
question and use that as your keyword
phrase then again you have an
opportunity of showing up for a featured
snippet in Google just by doing some
additional research within Google itself
or on quora so according to Google the
autocomplete predictions are
automatically generated by Google's
algorithm without any human intervention
it's based on a number of factors but
the primary factor is how often past
users have searched for terms so Google
collects all the keyword queries that
somebody types in and they're suggesting
some of the most popular terms that
people have typed in so if I go back to
Google again if I start to type in
recipes I could see some of the other
queries that somebody else has typed in
or some of the most popular queries
relate it to that topic so if you enter
the keyword healthy diet Google's going
to suggest multiple keyword suggestions
that users have asked in the past and
you could certainly get the search
volume of those keywords just by looking
in Google itself I can see for healthy
diet recipes billions of pages related
to healthy diet recipes I can also get
the search volume by going into Google's
Keyword Planner so if I type in healthy
diet I'm going to be able to see what my
search volume is for that keyword and in
addition I can see the seasonality of
that particular keyword and in addition
to that Google is going to provide some
other related keywords to my search
query so if I'm looking for healthy diet
Google's going to suggest hey maybe you
should choose healthy food or healthy
eating or how to lose weight so those
are LSI related keywords that Google
provides in the keyword plan which is
built into the Google ads platform
another option for you is Wikipedia so
Wikipedia is a vast platform of content
so we could turn Wikipedia into our own
assets and use it to our own Advantage
by finding relevant keywords in an easy
fashion so with Wikipedia we can
identify a list of keywords in The Meta
description itself we could choose
keywords from the first paragraph of
Wikipedia that has many relevant
keywords or we could take a look at
keywords from the Wikipedia content
section so we can also see additional
Pages like the see also section that
gives relevant keywords that you're
looking for we can also look at the
references section as they contain
relevant keywords so go to Wikipedia as
an example and I type in healthy diet
into Wikipedia here I can get just in
the first paragraph alone I can see some
additional keywords that I might choose
to use like micronutrients I never knew
that micronutrients was related to
healthy diet but Wikipedia is providing
some information about what
micronutrients is and maybe I can use
that as a keyword an LSI related keyword
to my content so if I scroll down I get
to see also section so it might give me
some information food information
consumers for example dietary guidelines
I can look at categories like dietetics
and diets I can also look at the
references section so I can also see
what information was provided like
health effects of overweight and obesity
I can look at diet and physical activity
so all of these are related to my main
keyword healthy diet so the answers are
right in here on the platform they're
just all over the page so Wikipedia has
an abundance of information you just
need to know where to look so again with
Wikipedia you can look no further than
the first paragraph you look no further
than the see also section the references
section category section there's lots of
information right on the page itself to
help you get ideas for keywords so if
you Google your keyword with Wikipedia
term in the search query and get
relevant keywords from the title tags in
the search so you can also do that as
well so if I type in healthy diet
Wikipedia and search I can also get some
information here as well so people also
search for healthy food advantages or
healthy food habits essay or information
about healthy food all of these are
related to my keyword healthy diet so
again another bit of information for you
to choose or look to choose some
additional keywords for so Reddit it's a
popular Community where people post
content and discuss a variety of topics
so that's what Reddit is so with the
help of subreddits an individual can
find relevant keywords with with high
search volume so in Reddit there's an
easy way to find out keywords they have
a keyword tool called keyword it so the
keyword it gives the average monthly
searches for a particular keyword so if
we type a Word in key Reddit and choose
keywords from the auto generator list
this tool will extract the keywords and
give us those relevant terms with search
volumes so if we go to the keyword it
and Show an example of that for example
healthy food if I get keywords I can see
what keywords are relevant in the search
volume of that keyword so if I just type
in healthy food keyword tool is going to
tell me some relevant keywords and what
the volume is so if you don't have the
Keyword Planner tool in Google ads
available to you this is a good
alternative solution to finding keywords
so it's free you just need to go to
keyword.com type in your keyword click
get keywords and what it's going to do
is give you some relevant keywords
related to your primary keyword with the
search volume let's talk about keyword
clustering now so the whole idea about
keyword clustering is to really take
advantage of the keywords that we're up
optimizing for to gain higher ranking so
if we can cluster keywords together in a
theme and that theme of keywords is
relevant to a specific page of a website
then we have a better opportunity to
rank so in other words why do we have to
Target just one keyword when we can
Target many so keep in mind you know LSI
keywords we want to group a bunch of
keywords together that are similar for
Content so for example after some
keyword research you can thematically
group keywords into a core topic so for
example we can cluster these group of
keywords together like for example what
is SEO how does SEO work intro to SEO
what are the basics of SEO all of those
are related to the chord theme what is
SEO another cluster of keywords for
example could be SEO techniques SEO best
practices tips and tricks website
optimization on-page SEO techniques Etc
so those are clusters of keywords okay
that we can group together in theme
games and if we group keywords together
in themes we can apply that to a
particular content on our website so the
whole idea behind clustering keywords
it's going to provide more diversity
more of an opportunity for us to be
found so that's the whole idea behind
clustering so some additional steps
remember stay up to date on industry
news to brainstorm your ideas first and
identify a list of keywords like a thema
keywords that you can cluster together
and then you could determine the
keywords that your competitors are
already ranking for so for example if we
want to rank for the keyword SEO best
practices for example we can use a tool
called keyword Moz if I go to keyword
the keyword Explorer tool and Moz and
just type in SEO best practices what
it's going to do is it's going to give
me some volume related to that
particular keyword but more importantly
what it's also going to do is it's going
to show me me what pages are already
ranked for that particular keyword so
therefore I can get a sense of who is
already ranking for that keyword so here
I can see Moz Moz medium.com alexa.com
so I can get a sense of what web pages
are ranked for a particular keyword or
group of keywords I want to rank for
myself so if we look at tools for
keyword research look no further than
Moz that's the mods of the tool I would
just choose but you could also use
Google's Keyword Planner which we used
in the example so for example if I go
back to the Google ads Keyword Planner
if you're in Google ads you click on
tools you click on Cleveland planner and
what Keyword Planner does is it provides
you for a particular keyword the average
monthly search volume of the past 12
months it provides you information on
seasonality so if I hover my mouse over
a graph I'm going to be able to see the
volume per month over the last 12 months
what the Keyword Planner also does does
is it provides me some additional ideas
for my particular keyword and in
addition to that it's going to provide
me some sense of how competitive that
keyword is by telling me whether it's
low medium or high in terms of
competition so there's sem Raj there's
also other additional keywords tools out
there like word stream or href or the
Reddit tool keyword it and then Moz is a
is another tool I particularly use so if
I go to Moz again here I can just type
in a keyword that I'm interested in it's
going to give me the search volume of
that keyword it's going to give me the
level of difficulty so 50 out of 100 so
it's halfway between difficulty and easy
and then it's going to give me some
additional metrics like for example what
my expected organic click-through rate
would be if I were to rank for this
keyword but more importantly what I like
about this is we could see exactly what
other sites are linked to this
particular key word we're interested in
so here I can look at the top 10 list so
this is mozz's keyword Explorer tool so
that's what this tool is and it's part
of moz.com so there's a lot of tools at
your disposal I particularly use Moz I
particularly use Google's Keyword
Planner and those are the tools I use
but there are lots of tools out there if
you are looking to become an SEO
professional then look no further than
simply runs postgraduate program in
digital marketing so don't miss out on
this opportunity Find the course Link in
the description for more information
on-page optimization as the name
suggests is the practice of optimizing
web pages to rank higher and get
relevant traffic from the search engine
on-page optimization includes both
content and HTML source code
optimization search engine optimization
can be very complex so when you're
trying to understand it for the first
time I find it very easy just to break
it up into general concepts that you
might already have an understanding of
when you look at the hundreds of signals
that go into SEO they can be broken up
into either relevancy or because
sometimes it's both popularity so
relevancy and popularity out of all
these signals they fit into one of these
two things we're going to break all the
signals we have into these two areas in
this section we're going to talk about
the on-page factors that's because these
are the factors that you have direct
impact upon and you can make a small
tweak and have a big impact with Organic
traffic with your on-page relevancy
factors the primary on-page relevancy
factors that I'll cover in this lesson
are title tags and meta description
header tags which are used for headlines
and subheadings website URLs and URL
structure image alt text internal links
keyword usage and sitemaps
let's start with one of my favorites and
that is the title tag this is also
called a page title the page title is
not shown on the page now rather it is
displayed on the browser Tab and this is
what makes it highly important is that
in addition to being displayed on the
browser tab it is also the title tag or
the page title that is shown on the text
in the Google search results as the link
to the page
the page title influences both the
click-through rates and people's first
impressions of our website
next up we have the meta description
Now The Meta description can be a bit
confusing
The Meta description is in the code and
it does not influence rankings
but it does influence clicks
people will see your snippet or your
page information in the search engine
results
that gray text is the meta description
if you don't have a meta description
then it may pull information from the
page
you can affect this and improve the
chances of your meta description
appearing if you write a short
descriptive phrase of the content or the
purpose of the page
and just because we edit these elements
does not guarantee that they will show
up I often say that we affect the change
but we cannot control it
this is because the search engine May
override your changes and show different
content in these areas
sometimes it may help and it might be a
better description but many times it's
not
now let's go to the next element the
header tags these are also referred to
as the heading and subheading
and this is how HTML was built when the
web was first created
it enables a logical hierarchy of
content
so starting with the headline then
displaying a subheading and then
subheadings after that
the idea here is that you're
establishing a hierarchy of information
so you start with the H1 like a
newspaper there's only one main headline
per page
it describes the main purpose of the
page
then a subheading the H2 this is how you
break the sub content into sub
categories obviously you'll want to use
a keyword in there as well
you see by describing the purpose of the
page in the headline and then again in a
subheading you're naturally going to use
your primary and secondary keywords
because you're going to associate them
with the product or the purpose and the
benefit
the key is to keep it short
you see after the headline are the
subcategories the H2S and then your H3
is typically used as a paragraph heading
now putting the keyword in these
headings alone does not make your page
optimized remember the purpose is to
provide a quick reference for people to
find the content they need within
seconds
so short explanatory heading and
subheadings paragraph headings are very
effective
and naturally you'll be using keywords
to help people locate the information
that is most important to them
now if we go back to the search engine
results page the serp there is another
element in that listing the page title
is the large Blue text The Meta
description is the gray text now the
green text is the URL of the page that
is listed this is the address of the
page just like the address for your home
the internet knows that the URL is the
address for that page this is extremely
important for SEO for a variety of
reasons the most important though is
your keyword usage I like to make sure
that I have at least one Relevant Word
in the URL now also here keep it short
one of the worst things you can do is
have a URL full of keywords or even
worse hyphenate them all remember people
use these urls
they provide context for the page people
also copy and paste URLs into Mobile
messages emails and Social Links so it
is extremely important to keep these
short succinct and I like to say
readable
now I've just briefly touched about the
importance of the URL and now let's look
at the URL structure
first let's start with the primary core
of the URL the domain name
in the example with the URL I have here
example.com that's the domain name so
this is the first thing that people see
with your online business
now
be on the internet this is going to be
what's in all of your ads emails
brochures business cards and online your
social profiles all of your marketing
efforts are going to drive people to
this domain there's a lot of advice
about buying or using domains that have
your keywords in them and unfortunately
domains have been being sold for decades
so there's less chance of finding a
domain with the keywords you want now
the search engines don't make the
keyword used in the domain a primary
ranking signal so that's good however
the domain is your business it needs to
be memorable if you have a very I call
it a spammy looking domain name with
multiple words and hyphens or one that's
hard to spell or confusing people are
going to make an initial impression off
of that so make sure you have something
that's going to make a great first
impression here's the rule for a domain
name something that's easy to spell and
easy to pronounce ideally sure it's
something you can type and share
something thing you're going to be able
to put on a business card and be proud
of not something that you bought
primarily because you want it for SEO
reasons and you think with that you're
going to succeed as an example just
think about Amazon their domain name
says nothing about books and yet it grew
to be one of the largest e-commerce
companies in the world the same with
Alibaba or Google their domain names
were not the keyword but their marketing
and branding built their company now
everything after the domain is a
subdirectory this is based on your
website organization as an example if
you have a website selling shoes then
the subdirectory can be called shoes
it's easy right the sub directory is the
folder that contains the relevant files
or Pages for that group think of a file
folder with documents inside the file
folder is usually based on a major
category of content or products now
inside the folder are individual
documents or Pages these files or Pages
usually come after the subdirectory in
this example you see the file.html the
next step in optimizing the URL is to
name the page in a way that explains the
content of the page to use our
e-commerce shoe website a page name
would usually be a specific product name
this way you would end up with domain
name forward slash shoes as the category
forward slash brand name running shoe
insert that here
if you've ever looked at the HTML that
make up the instructions of the page
you'll understand a bit more of how
search engines get the information from
the page the text on the page and the
markup such as the headings provide
instructions as to where the text is
located the importance and prominence of
the text in addition to the arrangement
of the overall page HTML is a set of
instructions for a browser to assemble
the page and the search engines use that
as well now the search engines spiders
cannot see images as the internet
developed many attributes were added to
provide for accessibility and additional
features users that are site impaired
cannot see images
and the alternative text tag describes
the image
further there are many times when our
bandwidth isn't strong and not all of
the images will load in that case we
need the alt text description to provide
the context of the image and its purpose
search engines use this alt text
description to gain additional context
about the page the content of the image
and its purpose now we have an entire
section on links but at this point I
just want to cover internal links an
internal link is a link from one page on
your website to another page of your own
website now this is important from a
relevancy perspective you'll see
internal links in your main navigation
you'll likely have a link that says home
one that says contact us or about our
company
what you're showing to search engines
and to humans is that this section if
you click on this link is about our
company or this is where you find our
contact information
you see these links are not votes like
external links
however they provide relevance and
context to the information on your own
website
let's dive in a little more on keywords
when a search engine crawls and
processes your website it doesn't simply
look for the instances of specific
keywords
it's a lot more complex than that
it's using a technology called natural
language processing
natural language processing uses
algorithms to try to understand the
meaning of text
you see search engine processing is
attempting to be human
this is the same way that people see and
hear the words and we're using the words
to find the meaning expressed in the
words
similarly when a search engine goes to
your website it may see keywords but
it's looking for the context of those
words
you may say football but just having the
word football repeated throughout your
website isn't going to help you rank
specifically for football
what you need to do and what is more
common in actual human conversation
happens very naturally
when we talk about football we use
naturally additional words such as goal
and referee and World Cup you see Google
and the other search engines are going
to take these into account
by usage of other synonyms and other
common words you present the context of
a bigger broader idea for your website
the next site signal that we have is
sitemaps now there are two kinds of site
Maps
there's the site map that is for humans
and there is the site map that are for
search engine robots crawlers or spiders
the one that is for human is called an
HTML sitemap you've probably seen these
before the link is generally in the
footer of a website if you click on it
it shows you the major sections of the
website provide some search
functionality but looking at it as a
human it shows you the hierarchy of the
website and where to find important
information
it shows how everything fits together
now there's something else that exists
called an XML sitemap
it's not linked from any page of your
website but exists as an independent
file on your server
now this is something you can see but it
is formatted for search engine spiders
using a programming language called XML
it shows the hierarchy and the priority
of each of the URLs of the website every
page every document every image and it
also shows the date that each page was
last updated or changed
so at this point we've covered a lot of
things that are important and things
that you should be doing when optimizing
your on-page content
now let's go a different direction and
cover things that you should not be
doing keyword stuffing hidden text
repetitive anchor text and cloaking the
first one is keyword stuffing now back
in the early days of search engine
optimization
people used to increase the instances of
words on the page now this is well
before natural language processing at
that time search engines were looking
for occurrences of specific words well
search engines they're very smart about
this
what may have worked 20 years ago or 10
years ago keyword stuffing does not work
you're not going to rank better for any
given phrase by including it a dozen or
more times on the page in fact you might
get an over optimization penalty by
constantly repeating the same word over
and over focus on writing content that
engages with your visitors and uses
language naturally now the next one is
hidden text unfortunately I still see
this this is when you write content that
is solely for search engines and not for
people now typically it is attempted by
writing a lot of repetitive keywords as
text coloring it white and placing it
against a white background
see this was developed as another way to
add more keyword stuff text without the
user seeing the overuse of keywords now
it didn't work too well in the past and
it definitely does not work today this
tactic backfires in two ways first
search engines can tell when it's white
text on a white background it's easy to
tell from a computer science point of
view
search engines read the HTML and in the
HTML are the instructions for colors
when you hide text modern search engines
are smart enough to figure it out
probably better than a human now
secondly it's done to hide repetitive
keyword stuff text which is the second
thing against you these outdated
unprofessional tactics will most likely
get a website penalized by the search
engines the next one is repetitive
anchor text
you may have followed a link to a page
when looking for a business or
information and instead of the
information you want you get a page that
doesn't feel like it was written for
people
every sentence is redundant repetitive
and almost every keyword is linked even
when there doesn't need to be a link
it confuses the flow of the information
on the page now again this used to be a
tactic that sometimes would work but
it's no longer helpful
search engines and their natural
language processing algorithms have
advanced significantly they can tell
when something's not readable when
something is probably intended for
machines and rankings but not for people
search engines will figure it out please
don't waste time on redundant links
trying to inflate the relevance of your
links and Pages the last thing to cover
here is cloaking cloaking is the idea of
showing one thing to the search engines
and something entirely different to
humans now this is related to the rest
of the tactics I just covered it's
something that used to work but it was
expressly against the search engine
guidelines while it may have worked if
the search engine is discovered it on
your website you could have been
penalized or dropped from the search
engine results entirely now we've
covered all of the most important
on-page optimization factors let's take
a look at what the theoretically
perfectly optimized page would look like
in this example we can see many of these
elements being used together you can
also see that the base key phrase
digital camera is being repeated but
always included with a specific contact
next first at the top of the page is the
URL which has digital cameras in the
address
the page title follows using the context
of the information and adding the word
reviews you can also see at the top of
the page that the main navigation and
secondary navigation also called the
breadcrumb navigation provides context
of the Page's location within the entire
website and natural keyword usage
the H1 headline is the key phrase but
also happens to simply be the best title
for the content of the page
the subsequent subheadings provide
additional information such as ratings
recommendations and features
the links provide relevant ways to
access additional content
the image utilizes alt text there are
also clear calls to action which provide
relevant offers to visitors
as you can see the context of all of the
content is very strong and sends a clear
relevancy signal to both search engines
and readers
to conclude this section I'd like to
cover the top influencing factors
now sometimes you may find these as
lists but I found it a bit more
practical to separate them into
categories
typically every year you'll find these
collections of lists from surveys
experts or speculation
some are from testing but honestly you
can't ever truly test a search engine as
they change a little bit with every
algorithm
so the best thing is to take from these
lists these factors that are the tried
and true factors over the years that
have worked consistently
also those tactics that not only make
your website more effective with users
they tend to do well with search engines
so if a tactic serves that Dual Purpose
it's a good tactic
so these are not exclusive and have to
lists for every situation but guides and
indicators for you to use the top
on-page factors from surveys opinions
and data are these
a relevant page title page headings
anchor text links a keyword-based URL
a keyword or contextual file name such
as page name image name or PDF file name
alt text and images and finally what you
do with the content on a page to make it
more readable lists bullet points and
bolded text
the top factors for off-page linking
tend to contain these items
the total number of domains linking to
you
the number of Highly influential domains
linking to you
the number of unique domain IP addresses
the total backlinks without no follow
limits
the total relevant anchor text in links
to you
and finally the types and context of
keywords in Anchor text links
the domain also contributes factors to
your overall rankings such as the age of
the domain which would include ownership
information such as the length of time
owned and operated by a company
the real business information tied to
that domain such as the business address
being the same as the business
registration address for the domain
in addition the signals from social
accounts driving visits to the domain
functionally the search engines also
utilize some attribution based on the
quality of programming of the website
for instance taking care of the basic
search engine Protocols of the
robots.txt file XML sitemap and https
protocol
websites that Implement these features
have shown that they are familiar with
search engine guidelines and protocol
now one of the changes over the past few
years has been the implementation of
page speed as an increasing ranking
Factor
slow loading pages with a lot of
extraneous code that slowed the delivery
of the page will be penalized as they
take away from the user experience
optimizing the page code speeding up the
load time of the page can directly
impact your rankings and this is closely
related to the mobile friendliness of
your website
if your website is not mobile friendly
it will be limited in visibility as
Google's primary index is focused on
mobile devices and mobile delivery
behavioral factors are the newest
factors and with the Advent of
artificial intelligence it is making
determining the intent and the is making
determining easier
for a search engine to derive a judgment
of relevancy based on interaction
while the extent of these signals is not
fully known it is suspected that they
are minor but growing in importance
these include the amount of users that
search for a brand name business's name
and go to that result showing brand
awareness
also the amount of direct visits
bypassing search
time on page pages per session which is
also called the depth of visit
and lastly the behavior of a Searcher
from the results page how many results
are clicked how many times do they
return to the results this evaluation is
looking to judge if the results
presented were satisfactory or deficient
for that query
in the section on on-page optimization
we talked about factors that centered on
relevancy in this section we're going to
go in a different direction we're going
to talk about the signals that focus on
popularity so what does popularity mean
in this context well it's actually quite
simple popularity always relates to
links to hyperlinks on the web so you
have seen these when you see the
typically blue text that is underlined
what this is is a tool it's a ahref
technically in HTML that is pointing
from one web document to a different one
this is a pretty simple concept I
imagine you already know this
so what does this mean from an SEO
perspective well it turns out that this
gigantic group of signals the ones
related to hyperlinks are and are and
historically have been the Lion's Share
of signals that the search engines
process when trying to rank pages
now there's one big problem with these
from an SEO perspective is that they are
historically and today very difficult to
influence this is because they do not
take place on your website they take
place elsewhere it's other people who
are linking to you generally speaking
and this makes them very very difficult
to have an influence on so this is a
good thing and a bad thing it's a good
thing because it it turns out to be a
great metric for ranking web documents
it's a bad thing because it's hard for
us to make an impact on day-to-day level
hands down the most time consuming and
difficult part of SEO is link building
now there's a lot of reasons for this
primarily because it's constantly
changing and because of all the elements
that are involved with this but the big
the bigger takeaway here is that there's
no one-size-fits-all solution for link
building you have to take the context of
your business of your website and you
have to apply general principles to that
so in this video we're going to cover
these general principles so you can
figure out how to apply those to your
business
these principles are and I think these
are the most clever and the most
important ones are creating link worthy
content
proactively participate in an off-site
engagement and utilizing offline
relationships the tried and true method
for building links is creating content
that's optimized for humans so let me
explain what this means the currency of
the internet if you will is the content
itself that's why people go on they want
to read the newest article or they want
to see the newest video whatever it may
be that is what has been true since the
beginning and I have no doubt will be
true going forward so as an SEO or as an
online marketer in general you can use
this to your advantage creating the
content that people are going to want to
share with their friends or that they're
going to want to cite in any kind of
paper or whatever they're working on
that is a tried and true way of gaining
links this is what we call the power of
content you can do all kinds of bells
and whistles you can go do these newest
tactics you can try all these different
things out but at the end of the day
what's really important is the content
itself
so this is what I focus on this is where
80 of my time goes on when I'm working
on link building it's on the content
itself can I create something that is
just truly that is so truly great that
someone essentially has to link to it
this is what I focus on trying to answer
and while there is no simple answer to
that go in asking that question always
sets you in the right direction
the next strategy that I want to talk
about is actually very counter-intuitive
so if you're trying to build links to
your own website I found one of the most
effective ways and this is consistently
true is to engage off your own site now
this doesn't make any sense right why
would you work on other people's
websites if you're trying to promote
your yourself well think about human
beings human beings are much more likely
to link and give back to people to human
beings that they know well so a lot of
the time I spend when I'm doing link
building is spent off-site engaging with
others so sometimes this is through
social media so I'll use whatever the
latest social network is and I'll chat
with people there who have similar
interests or have similar interests to
what I'm trying to promote be it a
different topic or be it a new industry
all together I'll spend a lot of time
promoting others and a lot of times
chatting with other people building up
genuine real relationships with human
beings so that when it comes time for
them to write an article or when it's
when they're ready to link out to other
people I'm the first person they think
too and they link back to my website one
of the reasons that link building is so
hard is because the internet moves so
fast what worked yesterday might not
work tomorrow
so one of the most clever and easy ways
to avoid this problem is to just simply
go offline utilize some of the
relationships that you have off of the
internet in order to benefit on the
internet this is something I try to do
all the time because it consistently
works by far the easiest favors to cash
in on are the ones that you already owed
so these might be from your friends who
you work with who might be from friends
who from childhood these are people who
you actually know in the real world who
are much more likely to help you when
you're trying to promote new content
online
so what I'm trying to do link building
one of the things I focus on is people
that I know in the real world
so this can be lots of things this can
be personal friends who happen to have
websites and blogs this can be friendly
competition you have or friendly allies
you have in your space just saying hey
we're looking for these kind of things
can you help us out maybe I'll help you
out somewhere else it's utilizing these
relationships that Exist Elsewhere so
that you can start gaining these links
yourself
if that doesn't work if maybe you don't
have any friends in these Arenas you can
always go to local businesses and local
agencies so sometimes this is a
government-owned thing sometimes this is
just third parties all together
there's lots of things that they need
help with that you as a business owner
or you as uh trying to promote some
client may be able to help them with and
if you can help them offline they're
more much more likely to help you online
well link building it's very important
to understand that not all links are are
created equally a link coming from the
home page of CNN is going to provide a
lot of what we call link Equity it's
going to have a lot of popularity
metrics tied to it and so it's going to
be more valuable to you and help you
rank higher whereas a link also coming
from the home page but let's say Joe
schmo's spam blog that is not going to
be particularly helpful for you and it
actually in some cases could hurt you so
when you're going out and doing link
building make sure that you can stand
behind the source of the link that is
coming at you this could be in a good
example from like a government website
where it's trusted and a bad example
this could be from a website that you
would not normally go to even on your
own
in addition to that there's different
kinds of links depending on the
direction that they're going so if a
link is coming towards you towards your
website that's called an inbound link
these are the ones that are very helpful
for popularity metrics that we've talked
about
there's also outbound links these are
links that you linking to other people
now generally there's a big
misconception about this that you'd
think you would not want to link out to
other people but if you just follow the
natural chain of events and you look at
people who are writing blogs without SEO
in mind you'll see that they are linking
out naturally and it's these natural
patterns that search engines are looking
for so there's absolutely no problem in
linking out just as long as it's two
sources that you actually do trust so
there's inbound links there's outbound
links there's links that have a lot of
popularity value so like from an
established Government website or from
something popular like CNN there's also
links that are inbound that are not
going to have as much value for you that
you probably don't want to spend your
time building now regardless of where
your links are coming from it's
important to look out for one particular
attribute it's called Rel nofollow Rel
no follow was a tool that was originally
developed to combat comment spam like on
blogs you'd have lots of people who are
leaving
completely irrelevant comments so they
could link back to their own website and
get credit for that that does not work
at all today one of the primary reasons
for that is the search engine introduced
something called Rel nofollow where they
said here's a link that's going out for
my website but do not stand behind it
and it does not pass any credit a lot of
times when you're doing leak building
you'll get a link which you're very
proud of coming from somewhere very
popular but then realize that it has
this attribute attached to it no follow
and which means you will not get any
credit for it so make sure that when
you're doing your leak building the link
coming at you that you've earned does
not have this attribute associated with
it otherwise you will get no credit for
it now that you understand what nofollow
is let's let's talk about the biggest
use case for this social media most of
the links that we see in social media
are valueless this is because they're
either hidden from search engines
entirely this mostly happens on Facebook
or they're visible to search engines but
they use this row this Rel nofollow
attribute which means that they're
useless so while social media does have
many many benefits SEO and particularly
link value from SEO is not one of the
direct benefits of participating in
social media now that we've covered some
of the link building dues let's talk
about some of the link building don'ts
so these are things that you should not
do because you'll be wasting your time
and possibly more importantly your money
the first one is Spam so we have all
seen this online when you go somewhere
and you see just a bunch of spammy links
links that are clearly written only for
machines only for search engines a lot
of times these will have the name of
pharmaceutical drugs on them a lot of
times they'll have just can be
completely irrelevant to the content
while these have worked in some
instances they are certainly not a best
practice and they are certainly not a
long-term strategy so I never recommend
trying to invest in spammy links this
way because it's not going to ultimately
help you in fact in many ways it'll
probably hurt you so do not go out of
your way to try to get spammy links
the next one is buying links this is
these are toes closely tied together now
buying links is when you go out and try
to buy sometimes relevant sometimes
irrelevant links and again this is
something that had it worked sometimes
historically not always my biggest
problem with this is not so much the
ethical problem although there is one
there the search engines have Clues said
not to ever do this my biggest problem
with it is that you could not calculate
an accurate Roi on this so if you spend
a dollar on this you don't know if
you're gonna make a dollar or two
dollars back you have no idea there's no
way to accurately measure this so you
have no idea if this if this is valuable
to you or not
where as opposed to if you're creating
valuable content you can measure that
and you can directly tie it to Sales so
your your money dollar for dollar is
spent much much more effectively on
content than it is on buying links so I
highly recommend do not spend your time
or your money buying links
the last one is acquiring reciprocal
links so reciprocal links as you can
imagine are links that go in a circle
you link to somebody and they link
directly back to you now in the natural
web when no marketing is taken to place
into this there's no kind of
manipulation trying to go on that
happens that happens all the time so
don't go out of your way and be afraid
of this happening so one new site will
very regularly link to another news
article and that article might link back
to them somewhere else that happens so
don't stress about this too much but
don't go out of your way to try to build
all of your links in a reciprocal way
we're overthinking this by trying to
link to somebody else who links to a
third party that third party links to
you don't waste your time this is just
not a factor that you should worry about
reciprocal links are not generally as
good as one-way links but it happens so
often that is not is not worthy of your
time or any kind of investment trying to
avoid this
concept of linking is foundational to
good rankings and understanding the
internet at Large
it starts with the premise that good
content will be cited by others
recommending it to other people
how we cite and recommend information
online is by linking to it
we link to information that we find
valuable
based on that the search engines assess
content by how websites link to one
another
so we are going to cover the definition
and purpose of links and the different
functions that links serve
we'll also look at how links mirror
human judgment
we'll look at how search engines
evaluate links by mirroring human
judgment
and how that affects what's called Block
Level analysis
and how where the location of different
links and how they are used will greatly
affect their relevance
we're going to look at how visitors from
different link sources will behave
differently based on where they came
from
and also how you can measure the
effectiveness of links and finally we're
going to look at both good and bad
linking practices now links serve a
number of purposes
from a functional standpoint they
usually are our primary means of
navigation online we click on links we
go to different pages and from those
pages we find links to other pages
links are also a method of citing other
content
when we quote somebody when we use
information that we have found somewhere
else we cite that information to give
credit to the original author typically
online we do that with a link so that if
someone wants to see the original Source
document it's available to them that
also helps to provide credibility to you
credibility to the author of the
original source as well as assigning
importance to the knowledge that came
from that original source and the
authority of the original source
links also provide us with a clear
structure of how our websites are built
how the pages relate to one another and
how organized the information can be
so let's break down the functional part
of a link
this is important if you're going to be
developing anchor text and linking to
understand the structure
the ahref equals is the start of the
link tag
what you are doing is developing the
reference of where the document is
contained that's the href reference is
what it is short for
what comes next within the quotes is the
location of the document now this can be
a full URL or you may just be linking to
a document that's on the main root level
of your server
this is the full location where you can
access the document
and so you're putting the name of the
document the extension so that it will
be linked
the next part is what I have in caps
you'll notice off to the left I have
something in all blue text and
underlined which most people will
recognize as a link
you see when it is in between the
document location
and the closing of the link tag the text
you have in there is what's called
anchor text
you see instead of publishing the
document location in the full URL of the
document
we can put the link within text and
create anchor text so all someone has to
do is click on the link and the document
loads for them
this anchor text is vitally important to
understanding how we can add additional
relevance to linking content
then we see the closure of the link tag
this is what makes the internet the
internet is millions of pages connected
together by Links
so when we look at the functional side
of links and we look at this example
here as you can see the title of this
article is not the URL address of the
article it's a title and the title is
the link that is the anchor text of the
link
and so from a search engine standpoint
search engines look to see what words
are being used in the link and how
relevant those words are to the document
that is being linked
it also looks to see where is the link
is it in the editorial information in
the article
is it part of the navigation
is it in a sidebar or is it an ad
and then also search engines are looking
to see if this is a text link or an
image link
how long has that link been there
what type of link is it does it go
somewhere within your website does it go
to another website or is it a reciprocal
link which I will explain more later
they also look to see the text in the
link and the context to the page with
the link directs you to
we utilize links a little differently
you see from a human standpoint whenever
we refer information to another person
when we provide reference material to
another person or even if someone asks
us for a recommendation we provide this
information
you see offline we mirror the same
behavior as we do online when we link
people ask us for information and we
provide it
we just mirror that online by making a
link
offline we recommend we refer we provide
information to each other in much the
same way the way I want you to think
about it from a human standpoint is that
if you asked another person for advice
or directions or a referral
are there certain people that you would
trust more than others
I'm sure the answer to that is yes and
maybe you have some people in mind that
you are thinking about
you see we run across the same issue
with search
the search engines know that there are
some websites that are much more
trustworthy than others
just like if you were to ask someone for
information I'm sure you would ask the
right person
for the information you would ask the
most knowledgeable trustworthy person
you knew
who had Authority in that subject area
the search engines are trying to do the
same thing with the links that we
publish on our websites they're trying
to determine who is the most trustworthy
and relevant based on the
recommendations referrals and citations
of other websites to other websites
who are the websites that are trusted
that are authorities
the search engines are trying to do from
a technical algorithmic standpoint what
we do naturally from a human standpoint
now from The Human Side as I had said
before we need to think of links as
information that we receive from other
people
Word of Mouth advice information
directions recommendations this is where
we need to think about links not from
the standpoint of building false
relevance for a search engine
but being a helpful resource for our
readers how can we help them how can we
provide information and how can we be a
credible source of information
how can we develop our Authority within
the industry and so that people who have
questions about this content will see
our websites as authoritative and
credible resources
the best way to develop links as you'll
see is good content when people like
what they read when they like what they
see when they are willing to recommend
it to others it's because you have
created something of value
and they'll link to you when they feel
that you are credible
and that you are authoritative with this
information
only then will they share it with other
people
because you have earned that right for
them to share it with others by
providing content that is informative
educational
entertaining and you've provided that
service only then will people then want
to recommend it to others by linking to
it
now links serve a number of benefits
When I look at some of the incoming
links to my site one of the things I
notice is that if I get a link in
certain places that can drive a lot of
brand exposure I can have thousands of
people coming to the site looking to see
an article and that provides a lot of
exposure to a lot of people
however also getting a link from a
certain website especially if it's a
high relevant authoritative website I
can see my rankings increase because of
that
but then also a good link is going to
drive people that will convert and drive
sales or leads those who become
customers
so those are the three aspects of a good
link a good link will drive traffic to
your site a good link will assist your
rankings
and a good link will bring in business
if you can get a link to do all three of
those at the same time that's what I
call the golden link because it has all
three benefits
usually however you're going to find
that different links will provide
different types of benefits one of these
three or maybe two out of these three
one of the things I'm usually very
focused on is the link that drives sales
or generates leads that's getting links
in the right place that will benefit me
tangibly rather than just getting
thousands of people to see it
why it benefits me financially if I can
get a link in the right place
so from here let's break down the
different types of links
we have navigational links we see these
in our navigation our primary navigation
maybe the footer of our web pages where
we have links to typical information
such as about us or contact us
we also have sidebar links this might be
related information or offers or calls
to action
and then also I would break it down into
outbound or inbound type of navigation
outbound are links going to other
websites inbound links are links that
come from other websites and that also I
might send to other pages on my own site
now I've used the term editorial an
editorial link is a link that is found
within the content of the website
and by that I mean through an article
so if I am writing an article and I link
to someone else and cite them or
reference them
that is what's called an editorial link
it means that it's part of the content
a great example of this is that the
navigation on your web pages is not part
of the content
it serves a function as navigation
but it doesn't have anything to do with
supporting information with citing an
authority so information and links that
you put within the content and presented
content of your site are considered
editorial
now there's also call to action links
where you're bringing someone to a
landing page or a registration page or a
sale page
then also we have Social Links now these
can provide a variety of means but
typically a social link will go to a
profile
maybe it's a username that takes you
somewhere else or comment or maybe just
an image or something that goes to a
social site or that you have placed on
your own site as well
either way it's all contained within
that social network even though the
links are going on and off your site
they tend to be controlled in that
social environment
now I've used the term reciprocal link
now this is
something very specific
a reciprocal link is one where you would
go to somebody else and you would make a
trade such as if you link to me I'll
link to you and maybe you put those
links on the home page or maybe you
create a page just for that link
you see sometimes it just doesn't make
sense and so the search engines will see
that you've linked to each other but if
there's no contextual relevance if
there's no contextual relevance
most likely you won't get any benefit
because you've agreed to link to each
other for the primary purpose of
boosting rankings
now this is not to say that two websites
can't link to each other because there
is some relevance
we'll look at some examples of that
later on in this module
also then we have advertising links
these can be ads banners anything on the
page that is an advertising link that if
you were to click on it you would go to
that advertisers page
those links are typically through an ad
server and they take place in entirely
different ecosystem
but they are links and we need to know
what kind of links are advertising and
which kind of links are functional to
our websites
now when I broke down the different
types of links so we have our navigation
links we have links in our sidebar and
in our footer
with Block Level analysis does is that
the search engines look at the code of
the page
they break down the page because it's
very easy to figure out which part of
the code has to do with your navigation
which part of the code has to do with
your sidebar and your footer and which
part of the code is calling ads from an
ad server what this leaves is the
editorial content your article and the
ability of search engines then to break
down your page into these different
elements the reason why they do it is
that the links contained in the
editorial space are considered to be
more relevant in terms of linking to
other websites than any of the other
types of links on your web page search
engines don't consider all parts of the
page to be equally relevant which is
okay because neither do humans we look
at the navigation as utilization pure
utility because it's just helping me
navigate among the different pages of
your website I'm not expecting to learn
anything I'm using it as a functional
means of navigating your site now your
sidebar might have some calls to action
it might have links to other pages but
it's not an article it's what you've
developed and so it might be a little
more important than your navigation but
it's not as important as what you may
have written within content your footer
navigation is basically the same you
control that it's the same on every page
and so what the search engines are
looking for are the unique content
the unique article or information that
you've published and if there is a link
within the editorial content that is
highly relevant because it has to do
with content it has to do with
information that you are sharing
and so the links there are going to be
more highly relevant and are going to be
more important for the search engines to
see
you see it's the same way with humans
we're not going to look at navigation to
learn something it's functional the same
thing with the footer and as humans
we're reading the content that you have
in your article and if you link to
another source well you've provided us
with utility but it's contextual utility
because you're citing where you found
information or you're citing an
additional Source or you are linking to
an example and it enables me as a human
to see that understand it and if I need
that additional information I can click
on it and go to it
so I'm going to look at the information
on the page in that article very
differently that I'm going to look at
the headings the navigation the sidebars
or the footer because the article is
what is informing me and so the links in
the article I'm going to look at very
differently and hold them in a higher
level of relevance
now over time search engines have had to
refine the algorithm about links
you see in the early days of search
engine algorithms they used to Simply
count the amount of links than if one
site had more links than another that
made it more credible
however once people started to figure
that out people started accumulating
links by really any means necessary
and they were just looking for the sheer
volume of links because they knew if
they got the most amount of links it
would affect their rankings
and so over the years the search engines
have had to change and adjust and add
more relevance to their algorithm
refine it in order to look at different
aspects of links in order to properly
determine relevance
so over time it wasn't just having a
link it was then also looking at how
many people cite this site as an
authority so looking at the source of
the link and the types of pages
then also looking at the text of the
link and matching it with the text of
the page
does it match is it contextual
and then looking at the type of Link
doing the Block Level analysis
and then also the context the relevancy
of your site compared to the linking
site compared to the link and the
information that's being shared there
also some of the ways that they can look
at it at the age of the link how long
has that link been there
humans do the same thing when we look to
see how long someone has been in
business we're looking at credibility
and then of course there are many many
other ongoing refinements that are going
into the search engines evaluations of
links sometimes the age of the link
isn't as relevant especially when you're
looking for something that has happened
very recently
an Old Link could mean that it's old
news or that something has changed since
then
so search engines are in a constant
battle to ensure that people are not
gaming the system
by falsely creating relevance through
linking
the link relevancy and the algorithm is
all about trying to determine who is the
most relevant and credible within this
area
and that is the focus of most search
engine algorithm refinements over the
past few years and it will be into the
future
now this is where I'm going to start
bringing in some screenshots from a link
Management program
as a search engine Optimizer a link
Management program is probably going to
be one of your best friends as you move
along in this industry
in this example this program link Decks
that I'm using will track the incoming
links to my website and it'll also
provide a breakdown as to what type of
website those links are coming from so I
can see how many links I have from blogs
how many links I have from news sites
how many links from wikis how many links
from directories forms social media
public relations sites articles or
additional resources
then I can also add my competitors and I
can compare where I stand in terms of
the amount of links from each source and
where my competitors stand
in this way I can be sure that we all
have a similar link profile you see if
my linking profile looks vastly
different than all my competitors the
search engines are going to see that as
well and know that something might be
different with me good or bad and that's
going to raise a red flag
so I want to look at the linking profile
because every industry and
almost every business is linking profile
is going to be a little different but
especially among Industries we see that
linking profiles that is the amount of
links from different sources it's going
to be slightly different for every
different type of industry or business
so this helps me understand where my
links are coming from which is vitally
important because from a business
standpoint one thing that I've tracked
consistently in analytics is that people
will act differently and also I can
predict which source is going to send me
the best customers
you see just because someone comes from
a link doesn't mean they're going to buy
or become a customer or really become a
lead
many times they're going to come look at
your information and leave
and based on how they come to your site
whether it's through a Blog a directory
a forum or a new site has a lot to do
with how they view your website
and it's all about the context
you see this is what I've learned over
the years is that people will behave
differently based on how they find the
website
what I found is that people from blogs
news sites and articles they tend to
stay longer do more and have a higher
chance of conversion of becoming a
customer or a lead
the main reason is because blogs and
articles they have a lot of context it's
an article someone has taken the time to
write some information out and then link
to my site which means there is a highly
contextual reason for someone to click
that link
also what it means is that there's a lot
less competition for that link when my
link is in that article
compare that with social news or any
type of social site
you see when you're on a social site and
you're looking at your social stream of
information there's a lot of different
people competing for your attention a
lot of different things and it's not
just in one subject area it's usually
from multiple subject areas and so the
context is very low because there's a
lot of different types of information
and the competition for your attention
is very high
because of that people from social sites
or applications
tend to visit more often but they only
tend to view one page and leave
immediately
because they're looking to see what was
interesting and then they move on to the
next subject
that's the difference between how people
react based on where they come from
and so when I'm measuring links I'm
looking to see which links do I have
what's the source and then how do those
sources behave differently from one
another
and why
you see if I find that I'm getting links
from sources that people are staying
longer doing more and converting at a
higher rate then I'm going to continue
to focus on building links in those
areas because it directly affects how I
monetize my website
so here's a strategy in building links
one of the things I'm looking at is the
source of links like I said if I can
find a link Source that's providing
visitors that will stay look at my
content engage with the content and
eventually convert and convert at a
higher rate than other sources of
content or visitors
then I'm going to focus on that source
and so I'm going to look at some high
Authority websites whether they're
industry Publications news sites
education sites those are what are
considered high Authority blogs articles
news sites
that's what I'm looking to do I want to
find the most authoritative website
and sometimes it happens naturally if
people that work at those websites or
manage those sites if they find you and
they like your content they'll link to
it and that way you can get more
credibility more relevancy
certain people certain organizations
certain websites have more Authority
influence than others it goes back to
the question that I asked you early in
this module that how do you know if
someone is more authoritative than
somebody else
we also have mid Authority websites
which you can get some links on and low
Authority websites which are very easy
to get links but here's what I've
learned when it comes to link building
one link from one high quality website
can be worth hundreds or thousands of
mid to low quality links
ultimately it's about quality not
quantity
one of the things that I will do
utilizing my link software is look at
the context of the link
I want to see how relevant this is so as
I said if I want to find a high relevant
website what I'm looking for in terms of
this is I want to see the influence of
the domain as well as the relevance of
the domain those are two factors that
we're going to look at when we're
evaluating the quality of a domain now
as I'm looking at this report here what
influence means is that it is a high
quality website
that within the linking algorithm these
sites have a lot of authority however
they may not be relevant
so for example they may have a lot of
sites attributing authority to them
but they may not be relevant to my
industry which is why we have the next
column of keyword relevance
you see when I'm evaluating my links I'm
looking for the sources that are both
influential and relevant
that means that I've got a link from a
site that fits the two standards of high
Authority it's authoritative and
relevant now it's good to have links
from authoritative sites that might not
be relevant it's still authoritative
however to get the full benefit I want
it to be influential and relevant but
not to say that I'm not looking for
links from these other sources this is
just a means of measuring what you have
as well as comparing it to your
competitors and other websites
now here's some best practices when I'm
optimizing anchor text I want to
maintain contextual relevance so I want
to use text in the text link and I want
to explain to people what's they're
linking to what they're going to find
when they click on that link if I use an
image as a link I'm going to use an ALT
attribute because if that image doesn't
show up that ultrabute
is necessary to let people know where to
go
but also I do get a little tiny bit of
benefit by using that alt attribute
within the image link
I also want to look at the relevance of
the source page that I'm linking to and
make sure contextually the link the link
text and the content of the page is
contextually relevant to the destination
page
I also want to be sure that I don't
overuse the keywords that I don't make
multiple links to the same destination
that I don't use the same anchor text
over and over
I can be downgraded or even penalized by
the search engine algorithm if that is
found on my pages
so as an example instead of using click
here
for a how-to article I might use the
exact phrase of how to fix whatever it
is and use that as the link to the page
that has the content
that's a simple way of looking at anchor
text am I directing someone to
additional information if I am then how
can I present it to them so they know
exactly what they're going to find
and Link it appropriately
I look at it as developing the next step
for your readers where do you want them
to go what do you want them to do what
resources do you have available to them
how can you structure them so that they
are easily understood and you're
explaining the Final Destination
like I said if you overuse anchor text
you can be downgraded or penalized by
the search engines
so what I will tell you to do is number
one avoid overstuffing anchor content
that means needlessly repeating keywords
in the anchor text don't do that
avoid being redundant meaning don't have
four or five or six links with the same
anchor text going to the same page
that's a clear way of letting search
engines know that you're going overboard
don't just randomly Place links
throughout your text just to get the
link
ask yourself are you really helping the
reader find the information they need
and do it once
and then also avoid extremely overly
promotional words within the linked text
such as best expert cheap number one
those types of things
so a couple examples we can say for
travel advice click here but I would say
here is my travel advice and Link travel
advice rewrite it be creative
if it were easy everyone would be doing
it
but this is where you can write things
in a better way to get the attention of
the reader and position it as a resource
also utilizing your url as the link or
as the anchor text as well for the link
in order to get that click
as I've got it here I would not
recommend that you use that I would
recommend that you avoid that
also the third line the check out the
best website for iPhones and iPhone
accessories utilizing overly promotional
words is one of those ways that you can
easily get caught by the search engines
now for future considerations when it
comes to Links realize that the majority
of algorithm changes are link based
evaluation refinements because people
are constantly attempting to fool the
search engines and develop a false link
profile
you should work to create high quality
links with high quality content
I wouldn't chase after Poor or low
quality links
now as I've mentioned before there are a
number of tools available for you to
manage and measure your backlinks tools
such as link decks Moz Raven Advanced
Link manager Majestic SEO and then also
you can use your Google analytics as
well however Google analytics only shows
you the visitors that have come from
links and what they've done the basic
functions of Link management software
and there are many other types other
than what are listed here but the first
thing that it does is just provide a
catalog of incoming links from other
domains to your site and your competitor
sites they offer tools for comparison to
see which domains are linking to you
what type of link it is and on which
Pages those links are listed they'll
also report newly acquired links in the
past 30 60 90 days or something similar
to that the purpose of Link management
software is to help you assess high
quality domains versus low quality
domains in terms of importance and
relevance
like I said the first job of a link
management tool is to collect all of
your backlinks you add your domain and
the tools will usually spider the domain
they'll go out into search engines and
go out into many other formats in order
to find and retrace who is linking to
you what page that link is contained
sometimes what text is on that page and
what text is being used in the link they
will catalog all of your incoming links
organize them format them and report
back to you most of these link programs
provide additional filters and
management tools so that you can get
more insights about who is linking to
you how they are linking to you and the
type of site
personally I use linkedex in order to
Monitor and report on my backlinking so
the first report here that I'm showing
out of Link text is that I see the total
amount of incoming links to my domain
this says I have over 2 000 links and
those 2000 links are on about 1 000
domains on average it looks like I have
about two links from every domain that
is linking to me so this is one way that
you start to look at your links number
one the total amount of domains that are
linking to you and then the total amount
of links available this way you can
isolate domains that are linking to you
consistently and also find those that
may not be the best domains or that are
sending a lot of links that are just not
relevant
the next thing I do in analyzing My
Links is to look at the type of Link
meaning the type of site that it's
coming from
this report breaks down the amount of
links coming from blogs news sites
directories forums social sites articles
or resources now it doesn't usually get
all of those links but it does get
enough to give you an idea of how well
you're doing in each channel one of the
things that I do like about this report
is it also has a timeline so I can look
and see when new links have been
acquired and maybe when some links have
been just disappeared that's called
churn and it's normal it's normal
because many times a link is published
on social media and it kind of just goes
away or it's not tracked anymore by your
link management software it can't find
it anymore and so linking is always
Dynamic you are always gaining new links
and losing old links there's going to be
a normal amount of churn
the next report shows me all of the
domains that are linking to me it also
shows me in the next column how many of
those domains are also linking to at
least one competitor and it will list as
many competitors as I have listed in
here if they list to multiple
competitors
it will let me know the influence of
that site or the authority that site is
seen because of the amount of websites
and credibility that Authority has for
that domain it'll also let me know the
keyword relevance how relevant that
website is overall contextually to my
domain and the content that I have
it will also let me know how many pages
on that domain have links to my website
so I can also go through and I can
filter this list by the type of site I
can filter by those domains that are
using anchor text to see how much anchor
text is being used and what type of
anchor text there are many different
ways that you can filter through all of
the domains that are linking to you in
order to get an idea of what's happening
on your domain what are competitors
doing and also the relevance of those
links to your site
now when I say that I can add
competitors this is another type of
report very similar to the one I showed
earlier where I look at my own standing
in the different types of sources of
links such as blogs directories forums
and so on I can also when I add my
competitors look to see how they are
performing in those different areas as
well and so I can compare my link
profile to my competitors
different Industries are going to have
different backlink profiles they might
be more heavily weighted towards blogs
or they might be more heavily weighted
towards forums or social sites in this
way I can look to see if my competitors
are actively link building and how
they're going about it I can see where
maybe they are excelling in one area
that the rest of the competitors are not
so I can compare different strategies I
can also compare different timelines to
see if I am acquiring Links at a faster
rate than my competitors this is very
important if you are a newer business or
a newer website trying to compete
now specifically what I can do is look
at an individual domain in this case
this domain has three pages linking to
me and that domain also links to two of
my competitors I can look at the
specific pages and what I'm looking at
here are Snippets this should be
familiar to you because what it's
showing is the URL of the page that's
linking to my page it shows me the page
title of that page and then in this
report it lets me know if there are any
keywords being used in the link in the
anchor text as well as the number of
links from that page now what this tells
me is that this is most likely a
directory something that is listing all
the different places that where you can
buy products because it's most likely
the linking to the domain name seeing
that there are no keywords being used in
Anchor text and also that there are 16
out about links from that page that
means that it must be a list of some
sort and they are linking not only to me
but most likely to competitors as well
so I can track my Links at the Domain
level and at the page level I can look
to see which Pages might have more
influence or relevance to my content I
can also see the link URL the page title
if any keywords are being used in the
anchor text and also within the context
of how many additional links are leaving
from that page if there are a high
amount of outgoing links on that page
then a link from that page might not be
as valuable since there are so many
links the less links there are coming
out from that page the more it will
benefit my site because I'm getting more
benefit from less links
now also what I'm going to do is compare
the link reports to my analytics I'm
going to go to my analytics because
linking software does not show traffic
it doesn't show how many people are
clicking on the link it only shows who's
linking to you but it does not show
visitor activity analytics will show you
visitor activity to see which domains
are most effective in sending visitors
to your site if you go back to the
primary benefits of linking visitors
branding and business analytics show me
visitors and business it shows me which
domains are sending me visitors and
which of those visitors are becoming
customers
so what I can do is go to Google
analytics look at all the domains that
are referring traffic to my site I can
also click on the domain and see the
destination page that they are linking
to I can see how many visitors are
coming either monthly or annually how
often they're coming back whether
they're new users or repeat users how
long they stay how many pages they View
and how many conversions as a result of
those visits this is a great way to get
a 360 degree view of your linking
because not only do you want links that
will help you rank better you also want
links that will send business and
customers to you as well
building links can take many forms
ideally it is through networks
relationships and marketing that other
websites and users learn about you like
you and recommend you to others
unfortunately there is a lot of bad
outdated and untrustworthy advice to be
found about building links to your
website
in this section I'll present the best
practices as accepted by the omcp
standard
the objectives for this module that
you'll be able to develop a link
building strategy
that you'll understand the value of
different link types
finally you'll be able to find inbound
link opportunities
the first step in building links is to
evaluate what you have
now there are many tools available that
you can utilize to do this for you there
are automated tools that you can get
that will catalog all of the incoming
links to your website
some of them are link decks Moz Raven or
Advanced Link manager there are many
that can do that you may also want to
utilize your analytics as well in order
to find websites that link to you
the first step is evaluating where you
are right now
your incoming links have a significant
impact on your rankings
and you can do a lot of on-page
optimization and see some results
however a lot of Google's algorithm
takes into account links from other high
quality websites
now when you evaluate what you have in
this example I'm showing you a
screenshot from link decks
link decks catalogs the incoming links
to my website and it groups them into
different areas
the first way it groups them is by high
value or high influence domains
those are websites that link to me that
have a lot of influence not necessarily
in my industry but High influence based
on the amount of people that link to
them as an authority on many different
subjects
the next way that it groups that is
based on relevance
now this is when it looks at the match
of my content versus the content of the
other website
in the first example we can see the
National Library of Medicine
it is a high influence website because
it is a government website with a lot of
information that is cited frequently
because of the amount of other websites
linking to that site it has a high
amount of influence
now based on the website that I am
measuring
there is a lot of keyword relevance
meaning that that National Library of
Medicine site with the government has a
lot of content that's very similar to my
site a lot of the same keywords are
being used
so not only is this website of high
influence it also has a lot of relevance
and that's key when evaluating my
backlinks
I want to look at which websites are
also referring traffic
so while I may have a link from the
National Library of Medicine I want to
look at my analytics and look to see is
it also providing visitors
our visitors following that link to my
site and I also want to look at the
quality of traffic that it produces
do these visitors stay longer than
average
do they convert more than average I want
to look at the quality of traffic based
on the source
next I want to look at the incoming
links from those other websites number
one I want to make sure that the
incoming link from the other site is
both accurate and relevant meaning the
text that is used in the link is it
accurate to the content that will appear
on the page when the visitor clicks that
link
is the content relevant this is
especially relevant if I have updated my
website changed the content or moved
things around
I want to be sure that that incoming
link sends visitors to the appropriate
page and the appropriate information
I also want to ensure that that link is
worded correctly that it uses the right
words that is sending visitors and
setting expectations of the content that
they will see
I may need to contact the website
manager or owner and maybe ask for a
better linked text or a more accurate
page destination
now this requires some interaction with
the owner or manager of another website
and you always want to be respectful of
their time and not demanding that they
make any changes
in some cases the organization may be so
big you may never find the right person
in order to optimize the text or the
destination of that link
you always want to look for accuracy in
cases where your company or website name
is utilized in the link
but also if there is any contact
information such as address phone number
a description of your business and any
content
make sure it's accurate and it all
points to the right place
another way to look for links is to
Simply go to a search engine and start
doing searches
search for your company your business
your company name and look for websites
that may mention you but do not have a
live link to your website
many times your company will be
mentioned or cited but there will not be
a live link you can only find these
through doing searches and seeing which
websites mention you without linking to
you
now this could be an opportunity to get
an Easy Link especially if you can find
some contact information and finding the
right person that could add a link to
your company information
again you'll need to be polite ask for
their help and it will help it if you
can develop the link along with the link
text and send that over
giving them just a quick and easy edit
to be able to add the information
so make it as easy as possible
as an example I've provided a sample
request format
again you want to be polite you want to
be inviting and respectful of their time
and their management
sometimes like I said you may find the
right person that can help you
however the larger the company the more
difficult it will be to make this happen
this just requires your patience
and again being polite and not expecting
the company to do what you are asking
many times this is just a formality and
sometimes companies will act on it so be
sure to approach this with the right
expectations
the next thing I want to look at are
business listings these are the easy
ways to establish links and ensure that
links are where they should be and also
opportunities
look for business directories especially
if your company has a local presence you
can utilize Chamber of Commerce lists
Association lists or local listings
if they are on websites see if they
offer links that can go to your website
rather than just the list of businesses
that are in the area
even on a larger level you can look for
associations directories or listings
where you can add your business or
double check if your business is there
and always ensure that your business
name address phone number and URL are
correct complete and consistent with
other listings
the next level will require some active
marketing and that's where you search
for opportunities
you can go out and look for other
resource lists within your industry or
directories of businesses within your
industry and you can get a link many
times through membership or submitting
your business as a resource
however you may want to step up your
marketing you can do that by
interviewing your clients seeing if they
might be willing to provide a
testimonial and a link to your website
you may also want to go out and find
other communities online maybe some
social communities that are relevant to
your industry
get involved with those communities fill
out a profile and get involved by
contributing information
by sharing information you'll find that
people like getting information and
they'll respond by linking to your site
another option is to utilize the tool
that you had for indexing your links
from the first step
you can also add your competitors and
you can look at their backlinks you can
look and see which websites and which
domains are linking to your competitors
but you always need to go and see why
what are those other sites linking to
and what is the nature of that link
sometimes it may exclude you from being
able to approach competitors backlinks
and ask them for links
however if they're being linked to by
companies that are simply stating here
are vendors in this space and they are
linking your competitors and you're not
there
then it might make a lot of sense for
you to approach and ask if you can be
listed as well
however be sure that the links to your
competitors are not from a consumer or
customer relationship
in that case it might be out of line for
you to ask for a link
make sure if you approach anyone who's
linking to a competitor and asking for a
link to your site
make sure the context is right and then
it makes sense for them
and that's the ultimate judge of value
does it benefit somebody else to link to
your site
we all know that it will benefit you
but when you present your link request
you need to offer value and a benefit
for others to link to you
so be sure that you present it in a way
that is beneficial
and good for those people that will be
adding the link they're the ones that
have to take the work to do it and
they're also the ones that are adding a
recommendation for you and your business
so as always you need to be considerate
and patient
now the best way to build links is by
creating something that people like and
sharing it
you see the best way to build links is
by creating value through content or
information or entertainment
you see when people like things they
link to it
if they find a study or a white paper or
research that you performed they link to
it
if you post a infographic that explains
something
and it's attractive people link to it
you see that's what's most amazing about
linking I find that when we put most of
our effort into creating content that
people like
that's what builds the most valuable and
the most relevant links
and so what type of content well you can
create infographics videos top 10 lists
or articles articles with advice or
analysis of Market data or even research
that type of content people love it and
so when you publish it out you utilize
social media to extend the reach and the
visibility of that type of content
and when someone likes it they'll link
to it and recommend it to others
now people also like depending upon your
industry or your business they also like
some personality maybe some humor
people always like expert information
they like the cute this is why pictures
of cats tend to be liked and linked to
more than almost anything else and also
the unexpected
if you can inject any of that into your
content that just makes it more valuable
more personable and again more shareable
by other people and every time someone
shares it it builds a link to your site
you see the best linking is when people
like something
when you create something that people
like and share you might be surprised at
the many opportunities there are
to get links based on your content
I've seen many many blogs based on
cooking fashion Arts Sports music
and when people specialize within a
specific topic they always find an
audience and so anything they publish
builds links
even on certain social media sites such
as Pinterest
people upload pictures on articles and
infographics especially about
landscaping flowers food cars you name
it there is a special interest for
anything and you can develop links from
those social sites to your site
and it can generate traffic
even with a Blog developing articles
that talk about upcoming events new
music Sports whatever it is when you
create content that people like
it takes the longest amount of time to
build content for building links when
you develop your own content that's the
biggest investment you'll make in time
and research and writing and
presentation
however
the result is that when you develop that
content
you will receive the best and highest
quality links and the most valuable
links are going to be to that content
as I mentioned before one high quality
link can be worth more than hundreds or
thousands of low quality links
so my best advice is to create content
that people like that they link to
and that will be high value links that
you'll generate to your site if you are
looking to become an SEO professional
then look no further than simply runs
postgraduate program in digital
marketing so don't miss out on this
opportunity Find the course Link in the
description for more information
Google search console formerly known as
Google webmaster tool is a web service
provided by Google Developers
Google search console is mainly
responsible for optimizing a website for
its visibility
indexing website detecting crawl errors
Etc
after understanding what is Google
search console
now we need to focus on why search
console is an important part of search
engine optimization
a website's technicalities are directly
or indirectly related to search control
consider you have created a website for
your business
but from past few weeks your website is
not visible in search result Pages here
search console comes into action
there is a possibility that searched
engine crawlers are not able to crawl
your website thus it is not visible in
the search result pages
to make crawlers crawl your website you
will need to optimize your website using
search console
some other technical aspects of search
console includes
fixing indexing problems
sending the updated content or Pages for
indexing
generating search traffic reports
generating alerts if there are any
issues related to indexing or any other
issue gets the list of sites linking to
your website keep the track of mobile
usability
amp pages
and more
so now it is the right time to
understand how search console works
but before we begin this topic have a
look at the range of courses of digital
marketing and search engine optimization
from skill up by simply learn you can
get the link in the description box
below so now I have a question for you
what will you do at first if your web
page fails to appear in search result
pages well let me know your thoughts in
the comment section below
stay tuned with this video Even though
if you don't have the answer right now
by the end of this video you will surely
able to answer this question so let's
get started by knowing how search
console works to understand the working
of search console it is necessary to
have a detailed knowledge about how
search engine works search engines
mainly Works in three steps crawling
indexing and ranking let's have a look
at each step one by one
so first let's start with crawling
search engines are hungry for content
and so they send Web spiders or web
crawlers also known as robots or search
engine Bots to discover new content or
any updated content
content can be an image a web page a
video or anything else present on the
web this process is known as crawling
now let's know about indexing
as soon as the crawler discover the
updated content or new content
these web crawlers start storing the
URLs of the content into the search
index or web index this process is known
as indexing once the content is indexed
it starts appearing in the search result
pages
when a user enters a search query the
most relevant results are taken from the
index
and displayed in the form of most
relevant to least relevant in the search
result Pages this process is known as
ranking now that we have gained
knowledge about how search engine works
here I have a question for you choose
the correct option with respect to
working of search engines
you need to choose the option for all
the steps of how search engines work
option A indexing crawling ranking
option b ranking indexing crawling
option C crawling indexing ranking and
option D crawling ranking and indexing
let us know your answer in the comment
section below
now let's get started by learning how
search console actually works
search console is a primary source of
information that helps search engine
Bots to crawl index and rank the pages
of your website
thereby allowing the website owners to
monitor the health of your website
all you need to do is integrate search
console with your website and get the
ownership
allow the search engine Bots to crawl
your website and index the pages also
don't forget to submit your website
sitemap to search engines submitting
sitemaps helps the crawler to discover
more pages of your website
thereby understanding your site's
architecture
we will know how it is done in the
upcoming part of the video
also you need to keep an eye on the
errors suggested by search console and
solve them else it may harm the ranking
of your website
now let me remind you that all the
reports that are generated in search
console are based on the activity of the
web Crawlers on your website now let's
understand various parameters and
terminologies from search console
to get a complete understanding of this
webmaster tool
so without any further delay let's start
understanding the basic terminologies of
Google search console and how they work
and improve your website's Health
the first one we have is performance
reports
Google search console provides two types
of performance report search reports and
discover reports
let's first understand about search
reports
search reports help to analyze the
search performance of your website
search performance reports include
metrics and dimensions
so let's first focus on metrics
here there are four types of metrics as
you can see in this image
the metrics include the total clicks or
I must say clicks Impressions average
CTR and average position
Impressions provides the data on how
many times your websites appears in the
search results
as you can see here the graph shows the
number of times this website has
appeared in the search results
the next metric we have is clicks
clicks provide the data on the total
number of times users clicked from the
search results and reached your website
the graph below shows the number of
times the users have clicked from search
results and they have arrived on any
page of my website so suppose if here is
a number 200 so we can definitely get an
idea
for very number of dates number of dates
provided on the x-axis which shows that
how many times the user has clicked and
arrived on the website and the number
various varies from between like 200 200
250 300 and in between 250 to 300.
and the next metric we have is average
CTR average CTR or click-through rate is
the percentage of Impressions that
results in clicks in the same manner the
graph below shows or the average CTR for
various different dates
the next metric we have is average
position the average position represents
the data about the average position of
the sites in the search results
it is possible that your website is
ranking today at number one position so
it may rank tomorrow at 3 some other day
at 4 some other day at 9 or 10 and again
it may rank to the one so this data
actually provides the detail about the
average position which your website
frequently ranks at so that is if it is
ranking at one two and three in between
one two and three positions so the
average position may be two
now understanding about the dimensions
dimensions are the data attribute that
defines who did something on your site
or from where
is the list of dimensions on which the
dimension performance reports are
generated that is
countries Pages queries devices search
appearance and dates
the dimension country suggests the
country from which the search came as
you can see here from the left column
you can get the list of number of
countries from the right side you can
get the idea about the clicks impression
ctrn position that is all the metrics
related to that query uh from which the
search came from or from that location
or whatever the activity has happened
from that location next we have is the
dimensions pages
Pages show the pages clicked by user or
a page that is viewed on a search so
this this actually you get the reports
from the search console in the form of
the links where you get the link which
is the exact page that is viewed on the
search
if there exists duplicate pages on the
site then only one canonical page or
canonical link will be displayed by the
search engines out of the number of
duplicate pages so basically canonical
links are those links uh like if there
are suppose there is a one original page
and there are two three duplicate page
of the same page so what happens uh the
original page gains the canonical link
and uh this page has more value than the
duplicate pages
so whenever the search engine will crawl
your website all the duplicate pages may
be ignored and all its uh link juice or
link Equity or anything will be uh
completely taken for the original page
uh moving ahead to queries
queries provide the query string that
users search on the Google search
console
so Suppose there is a website which is
suppose uh let's talk about the simply
learn website so suppose a user may add
as Java course and simply learn websites
appears at second or third position so
this query say suppose user clicks on
the website and reaches the website this
query Java course on simply learn or
Java course will add in the search
console showing that the user has
reached to your website using this query
Java course and again all the list of
the queries appears towards the left and
all the matrixes for that query like
clicks impression CTR and its average
position is appeared towards the right
in the search console now talking about
the search appearance search appearance
helps in grouping the data as per the
search result type or by the feature so
you can get here the number of search
appearance and again the same metrics as
with respect back to the search
appearance criteria next let's move
towards the dates
dates groups of data as per the dates
according to the public time zones now
let's have a look over the Discover
performance report
now here you must be thinking about how
the search is different from discover
yes search and discover follow different
approaches users enter a query to find a
required information with search
whereas discover shows the content based
on what result will be best match for
your query as per the Google's automated
system
now coming to the Discover performance
report as per Google's guidelines
discover performance reports are visible
only if your website has a minimum
threshold of impressions in discover
now moving to another important
parameter of search console which is URL
inspection
URL inspection is an interesting tool in
the search console this tool allows you
to inspect whether the URL is indexable
or not
some main functions of this tool
includes
checking the current status of the URL
inspecting live URLs requesting indexing
for a URL
viewing Pages rendered version viewing
crawl Pages viewing tested Pages
Etc
in order to check the index status of
URL open the URL inspection tool
and add the complete URL
for which we need to know its indexing
status
now to understand the results check the
present status if it shows that URL is
on Google as you can see in the screen
this means that URL qualifies Google's
criteria and is eligible to appear in
search results
if it shows URL is not on Google then
the URL does not qualify the Google's
criteria and is not eligible to appear
in search results
you can check more details like URL
Discovery crawl and indexing information
from the page availability tab
click on the crawl page to see the
information about the HTTP request and
response
if you find that the link is disabled
just hover over the page to check the
reason
now coming to the live URL test
it is helpful to test the live URL and
check if it is capable of being indexed
it proves helpful when you update your
page and want to compare it with its
latest indexed version just to bring it
to your notice
a live test will only confirm whether
the Google crawler can access your page
for indexing but it doesn't assure that
your page will be included in the Google
index all together with the help of
index coverage report one can find the
list of URLs which includes the URLs
Google has found on your website the
URLs that have been indexed and identify
if any indexing problem have occurred
next we move ahead to understand about
the site Maps
a site map is the file that contains all
the information of pages on your website
this helps search engine crawlers to
crawl your website and understand your
website structure
and helps them to index the pages more
efficiently
more the crawler indexes your pages
higher the chances for the pages of your
website to appear in the search results
with the help of site maps you can
provide information about various
contents like Pages videos images
Etc as you can understand a site map
plays an important role in indexing
process
you must be curious to know how we can
create and submit a sitemap to search
engines
before we understand this process make
sure that all pages of your website are
linked in an appropriate manner with
each other thereby maintaining a healthy
site structure
a site map can be created in XML format
RSS format or in text format
it can be auto-generated or created
manually as well
most commonly used sitemap is XML
following is an example of an XML site
map this is the simplest version of the
site map that we are representing here
you can submit a site map to the sitemap
reports in the search console
however sitemaps can also be submitted
through robots.txt file let's understand
about
robots.txt file
so let's understand the robots.txt file
in short
robots.txt file notifies the web
Crawlers
about the URLs that they can access on
the website as there are lots of search
engines there exists different web
crawlers thus there is a possibility
that some web crawlers may not obey the
instructions from the robots.txt file it
is necessary to know how to use the
proper syntax as different crawlers
understand syntax differently
thus there are chances that some web
crawlers might fail to understand the
instructions from the robots.txt file
a page can be indexed even if it is
disallowed from the robots.txt file if
it is linked to other site
next let's know what enhancement reports
are
all the rich results status reports are
displayed under the enhancement tab
so let's know more about rich results
these type of results are known as Rich
results in serps so basically Rich
results can be any search results other
than the traditional Blue Links for
example image results carousels
Etc
you can check whether the pages from
your website support Rich results or not
using the rich result test tool provided
by Google Developers now understanding
the rich results status report the
enhancement tab contains separate
reports for Rich result type some rich
results report types are listed below
that are breadcrumbs
education q a event FAQ fact check
guided recipe how to image license
job posting
learning video
review Snippets
Etc
Rich results status reports consist of
summary page and Details page
the summary page mainly consists of
Errors useful items found on your
website warnings
Etc The Details page consists of the
information about the issues when it was
detected item type when was the page
last crawled
Etc before we understand how to fix
error in search console it is important
to understand the status of each page as
reported by search console
each page has any of the following
status error warning excluded and valid
if the status of the page is valid it
means the page has successfully indexed
the status of the page appears to be
excluded
if one purposefully wants the page not
to be indexed
or a page is blocked by robots.txt file
for example setting the meta tag to no
index warnings majorly appears when the
page of your website is indexed
but there are some issues with the page
which needs your attention and have to
be resolved as soon as possible
if the page status is error then there
is a need to pay a detailed attention
over the issues in the page as these
issues prevent the page from getting
indexed
let's discuss about the errors in detail
and how we can fix them
some popular errors from the search
console are listed below
that is the redirect error server error
submitted URLs blocked by robots.txt URL
marked as no index submitted URL is a
soft poor not for 4 Note 4 or page not
found error
so let's first know about the redirect
error
some redirect error
that search console shows up are the
redirect chain that was too long
redirect true
redirect URL that exits maximum URL
length and bad or empty URL in the
redirect chain so all these error means
that the redirections are not working
properly and so there is a need to fix
them so suppose for example you have
added too many redirects from one page
to another
so in this scenario
search engine Bots find it a waste of
time to crawl again and again to the
same redirections and at that time the
search engine crawlers or search engine
boards ignore those URLs or redirections
so in such cases you need to fix those
redirection to a single URL
the next we have is server error
the server returns 5xx error when it
fails to fulfill a valid request this
error mainly conveys that something is
wrong with your website server all you
need to do is reach out to your hosting
services and inform them about the issue
and make sure it gets resolved as soon
as possible
the next one we have is submitted URL
blocked by robots.txt to resolve this
issue you need to remove the line of
code from the robot.txt file that
restricts Google from crawling the
respective page the next we have is URL
marked as no index
when a URL is marked as no index it
sends the signal to crawlers that this
page is not meant to be crawled or this
page is not meant to be indexed if you
want this page to be indexed check the
metadata and remove the no index
attribute
to allow the Crawlers to crawl the URL
now let's understand about the error
submitted URL is a soft 404 and 404 or
page not found error whenever a web page
load server returns a 200 signal showing
the success status code soft4 Note 4 is
a condition in which server returns 200
success status code and the page not
exist error simultaneously
this is considered to be a bad user
experience
this error can be solved simply by
redirecting this page to any relevant
URL
or the home page of the website
talking about 404 or page not found
error this error mainly occurs
when you delete the page from your
website but the URL of the page still
exists in the site map
this error can be solved by simply
removing the URL or removing the four
not four URL from the site map or
redirecting the URL to a new page
this will help to avoid the further
errors in near future
we will have a detailed look at other
4xx errors in the upcoming videos
now that we are aware of the basics of
search console let's dive deeper to know
some stats regarding the search console
in the SEO industry
when you're thinking of adding a
business online your website should
fulfill all the technical SEO needs
which can be achieved by Google search
console thus there is a huge demand in
SEO industry for the candidates having
strong knowledge of Google search
console
the average salary of an SEO expert
with the Google search console skills in
US is 53 000 dollars
to seventy eight thousand dollars per
annum and that in India is 2 lakh 76 000
per annum
some biggies in the SEO industry looking
for this skill sets include Accenture
Amazon people group
Eton Etc
so let me know your dream company to
work as an SEO expert in the comment
section below
what we're going to cover today I'm
going to start out with how to set up a
Google analytics account and so we're
going to talk about everything that
entails including creating your Google
analytics account we're going to talk
about setting up a property in your
account and what a property is we're
going to talk about setting up a
reporting view in your property and
we're going to talk about installing the
tracking code so those are the series of
steps we're going to go through today in
terms of setting up a Google analytics
account so let's get right to it and so
really the Bruin prerequisite here when
it comes to setting up a Google
analytics account is to have a Google
login and ID so when you actually go to
Google analytics you need to be able to
sign up or sign in and so once you
actually sign in then you're going to go
walk through a series of steps but
really that's really all you need to get
the account going is a Google ID and
login so if you have a Gmail account or
an other email account that you use for
other Google products then you're good
to go that's all you need to do so when
you actually go to sign up for Google
analytics you're going to be asked to
set up a new account and these are the
series of steps you're going to walk
through or go through to set up a new
Google Analytics account so you're going
to choose an account name and then
you're going to choose a property name
okay so the account name can be anything
you want it to be to name your company
your name whatever you want to name it
the property name is really the website
name so what website are we talking
about so here I'm going to set up a
fictitious website name for now it's
called demo simply learn so the URL for
this website demo simply learn is going
to be
demo.simplylearn.com so that's the
property when we talk about properties
in analytics we're really talking about
what website sites we want to measure
and then you're going to be asked to
choose an industry category and so for
simply learn we're in jobs and education
but you have a number of different
industries that you could choose from
this is important go ahead and choose
the most relevant industry that your
particular business is associated with
okay and I'm going to talk about why
that's important here in a minute and
then you're going to choose your time
zone and the time zone is also important
because that's when the day starts in
analytics then the day ends based on
that time zone so the data that Google
analytics collects starts and ends with
that time zone so very important to
choose the time zone your business is
located in okay and then you have some
additional options here okay so you have
some settings and so the first setting
is to allow Google products and services
so if you opt into this then basically
what Google's going to do is share some
product services with you via email I
would go ahead and opt into that that's
of course recommended by Google it
doesn't hurt to hear from Google on
related products and services that may
enhance your business the second is
benchmarking so benchmarking to me is
something you should opt into so going
back to that industry and category we
chose jobs and education so by opting
into benchmarking basically what
Google's going to do is share your data
that it collects on your website in this
case
demo.simplylearn.com it's going to share
that data anonymously with others in the
industry in this case jobs and education
and because you've opted in it's going
to do the same exact thing for you it's
going to share Anonymous data on other
websites in the same industry and the
benefit of that is we get to see what
other websites or how other website are
performing compared to ours what's the
Benchmark in our industry and so the
benchmarking to me is important and I'm
gonna go over that in a few minutes when
we go over the different reports but to
me I would always opt into benchmarking
because this is the only report Google
provides in analytics about how others
in your industry is performing versus
your website okay so it's a way to
compare your website performance against
others in the same industry the other
options here technical support and
account specialist I would also
recommend you opt into those because
then it allows you to basically Google
allow Google access to your account and
they'll be able to help you if you occur
or run into any issues so these are the
options in setting up a Google analytics
account it's very simple very easy to do
you're just entering in a few Fields
note that we talking about a website
right now so I'm talking about demo.com
definitely learn.com but just know that
if you want to track a mobile app Google
analytics will allow you to do that as
well you just choose the option mobile
app so we're tracking a website we want
to know how users behave when they get
to my website and that's what Google
analytics is going to allow us to
measure and look at we just need to do a
couple more steps in the process so once
we fill out these fields here we're
going to click get tracking ID now I'm
going to accept the terms of service I'm
going to accept another terms and
service in relation to data protection
I'm going to click accept once I accept
I'm going to be able to get some
tracking code the tracking ID is the ID
associated with your account and so this
number is going to be associated with
your account so your account ID starts
with UA and it's going to be this number
here now the dash one is the property
you set up so in this case I set up
demo.simplylearn.com if I wanted to
track multiple websites under that same
account then I can certainly set up
multiple properties just know that every
property I set up in that account is
going to have a dash 1-2-3-4
Etc depending on how many properties I
set up so by default I set up one
property so my first property ID is dash
one if I set up a second property the
same account number it's just gonna have
a dash too and that's important because
that ID that account and property ID is
going to be associated with that
particular property or website so again
once you finish setting up the account
settings then you're going to be asked
to add some tracking code to your site
and that tracking code is going to be
related to the account and the property
so notice my tracking ID up here notice
is the tracking ID and the snippet code
now this snip and a code needs to go on
every page of your website that you want
to track and you don't have to put it on
every page but if you want to track
website behavior on every page or
website then it needs to go on every
page of your website so if you're using
a you know platform like Drupal or
Joomla or even more popular platform
like WordPress adding the tracking code
site-wide is as easy as maybe adding a
Google analytics plugin to Wordpress for
example and then just simply plug in in
the ID now there's an alternative to
adding the Google analytics tracking
code to your site and that's Google tag
manager so Google tag manager is the way
I would recommend going so if you're not
familiar with Google tag manager I would
recommend watching the YouTube video we
have on Google tag manager you can just
go to YouTube Type in simply learn
Google tag manager and this will give
you a nice overview of you know what
Google tag manager is and how it works
but basically this is the way I would go
and I would recommend that in addition
having Google analytics you set up a
Google tag manager account and then that
way you can put the tracking code in
Google tag manager so if I go to Google
tag manager and I just go into an
account on tag manager I can just simply
put in the Google analytics ID right
into tag manager and so if I have it in
tag manager then tag manager is going to
be the place that holds the code and
fires page view when somebody comes to
my website so that way I don't have to
add the tracking code to my website if I
do it in tag manager so that's the
recommended method for me is to add the
Google analytics ID associated with tag
manager if you can assign associated
with tag manager then that's the easier
route to go versus putting code on your
website okay so again take a look at the
video we have on YouTube for Google tag
manager that's the route I would go now
once you do get the tracking code on
your website whether that be through
Google tag manager or through a plug-in
or you know just simply adding the
script to your site to pages on your
site then what's going to happen is
you're going to start collecting data so
that's ideally the way it works you need
to add this code to your website now if
you're not ready to do that and you
simply want to basically understand how
Google analytics works then I would
recommend getting access to Google
analytics demo account and so if you
just type in and search Google analytics
demo account basically what you're going
to do you're going to choose the first
listing there and you're going to go to
demo account so if you have a Google and
analytics or Google login then all you
need to do is click on access demo
account and so what Google is going to
do is put this demo account into your
account and so it's going to look
something like this so if I click on
demo account here it's going to add to
my Google analytics account so I'm going
to have then access to the demo account
from Google and Google analytics so I
would recommend going this route here if
you're not familiar or you're not sure
what you're getting yourself into so
think of the demo account as kind of a
test drive you're test driving Google
analytics before you even add any code
to your website so again all you need is
a Google account and if you have a
Google account and you add the demo
account to your Google analytics account
you're going to be able to see how
analytics works okay and so that's what
I would also recommend so if you're not
ready to start adding code to your
website then what you can do is just
just simply add the demo account and
then once you add the demo account
you're free to peruse around Google
analytics to see the different types of
reports it has to offer now when you do
actually set up a Google analytics
account you're going to have some
settings that you're going to want to
pay attention to so when you set up the
account you have the account name and
then you have a property so under each
property you have by default you're
going to have one View and so here you
can see this view here so if we look at
the account we set up we set up a demo
simply learn account property is demos
simply learned so that's associated with
the website we're going to track and
then again by default under each
property you're going to have a view and
so by default the name of the view is
going to be called all website data and
so in that view is where all your
analytics data is going to be stored so
you can see my screen here there's a lot
of different settings you have you have
settings means under the account you
have settings under the property and you
have settings under the view so we're
going to talk more about these settings
and future webinars for advanced Google
analytics users but for now know that
there's a bunch of settings that you
have that you can play around with when
it comes to Google analytics anything
from adding users to your Google
analytics account your Google analytics
property or view you can actually set up
goals you can set up filters you can set
up segments you can link up Google ads
you can you know set up remarketing list
there's a lot you can do in terms of the
settings as it relates to Google
analytics but so know those settings are
there they're located right down here in
this little sprocket icon that's the
admin icon so if you need to get to
these settings at any time you could
simply just click on the sprocket or the
admin icon and then you'll be prompted
to choose any one of these settings here
that you want to edit or alter so now
let's take a look at some Google
analytics reports so once you've
actually set up your account you have a
number of different reports that you
have available to you in Google
analytics so we're going to take a look
at you know customized reports we're
going to look at real time audience
reports acquisition behavior and
conversion so these are all the
different reporting buckets if you will
that you have available to you in Google
analytics so if I'm an admin and I'm
looking at the Google demo account let's
start out by looking at real time so if
I click on the real time report and I
just click on overview so basically what
this is going to do is show me at this
point in time how many users I actually
have active on the website okay so
that's why they call it real time
reporting because it allows you to see
the behavior of users who are currently
on your website and so this is the
overview report under real time and you
can see here I can see that 79 percent
of my users are coming from desktop 18
20 are coming from mobile and then
approximately three percent are coming
from tablet here I can see how they
actually came to the website so this is
the referring Source if they came from
say search or social I can see the
source there and I can see what pages
they're active on and then here I could
see what locations where they're located
and so if I want to see a breakdown of
everything in the overview I can
certainly do that if I go to locations
under real time I could see a majority
of my users are coming from the United
States okay where are they coming from
I'll just click on traffic sources and
here I could see the different sources
and mediums medium is the means in which
the traffic was driven so if it's Google
it's either paid search or organic
search so I can see here it's organic
then I can actually see what contents
they're looking at on my website so I
could see currently I have three active
users on the home page two active users
on the Google's women's white t page so
forth and so on now most importantly if
you have a vent tracking setup so if
you're taking a look at our Google tag
manager webinar you know that you could
set up event tracking in Google
analytics to measure engagement on your
website whether that be a form
submission or somebody clicking on the
play button of a video so if I click on
events I'll be able to see what events
are firing so here I can see we have
event tracking set up and I can see how
many different events are firing on my
website in real time so here I can see
e-commerce somebody clicking on the
quick view click some a couple of users
clicking on add to cart a couple of
users clicking on the promotion click
and as these events are fired you're
going to be able to see them highlighted
so if something gets fired it's going to
get highlighted and I could see that
these are the current events that I have
currently firing on the website and
that's what's currently fire now if I
want to look at the events that have
happened in the last 30 minutes I could
just click on this link here last 30
minutes and it's going to give me an
overview of the events that have
happened over the past 30 minutes okay
so that's event tracking and then more
importantly we can also look at what
conversions are happening in real time
just by clicking on conversions and so
now I can see I had one active user who
entered the checkout so that's goal
number four so in analytics you can have
up to 20 goals and so here I can see we
have goal number four has already had
one active user and so if I look at the
last 30 minutes I can see I still have
only one goal over the last 30 minutes
and that was somebody who entered the
checkout so that's real time reporting
in summary it just gives you an idea of
what's currently happening on your
website and so for me ideally if I'm
launching a campaign or let's just say
you do a new website redesign and you
want to see how users performing and
behaving then real time is a good option
for you so you could see how things are
happening in real time now let's jump
down to audience reporting so if I click
on audience this is just right
underneath real time I'm gonna see a
number of different reports available to
me under audience and so let's click on
the audience overview report so audience
reporting basically allows us to get a
sense of who is coming to our website
when I say who is coming to our website
it doesn't necessarily have to be a
specific person in fact Google doesn't
allow personally identifiable
information
in Google analytics personal
identifiable information such as a
specific name uh social security number
credit card information
Etc however we could still paint a nice
picture on who is coming to our website
meaning what country city or state did
they come from what language what device
did they get to our website from how old
were they okay were they male or female
or other what interests do they have
what browser did they use so we can
paint a nice picture based on all this
information that Google analytics is
providing us under audience so if I go
to audience overview here I can see I
have all these different options
available to me to get a basic
understanding of who is coming to our
website so for example I could see a
majority of the people coming to our
website speak English and are from the
United States okay in fact that's rep
represents 61 percent of the users and
so Google analytics does a great job of
giving me an overall percentage so if I
have a hundred percent of the users I
could see 61 percent of those users
represented English speaking users from
the United States seven percent
represented English-speaking users from
Great Britain and so when it comes to
analytics we have users and users are
broken down into two categories they're
either returning or they're new so when
you add the Google analytics tracking
script to your website what's gonna
happen is if a user or when a user goes
to your website they're going to get
cookied if it's the first time they've
been to your website what Google
analytics is going to do is store a
cookie in the browser so when that same
user comes back another day in the same
browser analytics is going to recognize
that that cookie is in the browser and
so then analytics is going to categorize
that user as a returning user okay so
that's how analytics is able to
differentiate new versus returning so if
that user doesn't have a cookie in the
browser then analytics is going to
recognize that store the cookie and then
count that user as a new user and so
when you're looking at analytics you're
going to be able to see a breakdown of
new versus returning so here I can see
over three quarters of my traffic over
the past week here I can see April 6
through April 12th three over three
quarters are new users to the website
here I could see about 23 24
are returning users okay so I can get a
good breakdown of what type of users are
coming am I driving new traffic am I
driving traffic that's been to my
website before what language are they
speaking okay I can also paint a bigger
picture how old are they are they what
gender are they do they come from mobile
so let's take a look at some of these
different reports under audience and so
if I skip down now to demographics I can
click on overview and when that report
loads I can see now under demographics
overview I can see the breakout of age
ranges and so here I can see the
majority of the traffic coming to my
site again over the past week now if I
want to change this date range I could
simply do that I can change the date
range just by clicking on the date range
and then maybe going say the last 30
days and I can even compare it to the
previous period or the previous year I'm
going to choose the last 30 days I'm
going to click apply now I'm looking at
data over the last 30 days and again you
can change the date range to any range
you want you can only go back as far as
when you actually created the Google
analytics account you can't go prior to
that so here I'm looking at the last 30
days and I can see almost 47 of my you
users were in their age range of 25 to
34. now when it comes to gender I can
say 66 percent represent males so I can
get a breakout of gender and age as well
as interest and click on interest and
look at the overview there and see what
the interest is of the users who are
coming to my site based on in-market
segments or Affinity I can also choose
language and location so if I want to
know exactly where my users are located
when they're coming to my website I can
click on location and here I can get a
breakout 43 of the users of the last 30
days were from the United States more
importantly I can align my audience with
goals and we'll talk about goals here in
a minute but here I can see if I have an
e-commerce website I can see of those 43
0.29 percent of those converted or
purchase something and that equates to
94 transactions so I can get a good
sense of not only how many users are
coming from a specific country but are
those users converting if I click on
mobile and mobile to me is one of those
reports I tend to spend a bit of time on
because I want to know what devices
users are coming to my website and so
for my website here or this is the
Google demo website I can see mobile
represents approximately 27 of the
traffic so desktop still represents a
majority of the traffic so for you you
want to keep an eye on mobile because
mobile is definitely a majority of what
people use nowadays that's how people
start their day that's how they transact
Via Mobile whether that's purchasing
something communicating or searching it
all starts with mobile so you want to
keep an eye on mobile and more
importantly you want to keep an eye on
Behavior so Google analytics is telling
me that yes I have approximately 27
percent of my traffic of the last 30
days came from mobile how are they
interacting with my website so if I look
across this report I'm going to be able
to see different metrics so if I'm
measuring specific metrics against my
dimension in this case the dimension is
what we're measuring and in this example
we're measuring mobile I can see that
the bounce rate is approximately 48 and
bounce rate means that if a user in this
case for mobile landed on a page they
left the site without going any further
so they consider it a bounce if they
don't go to another page if they leave
the site from the page they landed on
and they don't go any further that's
considered a bounce so bounce rate is
the percentage of people who come to the
site and leave the site without going
any further so in this case we have 48
bounce rate that's almost half of our
users who come from mobile leave the
website from the page they landed on so
is that good is that bad well it's open
to interpretation is definitely
subjective but you want to keep the
bounce rate as low as possible you want
to keep people on your site especially
if you have an e-commerce website you
want people who come to your website to
purchase and so here we could see 48
mobile and desktop it's a little bit
lower at 41 percent now if I look a
little bit further at engagement I can
see how many pages on average do mobile
users look at so versus desktop it's a
little bit lower you can see 3.86 on
desktop it's 4.5 now if I look a little
bit further in engagement I want to be
able to measure how long among somebody
from mobile stays on the website if
they're bouncing at 48 but they're also
looking at 3.8 Pages 3.9 almost four
pages per session then that means in
this report analytics is telling me
they're spending about two minutes on
the site and interestingly enough I can
see that mobile of the last 30 days had
more transactions so 51 transactions
versus 34 transactions from desktop and
interestingly enough the e-commerce
conversion rate is at 0.29 percent
that's higher than desktop at .07 it's
lower than tablet but it's higher than
desktop and mobile has the most
transactions and since they have the
most transactions they have the most
Revenue at 2 380. so yes the engagement
isn't exactly as great as it is this
desktop but we can see that people are
still purchasing with their mobile
devices so something to keep an eye on
and mobile is something I definitely
look at in fact since it's such an
important report one thing you can do in
analytics is if you actually like a
report and you think you're going to
look at that report multiple times then
you can simply just go ahead and click
save at the top here so if I click save
I'm going to enter a name for this
report I'm just going to call it mobile
report and click OK and then what's
going to happen is it's going to be
located under save reports and save
reports is located under customization
customization is located above real time
okay so if I close that up you can see
audience real time customization if I
click on customization if I click on
Save reports I should be able to see my
save report here and I do so here I can
see mobile report if I click on it I can
simply go to the report I was looking at
before I saved it so save reports to me
is a good feature in analytics because
it allows you to quickly access a report
that you've saved in the past so let's
take a look at one more report under
audience and let's go to benchmarking so
remember when we're setting up our
analytics account we had the option to
opt into benchmarking and I recommended
you do so and so if you did I actually
opt into benchmarking then you're going
to be able to see how your site compares
to others in the same industry so if I
click on benchmarking and then click on
channels what I'm actually able to do
now is compare my website with others in
the same industry so if I go back to say
jobs and education and I choose
education all education as my industry
vertical I should be able to see
websites that are in the same particular
industry and how I compare with those
websites so I'm choosing all country
trees I can narrow that down if I wanted
to I can just search for the United
States I can choose a specific State and
then I can choose a particular site size
so here I'm choosing sites by daily
session so these are sites that have an
average of 5 000 to almost 10 000
sessions a day and so in this vertical
education in the United States sites
that have five thousand to
9999 sessions per day that means that
they're approximately 310 web properties
contributing to this report okay based
on this criteria I chose now if my site
is similar meaning if I'm in the United
States if I'm in education and I'm
receiving 5 000 to 9 999 sessions per
day then I'm able to compare my site
against 310 other websites now Google's
sharing this data anonymously from the
other websites and they're doing the
same with your website to those
particular websites benchmarking reports
okay so it's a shared data anonymously
in particular Industries and verticals
and so now I'm looking at a channel
report so if I want to see how I compare
to others in my industry then I can go
ahead and see by channel for example in
my driving as much traffic as others in
my industry and you can see I'm not in
fact I'm 76 77 percent worse in terms of
the amount of traffic being driven from
organic search so anything in red is
going to show as a negative result a
negative comparison whereas something in
green is a positive comparison so if I
look at engagement I can see that I
might not be driving as much traffic but
I can see that the pages per session are
better than the side average or the
industry average I can see if I go over
again again looking just at organic
search I can see the bounce rate is
better than the industry average so the
channel report under benchmarking allows
you to measure how you compare to others
in your industry and you could do so by
looking at location and devices so if
you opted into benchmarking when you set
up your account then you'll be able to
compare your website against others in
your industry in your country region and
based on the size of your website in
terms of how many visitors or sessions
you're getting per day so let's go from
audience to acquisition so if audience
is who is coming to your website
acquisition allows us to see how the
traffic was driven to your website so
how do these users get to our website
and so under acquisition if we click on
overview we'll be able to see an
overview of how users whether they're
returning are new came to our website
and so what what analytics does by
default is they have a number of default
channels and when we say channels we
mean analytics is grouping different
channels based on how users got to your
website meaning how did users get to our
websites they come via organic search
meaning do they type something into
Google and find you in the organic
listing analytics also groups users
based on whether they came to your site
directly meaning did they type in the
URL directly into the browser or did
they bookmark your website and come back
via the bookmark so they're grouping
users under direct they also group users
under referral meaning do they come from
another website they group users by
social do they come from a social media
platform like Twitter or Facebook if
you're running paid search meaning if
you're running paid search on say Google
then do they come from Paid search ads
now if you're running display ads on say
Google's Network Google's Display
Network that's a default channel so
analytics for group users there so if
they don't recognize a channel then
they're going to group it as others so
by default Google analytics groups users
and how they came to your website via
these default channels and so I can see
how many users came to the site from
each Channel now if I want to drill down
on this report I can click on all
traffic and then if I click on all
traffic I can go to channels I can look
specifically at the channels report and
so now I can see organic search again
over the last 30 days is the number one
channel driving traffic and they
represent approximately again you can
see this number here in parentheses next
to the raw number of users I can see
that number's about 56 percent so 56
percent of my traffic over the last 30
days came from organic search and so
those those are the number of users
again as a metric you're also going to
have sessions and you'll see sessions a
lot as a metric so users are broken down
between new and returning so every time
a new or returning user comes to the
website basically what they're doing is
initiating a session so you can have a
user who can come back multiple times
every time they come back to the website
it's a session so session is simply the
start of somebody coming to your website
and the session ends when they leave the
website and so just like we looked at
with the audience reports when it came
to mobile we can also look at engagement
by channel so just like mobile we looked
at bounce rate pages per session average
session duration we can do the same
thing here with our Channel report more
importantly in addition to behavior we
can see conversions and since we're
running it Commerce platform we could
see what the conversion rate is by
channel so organic search did drive the
most traffic and they did have the most
transactions over the last 30 days and
the conversion rate in this case is 0.17
okay so how Google determines the
conversion rate they basically take the
number of transactions and divide that
by sessions so that means that over the
last 30 days organic search drove 38 123
sessions and of those 38 000 123 64
actually turned into a transaction which
equates to 0.17 which also equates to 3
000 in Revenue so I'm able to determine
not only how users are getting to my
website by looking at the channel report
I can actually see if they're engaging
and if they are converting and notice
when you look at a report in analytics
you can look at by Channel you'll also
get a summary so here I can see a
summary or a total based on my date
range so I could see over the last 30
days I've had 54 000 users 49
000 of them were new okay that meant
that out of those 54 000 users I had 70
000 sessions I could see my average
bounce rate was 43 percent the pages per
session were just over four and the
average session duration how long did
somebody stay on my website on average
about two minutes and 55 seconds the
average conversion rate was 0.14 and I
had a total of 97 transactions totaling
fifty five hundred dollars okay and
that's all over the last 30 days so any
report you look at in analytics is going
to have a summary and note that any
to allow you to save it so if it's a
report you think you're gonna go back
and look at at a future day then you
simply just have to click on the save
button conversely if you don't want to
save it you can simply just export it so
you can export it as a PDF if I click on
PDF it's going to allow me to export
that as a PDF now you have other options
available to you as well you can do a
Google sheet you can export it as an
Excel or you can export it as a common
delimited file so here you can see I can
save it as a PDF if I want to and if I
click OK it's going to save to my
desktop or location of my choosing and
then I can go back and look at it in
that format at a later time so that's
the export feature available to you in
analytics again if you you could save it
as well or you can export it okay some
other reports under acquisition if
you're running Google ads note that you
can connect Google ads to analytics and
this is key because now I can see how
many people are coming from from Google
ads to my website and are they
converting now this is important because
with Google ads I'm actually paying for
the click so you can see here I'm
running a report based on campaign data
so I could see what campaigns are
driving traffic how much a pain per
click and you can see on average I'm
paying 34 cents per click and then more
importantly I want to be able to see if
they're converting so you can see I've
spent 810 dollars over the last 30 days
and received 858 dollars in Revenue so
you want to make sure that you link up
your Google ads account to your Google
analytics account for this very reason
you want to be able to see how your
Google ads campaigns perform once the
users get to your website and so I want
to see if they're engaging and I want to
see if they're converting so they're all
sorts of reports under Google ads so you
can look at it by key words by search
queries by hour of the day if you're
running display campaigns you can look
at display targeting says all sorts of
reports under Google ads you just have
to link it up and you link it up under
the admin now there are other reports
that you can look at so if I go to
campaigns I can look at all campaigns so
if you're running all sorts of different
types of campaigns whether that be on
Facebook whether it be email whether
that be you know other types of
advertising let's just say Twitter or
Instagram you're going to be able to see
those campaigns here and that's under
all campaigns and again you'll be able
to see the campaign name and you'll be
able to see metrics associated with
those campaigns and more importantly
you'll be able to see your e-commerce if
you're running e-commerce platform or if
you have goals set up so you'll be able
to look at how your campaigns are not
one not only driving traffic but two are
they converting screen let's go from
acquisition reporting to behavior so
Behavior reports are going to actually
show you how users behaved once they got
to your website once they landed on a
page on your website how did they behave
so when we looked at audience we got a
sense of who is coming with acquisition
we get a sense of how the traffic got to
our website did they come from organic
direct social Etc the behavior reports
allow us to actually measure how that
traffic behaved once they landed on a
page on our website and so if I go to
overview under Behavior now I'm looking
at this graph here it's showing me how
many pages I've had and a page view is
simply once a page is viewed it's
counted as a page view so if a user
comes to my site they're initiating a
session and if they look at a page then
that page is going to have a page view
okay so a user can look at a page
multiple times in a session and every
time they look at that page it's going
to count as a page view so here I can
see in this graph how many pages I've
had again over the last 30 days and if I
look further at my overview report I can
see the specific pages and how many
pages they've had and I can also look at
some other metrics okay the average
bounce rate the average time on page I
can look at the exit rate which means
how many people actually exited or the
percentage of people who exited from
that page so I can dig deeper into my
behavior reporting so if I click on site
content and I click on all pages then
I'm going to look at a report by Page
this is my Dimension this is what I'm
measuring my page and now I can see how
many page views each page had over the
last 30 days now note you also have
something called unique page views so
unique page use is equivalent to one per
session in other words if a user came to
my site and looked at the home page then
the home page is going to have one
unique page view and one page view now
if the user in that same session looks
at other Pages then every page that user
looks at it's going to have one unique
page view however if the user goes back
to another to the same page in the same
session then it's still going to be one
unique page view but in this case the
home page if they look at the home page
a second time then the home page is
going to have two page views if they
look at the home page five times in one
session then the home page is gonna have
five total page views and one unique
page view okay so that's why unique
pages is equivalent to one per session
where pages is an accumulation of how
many times the page was viewed in the
same session so in other words you're
always going to have more page views
than unique pages okay so this gives me
a sense of how my pages performed so
again I can look at total page views and
then engagement so ideally what you want
to do with a report like this is if a
user is not engaging on the page then
that should tell you something about the
page itself if they're not engaging if
the bounce rate's high if the time on
page is low if the exit percentage of
exit rate is high then you probably want
to do something with that page now these
are all pages but if I jump down to
landing pages my landing page report is
showing me how many people actually
landed on that page and so here I can
see under my landing page report I can
see the home page had 36 000 17 sessions
in the last 30 days that's how many
people landed on the home page so here I
can see 71 percent were news sessions
meaning that I had a lot of new users
who landed on the home page in fact 25
000 or 52 percent of the people who
landed on the home page were new I could
see the bounce rates about 42 percent
but of those who didn't bounce they went
on to look at about 4.5 pages per
session and spent about three minutes on
the site and the one thing I like about
the landing page report is I can also
see whether that particular page in this
case the home page did it help
contribute to a goal or conversion and
in this case I can see of those 36 000
sessions I had 22 transactions totaling
1200 in revenue and that's an e-commerce
conversion rate of 0.06 percent so the
home page over the last 30 days
contributed to 0.06 percent of the
revenue so this gives you an idea of
when somebody lands on your website and
they land on a page is that page helping
to move that person along meaning are
they not bouncing and is that page
helping to move people towards
converting and so that's what the
landing page in effect allows us to
measure is the engagement and in this
case we're measuring transactions okay
so analytics also gives us some other
reports under Behavior including site
speed so site speed to me is an
important report to look at just like
the mobile report to me site speed is
important because what Google analytics
does is they take a sampling of pages
and in this case you can see over the
last 30 days they sampled
2835 page views and of that sample they
came back and said the average page load
time is about four seconds now ideally
you want to keep it as quick as possible
I would say even under three seconds
okay now there are other factors
involved with page load time the browser
you're using the country that you're
actually browsing that page from mine
know how to have the best infrastructure
you may not even be on the best internet
Network meaning you're on a cell network
or the Wi-Fi is not that great or you
can be on a page that just has a lot of
images or a lot of code that may slow it
down so there are other factors involved
and so what Google analytics does is
show you what those factors are so here
I can see by browser with the average
load time is if I want to look at
Country I could see what country is
contributing to the load time now the
great thing about the site speed report
is if I go to speed suggestions okay
what speed suggestions is going to do is
it's going to show me the page load Time
by Page and then it's actually going to
provide a link where I can actually
click on to get suggestions on
increasing the page load time so for
example I can look at this particular
page here this Google redesign shop by
brand slash YouTube page line number
five if I look at line number five I can
see the average load time of this page
is eight seconds almost nine seconds
okay that's an eternity to some people
now notice this link next to it so
Google's recommending seven total
suggestions so if I click on seven total
what it's actually gonna do it's gonna
open up a new window and it's going to
open up another Google report called
page speed insights and Page speed
insights is going to give me some
information about what I can do to
create correct correct the page load of
that particular page so look at the site
speed report it's important because
there is a correlation between site
speed or page load time and user
behavior of that page and there's also
correlation between page load time and a
page ranking organically on search so
page load time is very important it's so
important that I'm even going to save it
so I'm going to click save and click on
speed site speed suggestions as my name
and click OK and now that report is
going to be saved under customization
under save reports let's jump from
Behavior to conversions now conversion
reporting is arguably the most important
section in in Google analytics because
what the conversions reporting allows us
to do is see how people are converting
or if they're not converting on our
website and so in Google analytics we
have the opportunity to set up goals now
you have the opportunity to set up 20
goals in your Google analytics View and
so to set up a goal okay so you're going
to click on admin and Under The View
you're going to see goals and so if you
don't even have goals the first step is
to create goals and so you have four
different goal types in analytics so you
have pages session so how many pages per
session is so if your goal is set to say
three or two if somebody actually looked
at two or three pages per session it's
going to count as a goal okay so if I
look here I could see I have pages per
session set at 10. so that means that if
a user came to the site looked at more
than 10 pages per session then it's
going to count as a goal another goal
type is destination so destination means
that if somebody actually went to a
specific page then it's going to count
as a goal and in this case I can see
here that the goal is set to this
particular page here and so when
somebody actually lands on that page
it's going to count as a goal now there
are two other goal ties we can look at
one is duration so just like pages per
session in our previous example is
somebody looked at 10 pages per session
it's going to count as a goal with
duration it's based on time time so in
this particular case if you set up a
duration goal and the duration is set to
say one minute and 30 seconds then that
means if a user comes to my website and
they spend at least one minute and 30
seconds then it's going to count as a
goal okay and then the fourth type of
goal in Google analytics is an event
based goal so when you set up event
tracking you could turn that event into
a goal so if somebody clicks on say the
submit button of a form you can turn
that event into a goal so here you can
see the category equals contact form so
you can always verify if a goal works
just by clicking on verify this goal and
in this case this event is turned into a
goal so anytime somebody fires this
event it's going to count as a goal so
you have four different goal types in
Google analytics you have pages per
session destination event and duration
and so so once you've set up a goal then
you can measure goals under conversions
so now if I look at goals overview I can
be able to see how many total goal
completions I've had so if I want to
look at it by goal I can just choose the
goal option here so if I want to look at
for example goal 2 engaged users this
was the pages per session I can see that
I had a conversion rate of 10 meaning
that I had 7 000 of all the users that
came to the website 7 000 gold
completions meaning
7106 users looked at 10 pages or more on
my website and so that's how you want to
be able to measure whether users
wherever they're coming from whoever
they are whatever Pages they look at you
want to be able to look at the
conversion reports to see if they're
actually converting based on the goals
you've set up whether that's pages per
session duration and destination or
event gold conversion tracking reports
can help you measure who is actually
converting and the great thing about
Google analytics here is that I can
actually see by segments so the default
segment in a segment is just looking at
a specific user set so the default
segment is always all users however I
can choose a different segment so if I
want to choose instead of all users if I
want to choose Mobile Traffic I can
select Mobile Traffic hit apply so I'm
actually now looking at a subset of data
I'm looking at mobile traffic so if all
the mobile users have come to my site I
can see 1400 engaged or looked at 10
pages or more okay and that's a seven
percent conversion rate so the great
thing about Google analytics is you have
the opportunity to set up four different
goal types okay based on those goal
types you can go to goals over View and
look at the conversion rates of each
goal but you can also change the
segments of that particular goal to see
who exactly converted okay another
report I like under conversions is the
multi-channel funnel report so if I
click on multi-channel funnel basically
what this allows me to do is see how
different channels work together to
convert so remember the channel
reporting we looked at under acquisition
here I can see now how different
channels work together to drive the
conversion so if I look at three
channels direct organic and referral I
can see all three together drive two
percent of the conversions if I look at
direct and referral twelve and a half
percent if I look at direct and organic
12.24 so I can see how different
channels work together and so if I look
at top conversion paths as an example I
can actually see what channels how how
channels work together to drive the
conversion so in this example I can see
over the last 30 days that my top
channel grouping was direct times two
meaning that somebody came to the
website directly meaning they typed in
the URL in the browser or they
bookmarked it and came to the site okay
they came the first time but didn't
convert but then they came back a second
time via direct and then converted so
that combination is my top conversion
combination of the last 30 days my
second best conversion grouping is
organic search and direct meaning that a
user came to the website via organic
search first did not convert and then
came back via direct the second time and
converted so basically what analytics
does is give credit to the last referral
meaning if you came to the website via
referral or referring website and
converted then the ref referring
websites gonna get the credit for the
conversion but analytics does a good job
of showing you how different channels
work together so a channel may drive a
lot of traffic like organic search but
that traffic may not convert the first
time around for a number of different
reasons whether it could be brand
recognition Price shopping reading
content whatever the case analytics is
able to measure if that channel actually
did contribute at a later point and in
this case we could see organic search
drove traffic that didn't convert but
that traffic came back a second time via
direct and did convert so that's our
second best Channel grouping and so the
multi-channel funneling Report top
conversion pass to me is a good report
to look at so you can actually see not
only at channels work together but you
can see sources and mediums and
campaigns and how all that all those
different campaigns and different
sources work together to convert so
that's just a good report to look at
there are so many different reports
available in analytics there's so many
that we haven't even gotten to yet so my
advice if you look at the demo report
you can get a feel for each of these
reports under each section whether that
be audience acquisition Behavior or
conversions take a look at these reports
see what makes sense to you see what you
can use to improve your website
performance if you are looking to become
an SEO professional then look no further
than simply runs postgraduate program in
digital marketing so don't miss out on
this opportunity Find the course Link in
the description for more information so
if I go to Google analytics and I log in
okay what I want to do is go down to
admin click on admin here and admin will
take you to basically a screen that
looks like this where you have an
account column you have your property
column and then you have review column
now the The View column is where you're
going to go to set up goals okay so
every view in every property has up to
20 goals okay so by default in analytics
you're going to have at least one view
for your property so if I have a
property I'm gonna have at least one
view but if I happen to set up multiple
views like you see here then I know for
every view I set up I have 20 goals to
work with so where are those goals so
Under The View I'm going to click on
goals and now I could see I have 20 at
my disposal now you can see here by
clicking on the recording column I can
see I have in this particular property
this particular view I have five goals
that are active so you can use up to 20
but you don't have to have 20 active
Okay you can have one active two active
my recommendation is at least have one a
goal again when you set up a goal you're
going to measure everything in analytics
against that goal okay so in this case
we have five particular goals we're
measuring so we have five active out of
20 total so if I don't know no longer
want to use a goal I could simply just
turn it off if I want to continue using
it just turn it on okay it's that simple
you could turn on and off goals so here
I already have five set up so if you
want to set up a new goal the one thing
you need to know in Google analytics is
in order to set up a new goal okay you
need to have edit access at least the
view level I would say at the property
level so you want to make sure whoever's
in charge of Google analytics for your
organization or if you're in charge okay
you simply just want to go to user
management and user management you want
to make sure the email address you're
using to log into to Google analytics
has at least edit permissions so you're
going to need edit permissions to add
new goals so I have edit permissions I'm
going to go to goals and I want to set
up a new goal but before we jump in and
set up a new goal what is it that we
want to achieve that's really the
question we want to ask ourselves what
is the goal of the website well if it's
somebody downloading something okay are
you measuring that download via an event
okay are they filling out a form
submission before they download so if
they submit that form submission is that
the goal or do you have any Commerce
site is somebody purchasing something so
these are things you want to ask
yourself before you actually set up the
goal what is it that I'm trying to
measure now when you actually do go to
set up a goal you're going to click on
the red CTA button that says new goal so
analytics actually has some templates
set up for for you okay you can see them
here okay if you're somebody's
registering online or creating an
account or reading review downloading
something sharing something you could
choose all of these options here what I
normally do is choose custom 99 of the
time I'm just going to choose custom it
doesn't really matter if you use the
template or not it's just a template is
basically some free pre-filled
configurations but my recommendation is
always just go with custom you want
total control over how to set up your
goal so we already have in mind what
type of goal we want to set up so for
example if somebody goes to fill out a
form submission and they go to a thank
you page after that well what's the URL
of that thank you page we want to be
able to track how many people go to that
page because we know if somebody does
type in or fill in a form submission and
go to that page we know that they filled
out the form and so for example if I go
to continue I'm going to name my goal
first so I'm going to say thank you page
as an example notice analytics is
assigning an ID so notice this is goal
ID 15. that means that that's the next
available goal there are 20 goals
available in analytics and so what
analytics does is they group goals
together so one through five six through
ten eleven through fifteen sixteen
through twenty into goal sets so for
example goal 16 through 20 is part of
goal set for and why does Google
analytics combine these goals into
different goal sets well because it's
easier to measure and look at data by
goal sets so for example if I jump into
any report here if I go to all traffic
channels and I want to measure or how
many goals by Channel I can look at it
by goal set so if I have goal set one
selected then I know any goal I have
active in there between goal ID one
through goal id5 I'm gonna be able to
see those goals and goal set one and now
I'm going to be able to measure every
goal I have active and goal set one
against the channel so if I choose goal
set two whatever goals are active there
goal set three Etc notice I don't have
any goals 16 through 20 active that earn
goal set four therefore I don't have
that option available to me so back to
admin the bottom left navigation again
goals okay we want to measure somebody
going to the thank you page we have edit
access we're going to choose custom as
our goal setup we're going to type in a
goal name I'm just going to say thank
you okay this is goal 15. now this is
the important part Google analytics has
four different goal types destination
operation pages per session or screens
per session to screens per session is
related to mobile because Google
analytics measures mobile app activity
and then you have an event so we're
going to cover all four of these but for
the sake of this simple example I'm
going to choose destination why because
if somebody goes to that thank you page
we're going to go ahead and put in the
thank you page as the goal the goal URL
so for example destination is my choice
I'm going to click continue now this is
where I'm gonna put the URL so if my URL
is just simply thank you.html I can just
go ahead and put thank you.html or if
it's just thank you then I can just do
thank you depends on the website depends
on the URI structure so whatever that
URL is that's what you're going to put
in and when you're done you can verify
it so what Google analytics does is
actually will verify over the last seven
days if anybody's actually gone to that
particular page so if we click verify we
can see zero percent conversion rate so
that tells us that if this is the
correct URL then we've had zero percent
people go to that page this is just an
example however if you didn't see a
conversion then you might want to make
sure you check the URL here that you put
in and if you do see a conversion rate
then you know it's working so Google
analytics actually has options so we're
saying thank you is equal to so the
destination URL is equal to thank you or
thank you.html or thank you dot ESP or
whatever that thank you page is okay you
do have options so if you have a long
URL you could say it begins with and you
could say it begins with say thank you
so this is the logic we're going to say
hey if anybody goes to a rear URL that
begins with thank you thank Canada's a
goal or you could say equals two so if
anybody goes to a URL that equals two
thank you then count it as a goal you
have one more option Here regular
expression so Google analytics
understands the language of regular
Expressions so regular expression
expressions are just special characters
used to communicate with Google
analytics in order to hone in on exactly
what you're trying to track so we can
always say you know starts with or ends
with so we can you know use characters
like the dollar sign ends with or begins
with so we can always do that so you can
use regular Expressions as well if
you're familiar with regular Expressions
if you're not then you don't have to use
them but there are special characters
where that you can insert in that are
used as regular expression so if you're
not familiar with regular expression
don't choose that option you could
choose the the other option of equals to
or begins with now note that on all
three of these options I didn't put the
domain so if my domain is Amma Dash
foundation.org slash and then thank you
I don't need to put the domain because
analytics is already knows what domain
we're tracking so you don't have to put
in the domain here when you're entering
in in this case the Google URL so you
can omit the domain so when you put in
that URL you know that you have three
options to work with and then you always
always want to verify that goal URL you
always want to verify it because if you
see zero percent conversion and in this
case of the last seven days then that
should tell you something either your
goal is not set up correctly or you just
don't have any conversions either way
you want to double check that now when
it comes to the destination URL goal you
do have have an option here for funnel
so if I turn on funnel then that means I
have the ability to track how people
went through my funnel so if I have a
cart and I want to be able to check how
many people go in and out of the cart
then I have the option of adding
specific Pages as part of the cart so we
could say you know step one which is
basically cart we could say step two is
billing information that could be slash
billing we could see step three is
shipping information slash shipping and
then step four could be you know confirm
and that could be slash confirmation so
whatever your url structure is for your
cart and it doesn't necessarily have to
be a cart basically all I'm doing is
putting a series of steps with URLs as
each step and why do I want to do that
because I can then track how many people
go through my funnel that I've created
okay so here I could see this is my
funnel that I've created for this
particular goal okay and the funnel is
only available for the destination URL
so the funnels available if you want to
see traffic through the goal okay and
how people go through the funnel and
where they drop off now you have an
option here to make the first step
required so if you make that first step
required then that means you're
measuring the funnel through the first
step only now if I turn that off then
I'm measuring the funnel through each
step meaning that I can measure people
as they drop in and out of the funnel
where if it's required the first step
then I'm only measuring traffic as it
enters in the top of the funnel so you
have that option available to you the
funnel and then for all goals you do
have a value so if somebody did actually
convert okay go Google analytics is
going to count it as a conversion and
you can assign a value so if you're not
an e-commerce website then you may want
to think about assigning value if you
are an e-commerce website then analytics
has the ability to track e-commerce
revenue for your website so you don't
need to add a value but in this case
let's just say your non-profit
organization and you're collecting
donations
and on average over the past year every
donation that somebody contributed was
equal to five dollars well you can just
go ahead and put five dollars in there
as the value for that goal so that means
that if somebody did go to in this
example slash thank you and convert
analytics is going to count it as a goal
and then assign five dollar value
alongside that goal so if you're
non-ecommerce if you're say a non-profit
like this organization or your B to be
and you want to track some value then
you have that option there so with the
destination URL goal you have the option
of adding a funnel with all goal types
you have the option of adding a value
all goal types and we're going to go
through the rest of them you have the
option of verifying that goal so that's
the structure of setting up a goal
destination URL is just one goal type
we're going to talk about the other
three goal types because in Google
analytics there are four goal types
again destination is one of them with
destination as you do have the option
with all goal types is you have to be
able to choose your logic here so we're
going to cover that with the other three
but just know when you set up a
destination URL goal you have the option
of adding a funnel now when you actually
do set up a funnel what's going to
happen is analytics is going to measure
traffic as it goes to the funnel so
where do you look for that funnel
information Nation well you want to get
out of admin you want to go to the left
side navigation you want to click on
conversions then goals then funnel
visualization So based on the funnel you
set up you're going to be able to see
traffic as it goes through the funnel so
notice on this particular funnel we
don't have the first step required why
because I could see traffic as it goes
in and out of each step of the funnel so
let's go through this funnel and see how
people react so here I could see the
first step is the store front page so
over this particular period of time I
had 84 sessions enter the storefront
page so out of those 84 I can see 21
left the storefront page 63 went on to
the next step in the funnel which is the
cart page I can then see 24 people went
on to the cart page directly and file
I've exited the site all together okay
so that gave me 87 total and from 87 I
saw that 82 went on to the next page for
the next step what analytics does is
they give you a percentage so in the
first step we had 63 move on to the cart
page out of 84 that's 75 percent so from
the cart page to the create your account
page we had 94 move on so we didn't have
anybody enter in the create your account
page we didn't have anybody leave to
create your account page so if 82 82
create your account and then we have 82
move on to the payment page so that's a
hundred percent okay we have one exit so
we have 81 that proceeded to beyond the
payment page which was purchase so 81 of
82 is 98
and we started with 84. so that gave us
plus the 24 that we accumulated along
the way so that gave us a 75 percent
funnel conversion rate so 75 percent of
the people who entered in the funnel
went on to purchase okay so don't be
confused with the overall e-commerce
conversion rate so 75 is the funnel
conversion rate the overall conversion
rate for this particular goal is
18.45 over this particular period of
time why because that takes into account
all sessions that have won to the
website so 18 of all traffic went on to
convert but those that did go into the
final 75 percent converted so that's a
look at the funnel so if you set up a
funnel that's what it's going to look
like you have the option to measure
everything from step one and Beyond or
measure as traffic goes in and out of
the funnel so the purpose of this is
we're going to be able to see where
traffic drops off how effective our
funnel is what pages we need to address
in that funnel okay so that's the whole
point of the funnel and the funnel is
available with the destination URL goal
so if I go back to admin if I go back to
goals Under The View I can actually see
what that funnel looks like so here we
chose regular expression so this is what
the URL is okay you can see our funnel
in each of the steps we have set up
notice we're using regular Expressions
here and then if we verify this goal we
could see over the past seven days 19
conversion rate so that tells me
something's working in this particular
with this particular goal because we do
have a conversion rate okay so that's
the destination URL goals let's now talk
about the other three types of goals so
the next goal type we're going to talk
about is pages per session so if you're
not sure what type of goal to set up for
your website at the very least you
should try and set up either duration
related goal or pages per session
related goal so let's talk about the
pages per session so basically what this
goal is going to allow us to measure is
for example if we set the goal to three
pages per session then we're going to be
able to measure if how many people went
to the site and looked at three pages
per session so let's take a look at that
goal so if I open up the goal here I can
see three pages per session is what
we're naming it so basically what we're
asking analytics to do is anything
greater than two pages which would be
three and Beyond count as a goal so if
anybody comes to the site looks at more
than two pages three pages or more then
it's going to count as a goal and so
here we can verify it so if we verified
over the last seven days we could see a
4.12 conversion rate and that tells me
that four percent of my traffic over the
last seven days looked at at least three
pages or more so you're probably asking
yourself well what number should I put
in for the actual variable so in this
case we see two well what you want to do
is you want to look at on average let's
just say year to day you want to make
sure you have statistical significance
so you want to look at a period of time
so if you go to analytics go to audience
okay and then if you go to overview and
if I change my date range to year to
date I could see on average right now I
have 1.21 pages per session so that's on
average
so we don't want to make our goal one
page we don't want to make our goal two
pages we want to make it three so we
want to be able to basically measure at
a higher rate okay why do we want to
measure at a higher rate because if 1.21
is the average then two pages per
session really isn't moving the needle
so what we really want to do is get
people to stay on the site longer look
at Pages more during their session so
look at more pages and so we want to be
able to see what segment of the audience
is looking at more pages what channels
driving traffic that's looking at more
pages what pages are contributing to
more pages per session so the whole idea
is you want to hone in on what your goal
is and see what's working and then see
what's not working so you can make
adjustments the whole idea be on Google
analytics is to improves website
performance and so if our average is 1.2
then if we change it to just 2 it may
not be good enough so in this case you
know we want to up the bar a little bit
so we're going to choose three now you
can choose four or five that's perfectly
fine just know if your average is 1.2 I
wouldn't choose one page per session as
my goal and I probably wouldn't choose
two so I'd set the bar a little bit
higher now the third goal type available
in Google analytics is also engagement
related and that's duration so just like
pages per session we can measure how
long somebody stays on the website and
we could set up a goal for that so in
this case I have a goal set for one
minute 30 seconds so my goal type is
duration so if I click continue then
basically I'm asking analytics in this
case anybody who stays more than one
minute and 30 seconds on the website
count it as a goal and so so before you
actually put in the number of hours
minutes and seconds you want to look at
that average so if you go back to
audience overview here I can see a
minute and seven so do we want a minute
and 30 maybe we could do that maybe we
can go with two minutes so again the
whole point is you want to set the bar a
little bit higher than what the average
is and so here I could see over the last
seven days if I verify this particular
goal I can see eight percent of my
traffic over the last seven days stayed
on the site at least one minute and 31
seconds okay they stay greater than one
minute and thirty and so the whole point
is you can hone in because this is a
goal I can go in this is goal okay this
is a goal here and so I could see that
this is gold 13. so now I can go to
acquisition as an example I can go to
channels as an example since this is I
go this is goal 13 so that would be in
goal set three so I can actually see
what channel is basically driving that
goal okay in other words what channel is
driving traffic that is staying on the
side at least one minute 30 seconds and
so that's the whole idea behind goals so
likewise for pages per session we can go
into channels and here I can see we have
a over this period of time year to date
pages per session we have three percent
conversion rate and here I could see for
example organic search has a 13
conversion rate here I could see social
media has a 10 so I could see that or
people coming from organic search are
staying on the site longer or they're
looking at more pages than any other
channel so just like duration or
destination or any goal you set up you
can measure that goal against any
Dimension just because his engagement
doesn't mean you can't you absolutely
can and so the whole point of Engagement
related goals is to figure out what's
driving traffic the site but what
traffic is engaging so you want to be
able to pinpoint that so you can improve
website performance now the fourth goal
type available in Google analytics is an
event so if you click on new goal
include custom click continue you have
the option to choose an event so an
event is something that you can measure
on your website that analytics can't
measure by default so if you want to
measure PDF downloads or clicks on
buttons or clicks on play buttons on a
video or click on a submit button or
click on an external link I mean you can
measure pretty much anything with an
event then you want to be able to turn
that event into a goal so let's quickly
summarize what an event is so again we
want to be able to measure a particular
event that happens on the website so in
order to do so we need to identify that
event so if I go to for example this
particular website here and I want to
measure how many times somebody clicks
on the Donate Now button well if I met I
can measure that as an event so when you
set up an event in analytics you have to
actually assign a category and an action
for that event so that's the first thing
you need to do when you identify an
event or let it go first you need to set
up the event in order to set up the
event you need to assign a category in
action okay so once you identify what
you want to track as an event on your
website you're actually going to go on a
tag manager or have your web Master go
on a tag manager and set up a tag and in
that tag they're going to assign that
particular category in action and so
here you can see we have this set up our
category is named donate now and our
action is click and that's what we want
to do we want to measure how many people
click on that donate Now button so
anytime somebody does that then the
category donate now is going to appear
in analytics with the action click so
when you actually do set up an event you
can go into analytics and you could test
that event so if I go to the website and
I click donate now Okay the reason why I
have this as an event is because I'm
taking to a third-party website to
handle the donations so here I can go
into analytics and now I can see a
category is being fired for header
donate with the action click so that's
my category and that's my action so that
category in action is what is firing
after somebody clicks on the Donate Now
button so if I want to turn this event
into a goal I can easily do that now
that I've set up the event now that I've
identified the category in action I want
to go back to admin and set up the event
with these parameters in place so just
turns out we already have the goal set
up so let's go through how this goal is
set up so first we chose custom we chose
event we gave it a name it has the best
practice when you actually set up a goal
as an event or turn an event into a goal
I would add the prefix event colon to it
and then that way when you're
identifying goals in your reporting you
know it's an event so I'm going to click
continue and now that I've actually have
set up the event already in Google tag
manager I giving it a category give it
an action okay see here you can see we
have a regular expression set up so
anything with the header donate or
donate is going to fire this goal so
over the last seven days I have a 0.81
conversion rate okay I could have easily
put in equals two and put in whatever
the action what or the category which is
donate now or I could have put action
equals click I could have done that as
well so let me show you another example
here so if I do this custom continue
events donate now here's my goal ID it's
going to be an event so all I need to do
is put in the category in action so
donate now and then click so that's all
I have to do and that's my goal so I can
verify it okay to see if anybody's fired
it and basically that's what I need to
do to turn that event into to a goal
okay so you need to set up for an event
first you need to identify the event set
it up and Google tag manager which is
another platform and once you've done
that then you have your category in
action once you have your category in
action you're again going to go into
analytics and then simply put in that
category and action into the appropriate
fields to set up your event related goal
now all events don't have to be turned
into a goal if you actually do set up an
event and you're not worthy of a goal
meaning it's not a kpi or a dozen align
with your business goals well don't fret
you can always just go to behavior okay
you can always go to events you can
always go to overview and measure your
events that way so here you can see all
of our events that are fired now we do
have this one turn into a goal so if
it's important for a business then we
want to make sure we we convert that
particular event into a goal okay if
it's not important for example
somebody's just clicking on a social
button then you don't necessarily have
to turn that event into a goal if you
don't want to know that it's sitting
here under events under Behavior so the
point I'm trying to make here if it's
important to your business and you're
already tracking it as an event via
Google tag manager then feel free to
turn it into a goal all you need is a
category all you need is that action and
so so one final note on that event
related goal just like any other goal
you can add a value okay so if I have an
event set up I can choose to add a value
here or in Google tag manager if I've
assigned a value to that event so if I
go back to the actual event and Google
tag manager you can see I have a value
set up for one dollar then I could just
go into analytics and say you know what
I already have the value added so go
ahead and use the value added in Google
tag manager okay so I'm going to choose
yes now if I choose no I have the option
to add the value here just like I would
with any other goal so just keep that in
mind you can add a value to any goal
type with an event related go you can
add the value right into the tag in
Google tag manager just as I've done
here so remember when you actually set
up your goals whether it's a destination
pages per session duration or an event
you can just go ahead and choose that
goal set that it's in and measure any
Dimension against that particular goal
so here I can see e newsletter sign ups
by Channel I can go into another goal
set here I can see contact form
submissions okay I can see what
particular channels driving contact form
submissions okay so just know that you
can align a goal against any Dimension
so if you have e-commerce you don't have
to set up for goal for that that's
separate but if you want to take a look
at your goals and analytics and on its
own you can just go to conversions goals
overview here I can actually get a good
sense of how my goals are performing
over a period of time so again if I
choose for example year to date now I
could see based on the goals I've set up
how many total goal completions value
which takes into account the value we've
added into these goals okay the total
conversion rate and here I could see it
broken down by the goal I actually have
set up and I can see it by Page or I
could see it by Source a medium so I
could see Google organic is driving the
most gold completions then Google CPC
direct and then I could see some others
in here as well out contributing to
goals now I do want to point your
attention to another report in Google
analytics that does take into account
goals and that's multi-channel funneling
so again under conversion goals
multi-channel funnels if I go to
assistant conversions I can actually see
what channel in this example is
assisting with the conversions I've set
up and so what do we mean by assistive
conversions well that means that if a
channel let's just say organic search
drove traffic to the website and that
traffic didn't convert when it arrived
at the website and left but it came back
a week later via another Channel let's
just say email and when they came back
via email they did convert during that
session well what analytics does is they
give an assist to organic search because
they help Drive the traffic to the
website so it's similar to the game of
basketball if I have the ball and I pass
it to my colleague and my colleagues the
one who scores because they had the ball
last well they get the credit for the
point I.E the conversion but I get an
assist and so analytics works the same
way they're always going to give credit
to the last click or direct conversion
but they will give credits to the
channel in this case that assisted with
the conversion so that's under a cystic
inversion and that's based on the goals
you have set up you can highlight any
particular goal here if I want to hone
in on say the Donate clicks only then
I'm going to be able to see what
contributed to that particular goal so
there's another report in here top
conversion pass that I think is
important so after you set up your goals
you can actually see what channels in
this particular example help to Drive
conversions again this is year to day so
I can see all the different combinations
of channels that work together
to contribute to a conversion so again I
can choose a specific goal or I can
choose all my goals so those two reports
are under multi-channel funneling
there's also another report that I think
is good that's time lag meaning how long
did it actually take somebody to convert
so here you can see most of our
conversions 265 year-to-date happen on
the day somebody arrived on the website
but I could see I did get some
conversions a day later two days later
Etc so you have time lag top conversion
pass assistant conversions they're all
under multi-channel funneling and
they're all available after you set up
at least one goal and so if you're not
sure what goal to set up okay don't fret
you can always at least set up an
engagement related goal so that's
available to you duration pages per
session you also have destination and
event tracking and they're all available
to you you have 20 available per view
now if you're not quite sure exactly
what type of goal to set up there is an
option available in analytics and that's
the gallery so you can always import a
goal from the gallery so in other words
we could take a look at what other
people have set up in terms of goals so
you just have to click on the button
import from gallery and it'll take you
to the gallery and you'll be able to see
what are the goals others have set up so
many of you out there have a website
similar to the one I'm looking at now
this is a non-profit that I work with
I'm a foundation and like this website
and probably like your website you
probably have some interactivity on
there that needs to be tracked for
example buttons uh if you have buttons
like this one that says donate or
newsletter sign up or there's a PDF
download or a video that needs to be you
know tracked based on the amount of
people who click on the play button so I
mean all sorts of inter activity on a
website have you ever wondered how to
track that well there is a way to track
that because by default Google analytics
can't track interactivity and engagement
on your website like you probably want
to have your website tracked so if you
have buttons and videos and things of
that nature that you want to have
tracked well you're going to need event
tracking and if you're in analytics and
you're always wandering around the data
and you happen to find yourself under
events well if you want events on your
website and you want data to populate
under Behavior top events you're going
to need to set up event tracking so
event tracking is a two-part process and
we're going to talk about about that
two-part process the first part of that
is to identify what you want to track
okay so if we go back to our example
website here I'm a foundation again we
noted there's a lot to track here we
gotta donate now Bob we got a newsletter
sign up we have some social icons okay
we got a donate Now button here we got a
play button here got all sorts of
interactivity you know we got a button
here that says you know purchase tickets
for an upcoming event I can go
throughout the website and find
different buttons and things to to track
let me just say this there's no shortage
of what you can track on your website
with event tracking so event tracking is
just basically in layman's terms
tracking engagement on your site because
Google analytics by default is only
going to track page view data meaning
how somebody got to your website what
page they looked at how long they stayed
on that page what page they left from
more or less their timing how long long
somebody stays on the website and what
pages they look at so there's more to a
website than just how long somebody
stayed on a page and so in this example
we want to be able to track everything
here not just the donating album but
everything because once you get the hang
of event tracking then it's very easy to
set up okay so step one identify what
you want to track okay so there's a lot
we want to track we're just going to use
one example to start off with and that's
going to be this donate Now button okay
so this donate Now button we want to
track now we have a newsletter sign up
we have Facebook and and that's fine you
could track all that but for the sake of
going through a step-by-step process
today let's just focus on the Donate Now
button what's focus on the Donate now
button then we'll come back and start
tracking these other things but this is
what we want to track to start out with
okay so step one identify what you want
to track now when it comes to tracking
events on a website you want to identify
to find those events so we did that by
choosing this donate Now button now once
we identify what we want to track we
need to assign two parameters for that
event so with event tracking you have
three parameters but one is actually
optional so you have two mandatory
parameters that you have to assign to
everything you want to track on your
website and that's the category and then
the action so event label or label is
the third parameter but again that's
optional okay so basically when we
identify an event on our website we want
to assign it a category and an action
okay so why do we want to assign it a
category in an action because when we're
in analytics under Behavior under events
top events we could see we have
different categories here and we have
different actions we have different
labels so if I click on any one of these
Dimensions I'm going to be able to see
the sum of the parameters I've entered
in for previous events I'm tracking okay
so the whole idea is you want to be able
to group different events together into
a category and assign an action and
assign a label to it that's really what
you're doing you're just grouping and
identifying the events you're trying to
track and so in this case I have this
donate Now button sitting in the header
okay in fact I have a lot of things
sitting in the header so if I wanted to
and I want to track all these buttons I
can create a category called header and
then if I track all these buttons all
these buttons can sit in that same
category if I wanted to or I can create
a separate category for each of these
buttons it's up to you how you organize
your categories because basically all
you're doing is giving a name to what
you're trying to track and the name is
equivalent to a category so in this case
the Donate Now button is very important
I'm just going to call it category
header donate now I need to give an
action to each category and so in this
case I'm just going to say click because
that's what the action is doing it's
it's somebody's taking the action of
clicking now if it's a video and it's a
play button I can assign an action of
play it's up to you whatever you name
these parameters you just need to be
organized and methodical about what you
name it that's all and so in this case
header donate and then click okay and so
that's our category in action and so
that's clearly step two so step one
identify what you want to track step two
assign a category action and or label
but remember label is optional so if I
go back into analytics here I could see
some categories and if I click on action
I can see some actions that I've named
now step three so we've identified in
Step One what we want to track we've
assigned a category in action so step
three is going into Google Google tag
manager to set up the event okay so if
you're not familiar with Google tag
manager then you can easily just you
know do a Google search for Google tag
manager and basically you'll have all
sorts of information on it there's a
good video overview of tag manager here
that you can watch so tag manager
basically is what we want to use to set
up event tracking now tag managers use
for a lot of different things but the
main thing we're doing here is setting
up an event for our website and so I'm
logged in to the same email address I'm
using for analytics okay so now I'm in
tag manager and I want to set up my
event for this donate Now button so what
do I need to do well for every event I
want to set up I need to set up a tag
okay so if I go to tags I can see I
already have some tags set up and some
of these are events and so when you
actually set up a tag I recommend having
a naming convention so here you can see
any event we set up we start out by
calling it GA Dash event Dash whatever
it is we're trying to set up and so in
this case we want to set up a new tag
for the Donate Now button on our website
so we're in Google tag manager because
tag manager is what's going to fire that
event so if I click on new okay and I
click on tag configuration I'm going to
choose Google analytics and then I'm
going to choose events as my track type
so we want the data to show up in Google
analytics and we're tracking an event
we're not tracking a page we're tracking
an event and so now remember in step two
you identified what you want to call
that category you identify what you want
to call that action and you have some
optional parameters like label so first
things first header donates the name of
our category and our action is click and
if you want to add in a label and a
value so if you want to sign a value you
can if you want to add in a label you
can okay those are optional so you just
need to focus on category action and
then the last setting here that's
probably worth mentioning is a
non-interaction hit okay so this is
automatically set to false and why is it
set to false because it's a
non-interaction no that's false we want
this event if somebody clicks on the
header donate to be an interaction so
for example if I land on this page here
and I click on that donate Now button
that I'm tracking as an event and I
actually leave the site because I have
my settings set to false I want that
click to be an interaction then
analytics is not going to count a bounce
if I change it to true so from false to
true then that means it is going to to
be a non-interaction if somebody lands
on the page and if somebody clicks on
the button so I don't want it to be a
bounce I want it to be an interaction so
my advice is leave it set to false we're
going to choose Google analytics as our
setting here this is our variable for
Google analytics so in other words that
variable is set to our analytics
property ID and more or less that's what
you need to do to set up the tag okay
you need to in step two identify the
category in action and or label and or
value now value can be anything you want
you're assigning a numerical value so if
you just assign one anytime that event
fires in analytics it's going to have a
value of one okay and so we have our
non-interaction set to false so anytime
the event fires it's going to count as
an interaction and therefore not count
as a bounce if somebody landed on that
page so that that's more or less all you
need to do to set up the tag and Google
tag manager now if somebody else is
setting up the tag for you then again
you want to revert to step two you want
to be able to give that person the
appropriate category action and or label
and or value why because you're the one
that's going to be going into Google
analytics and you're the one that's
going to have to go to behavior events
top events and look for the particular
at category in action and or label so
you need to be able to communicate that
information to whomever is setting up
the tag now if it's you great you
already know what it is because you're
entering that information into tag
manager so in this case I'm going to go
ahead and choose a variable for my label
parameter and why do I want to do that
because in tag manager I have something
at my disposal called very variables and
variables allow you to see specifically
things that are being tracked so in this
case I chose page path okay so pagepath
is a URL and why did I choose page path
as my variable for the parameter label
because if somebody does click on the
header donate button and the header
donate button on our website is on every
page so if I go to the children's page
I'm still going to see that header
donate button and so for me I want to be
able to see what page somebody clicked
on that header donate button and so this
allows me to actually see in Google
analytics what page somebody clicked on
the header donate Now button and so now
if I go back to GTM Google tag manager I
have a category I have an action and I
have a label which is a variable okay so
note that in Google tag manager you have
a lot of different variables at your
disposal and variables are there to help
you identify specifically what is being
tracked so take a look at all the
variables at your disposal and tag
manager in this example I'm using page
path so now once you set up your tag
pretty straightforward again tag types
Google analytics track type is event you
are assigning the category action end or
label and or value you're changing or
leaving the default in place for
non-interaction hit and then you're
choosing the variable for Google
analytics which is your property ID so
once you've done that you have a tag the
second part of setting up a tag is to
assign a trigger to that tag so tag
manager needs to be able to know when to
fire that event and so here I'm going to
look at a trigger I've already set up
for this particular event and so if I
click on it I'll be able to see that
what it is is a click on some links not
all links but some links I'm actually
saying Hey Google tag manager fire this
event when the click ID equals header
donate button now it just so happens
that if somebody did click on this
donate Now button they're gonna go to
another website in this case
networkforgood.com so in tag manager I
could have set the trigger to equal URL
equal instead of Click ID I could have
said URL equal
networkforgood.com so that could have
been my Logic for my trigger in this
case I decided to go with the click ID
and so in this case that button has an
ID associated with it called header
donate button so if you wanted to use
click ID for your event for your button
you could simply just us go to the
website you can right click on that
button and click inspect element and so
when I actually inspect the element I
can see now the button here you can see
it's highlighted in the upper Pane and
in the lower pane I can see where it's
linking to it's linking to
networkforgood.com but here you can see
if I hone in a little it I could see ID
equals header Dash donate dash button so
that's the click ID notice there's also
a class I could have set the trigger to
equal this class or again I could have
set the trigger to equal the URL or the
page that this button is pointing to I
could have chosen any one of those but I
decided to go with the ID so this is the
ID I chose and that's the ID I have in
my trigger okay so that is what's going
to fire that event so if somebody clicks
on a button that equals header Dash
donate dash button it's going to fire
that event which is going to equal
category header donate action click and
then the label is going to be page path
so now that we've set up our events we
want to test to see if it actually works
so there's two ways to go about testing
an event and the first way is through
Google analytics so if we go to Google
analytics and then we go to real time
okay we can go to events and here you
can see one is already fired so let's go
ahead and go to and test this and go to
the website so if I go here for example
and I click on omagar alumni okay so if
I click on that you can see I'm under
our family and if I click on that button
then go back to analytics and look at
real time I should be able to see this
event fire so if I click on it I'm going
to go to network for good now if I go
back to analytics here in real time
under real time under events per second
I can see that event firing category
equals header donate the action equals
click now if I click on the category
here I can see the label the label
remember was page path and here you can
see this event fired on the our family
page which was the page I was just on so
that's one way to test to see if your
event works and in this case analytics
recognize the event so it works it fired
and so therefore it's going to show up
under Behavior under events you can go
under overview or top events okay and
what am I going to look for in this case
I'm going to look for header donate okay
if I click on header donate as my
category I'm going to be able to see my
action and if I click on action I'll be
able to see my label in this case home
page and then later on when the data
propagates in Analytics I'll be able to
see under label the page that I clicked
on that header donate button which is
slash our family okay the second way in
which you can test to see if an event
fires is if you preview so if I click on
preview in tag manager okay I'm going to
go into preview mode okay in preview
mode allows you to see in analytics and
tag manager and on the website what tags
are firing so here I could see I'm in
preview mode now so I'm going to go to
the website and I'm going to refresh and
in my browser same browser I'm using for
tag manager I can see the tags that are
being fired on this page already okay
because I'm in preview mode so here I
could see remarketing I could see page
views I could see Google optimize I
could see some tags that are already
firing on this page now if I click on
this button here by holding down my
shift command and then click on that
button I'll be able to see that the tag
fired in preview mode there's my event
header donate and I can see it fired so
now I can see it fired in the preview
mode so in addition to Google analytics
in preview mode I could see that that
tag is fired and I know that it's
working so there you have it you have
two ways to test to see if the event
fires again you have real time in
analytics okay so in real time if you
just go up to real time all you need to
do is go down to events go to your
website click on the button if you see
it firing in real time then you know it
works the second version or second way
to test your event is through the
preview mode okay if you see it firing
in preview mode then you know it's also
working okay so let's rehash our steps
first step is we want to be able to
identify
what we want to track okay so it could
be this newsletter sign up it could be
click on a Facebook it could be anything
we want to be able to track an image a
click on a CTA button whatever we want
to track identify it second step
identify the category action and label
because that's what's going to show up
in Google analytics remember label is
optional variable or excuse me value is
optional third step go into tag manager
actually set up your tag and your
trigger so if you set up a tag and it's
an event name it GA Dash events that way
you can see in your list of tags in tag
manager what event tracking you have
already set up so when you set up your
tag you set up your trigger your trigger
is based on logic that can be a URL it
can be a click ID it can be a class ID
whatever you want to use to fire that
event and then once you do that you want
to test it you could test it in GTM or
you could test it in Google analytics if
it doesn't fire you want to tweak your
trigger if it does fire then great and
then one thing I would recommend is if
you're setting up various events for
your website as a best practice what I
would recommend is set up a spreadsheet
and in that spreadsheet you know you
want to put a note what's firing what
are you doing to fire it could be in
this case someone somebody clicks on the
Donate Now button in the header you want
to put the tag name in here the type
okay then you want to record your
category action and label and then the
great thing about events is you could
turn those events into goals and that's
as simple as going back into analytics
okay so if I go in analytics and I go to
admin and I go to goals if you set up a
new goal okay all you need to do is
choose custom click continue you're
going to to choose event as your goal
name and then from a naming perspective
in Google analytics for your goal I
would definitely put event first and
then click on header donate okay so if I
click now continue what is my category
it's equal to header donate my action is
click and so I can verify to see if this
is working and here I can see in
analytics that the goal would have a
0.22 percent conversion rate so that
tells me that the goal is working and I
can turn this event into a goal and when
you turn something into a goal in
analytics then you can measure it across
all dimensions that's what I would
recommend if the event is equal to a kpi
or business goal or it's of importance
it's something you really want to
measure okay if it's just a click say on
a Facebook button I wouldn't recommend
setting that up as a goal okay so once
you've set up your event you recorded it
in your spreadsheet it's firing you want
to be able to then go back into Behavior
back into events okay you can go to top
events okay so top events tell you by
category as a default what events are
firing or what category is firing the
most okay so if I choose my date range
here I can just go to here to date so
here I can see my enter donate button
fortunately for me has the most total
events now notice in analytics you also
see unique events and so the difference
between unique events and total events
is that unique events are equivalent to
one per session where total events means
that somebody can come to your website
initiate a session and click on that
button multiple times in the same
session so if I go to the alma
Foundation website okay I can click on
that donate Now button three or four or
five different times in the same session
so what analytics is going to do is
actually in that session count it once
but accumulate the number of clicks as a
total event for that session so you're
always going to have more total events
than unique events because in some cases
users May click on the button more than
once in the same session and so here I
can see total events unique events and
if I added a value to that event I
should be able to see it here so if I
added a dollar as an example to this
particular event because it had 164
unique events I should be able to see
164 as my value but since I see Zero
that means that I did not assign value
and so average value basically is just
giving me how much average I have per
event so it's taking into account the
number of or the value the total value 5
divided by the total number of unique
Pages or sessions and so because I don't
have value I'm not going to have average
value but here you can see because value
is optional here I can at least see how
many events or how many clicks I receive
for a particular button again it could
be a video if I clicked on this video as
an example I can see how many people
actually started it I could see the
unique and the total events and if I
click on label if I have a label
assigned then I'll be able to see what
page triggered that event so if we go
back again to our header donate button
back to category if we click on label as
our primary Dimension here we can see
the home page had the most unique events
been followed by the children's page the
contact form Etc so what you can do in
analytics you can also look at the pages
that have driven events so here I could
see the home page has a q simulated the
most total events followed by the
contact us so that's how you would look
at the data in Google analytics under
Behavior under events and then under top
events or overview is where you can
start analyzing your event tracking so
first you need to do identify it assign
a category action enter label set up
that tag and Trigger once you do that
once you test that it's working this is
where you're going to go to analyze the
data let's start out with why GTM so
let's just say you're Sam and you have
your own e-commerce website you want to
understand how people are interacting
with your website well Sam today's world
of websites contain a lot of
interactivity everything from videos to
PDF downloads to commenting to form
submissions uh to all sorts of chat
functionality interactivity going on
throughout the website so there's just a
lot that you need to track outside of
just page views and so really what GTM
does is they help you track all these
things I just mentioned everything from
somebody clicking on the play button of
a PDF to somebody clicking on the submit
button of a form to somebody entering in
something on a chat function so that's
what GTM is so why GTM because it helps
us track all that interactivity so all
GTM is is really allows you to really
place a piece of java code which is just
script and the script that's added to a
web page to collect information so
that's really what a tag is it's just
some script that gets put on a web page
in order for you to collect information
like page views clicks Etc and they send
it to third-party tools okay so that's
what GTM does it basically allows you to
take all these tags that collect
information and you can use them in GTM
so if you want to for example collect
how many people you know enter a chat
functionality and start chatting well
you're going to take that script and
you're going to put it in GTM and GTM
will then allow you to start tracking
that information so that's really what
GTM is it just allows you to put tags
into a container or think of it as a toy
box you have all these toys and you want
to track well you can put all those
those toys or tags in a toy box or
container and we're going to talk a
little bit more about that but before we
get into GTM let's just say you know
you're communicating with your developer
and there's a new user request on your
web page and you want to update the tag
well your developer considering it's
probably a small update your website is
probably gonna not um has hesitate and
is going to go ahead and turn around and
do it normally and so normally what
happens is the developer is going to go
to the website and update the tag well
what if you have a few things that you
want to track all those things I
mentioned before from downloads to
clicks to you know somebody checking out
to watching a video well your Web Master
your web developer is going to go well
hold on a second now all these requests
are going to take time I need to put
them into the work queue so to speak
well what happens is when they go into
work queue usually it's going to take
some time and in some cases you as a
marketer need to launch a campaign and
you want to get that tracking added to
the website in time for the campaign
launch so you want to go ahead and
quickly turn around the tracking for
that particular campaign let's just say
you're launching a campaign and you're
sending people to a landing page that
has a form submission and you want to be
able to track how many people click on
the submit button of that form
submission well if you need to turn that
around your developer's like well I need
to put that in a work queue the timing
isn't going to always work out between
you and your developer is my point and
so that's where GTM comes in because
there is a solution to update your tags
faster and that's Google tag manager so
when we say GTM that's what GTM stands
for Google tag manager it's a place for
you to add tags quickly and easily so
tags remember are just Snippets of code
that allow you to track things on your
website interactively interactive
actively and basically when you have GTM
you can bypass the webmaster and do it
quickly and easily so that's what GTM is
all about so why GTM because we just
identified two benefits one you could
track all the interactivity on your
website and two you can bypass your web
developer or webmaster and so that's the
benefit of GTM so the benefit you get
those tags tags updated very quickly via
Google tag manager okay so that's what
tag manager is so what we're going to
talk about today is specifically what
tag manager is and what it does we're
going to list some of the benefits of
tag manager we're going to show you how
it works and then we're going to show
you how to get started with tag manager
tag manager if you're not familiar with
working with webmasters and dealing with
JavaScript and tags and all this jargon
is just new to you today okay well don't
fret sit back we're gonna take it slow
this is an introduction into Google tag
manager again let's start out with what
is tag manager so we've already
introduced it to some degree because we
already introduces a tool where you can
put all your tags into a toolbox toy box
or container so to speak right and we
already already mentioned that hey you
can bypass your webmaster so you're
probably thinking well if I'm if you're
not familiar with tag manager how can I
bypass my webmaster well first of all
it's a free tool and it's a Google tool
hence the name Google tag manager and it
helps you really that's the main point
it's deploy and track tags on your
website bypassing your webmaster so
that's tag manager and so examples of
tags that can be deployed via Google tag
manager are numerous these are just some
examples like Google analytics
Facebook's pixel tracking or Google ads
There's No Limit into the number of
texts you can track and tag manager
there is no limit you can add any number
of tracking tags and tag manager okay so
some of the benefits well again I we
just listed two you can put any tag into
tag manager and track that onto your
website and we know you can bypass your
web developer or webmaster and what it
also does is it also allows you to test
and deploy your JavaScript codes quicker
so remember these JavaScript codes or
Snippets of codes are just there to
track certain things on your website
whether that be a page view or somebody
clicking on a play button or tracking
somebody who converts or even just goes
to your website so the biggest benefit
is you can take that snippety code let's
just say Facebook let's just say you're
growing Facebook marketing and you want
to put that Facebook pixel on your
website so that you could track people
who come from Facebook and convert well
you don't need to put that Facebook
pixel on your website you can go right
to tag manager and you can put that
snippet of code right in tag manager
really quickly and the other benefit
here is all tags are managed in one
place and that's that to me is really a
good benefit because when you start
adding tags on your website and you have
some tags and tag manager it just gets
very confusing so ideally all the
tracking codes you have on your website
needs to be in tag manager think about
that all the tracking so if you're doing
Bing or you're doing Facebook or you're
doing Twitter or you're doing in
LinkedIn and you're doing Google you're
doing all this type of marketing on all
these different platforms you're going
to have tracking code for all these
different platforms and instead of
putting all that code on your website
return gonna slow down the slow time of
your web page and website you want to
put them all in tag manager so they can
be organized and you know exactly what
you're trying to track and the other
great benefit of tag manager is there's
a versioning control so let's just say
you have added tags to your website via
GTM for the last six months well and
let's just say you add another tag
yesterday if you added that tag
yesterday and something doesn't work
well you can just roll back to a
previous version It's that simple so you
have versioning and that's that's a good
thing when you have versioning you can
control what gets published and if
something doesn't work after it gets
published then you can roll back to a
previous version so it's a a peace of
mind so to speak just because you've
added code to your site there's no
guarantee it's going to work and so you
can always control what version you're
dealing with in tag manager and we'll
talk a little bit more about that so the
biggest benefit here to me with tag
manager is you have event tracking and
so we talked about some of the things
you could track on your website from
videos from play buttons to somebody
clicking on the stop on the video or
pausing it all the way to somebody again
chatting or let's just say somebody
clicking on that purchase button on your
website okay and you want to track all
these different things these different
interactivities and buttons well event
tracking is what you're going to use to
track all those buttons and to me this
is the biggest benefit of tag manager
and I'll show you some examples as we go
along and if we didn't mention it
already I'll mention it again it is free
tag managers free there's no limit so
once you have tag manager going you can
add as many tracking codes as you want
there's no limit on the number of
tracking codes you can add to tag
manager Okay so so it's free and you can
use it to its fullest Advantage okay so
it's also high security meaning that it
has different levels of permissions okay
so you can have uh somebody just go in
and look at the different tags and
tracking codes you have in GTM or you
can ask somebody who is very familiar
with tag manager it can go in and add
the tracking code to tag manager and
then publish that tracking code when it
gets added so those are all the benefits
let's talk about how it works now
specifically how does tag Manager work
because you're like Rob okay again a lot
of jargon you know you you got tags and
JavaScript and and versioning and
Publishing and all this other stuff well
I know I'm throwing a lot at you at once
but just bear with me here okay so let's
start talking about how it actually
works so you have a website okay
whatever that domain is you have a
website and there's chances are on your
website you have some form of
interactivity whether that be a video
whether that be a Blog whether it be a
form submission you have a website with
some interactivity and let's just say
you're even thinking about getting ready
to launch some type of campaign on maybe
Google or Facebook and you want to drive
traffic to your website fair enough
you're joining the millions of other
websites that are out there that have
interactivity that also Drive traffic to
the website so incomes Google tag
manager and so tag manager is important
because again we know we want to track
people coming from that Facebook
campaign or that Google campaign and
interacting with our site so if you are
running Facebook and you are running
Google analytics well guess what you
want to put that tracking code in tag
manager so Google analytics being a
Google product works very nicely with
tag manager Facebook has its own
tracking code and but you still want to
be able to track people who come from
the Facebook campaign to your website so
you're gonna get that tracking code from
Facebook and put it in tag manager
that's generally how it works so so here
information from your website is shared
with another data source through tag
manager so think about that if I add
Facebook tracking code to tag manager or
let's just say a Google analytics
tracking code to tag manager tag manager
is the one that's pushing out and doing
all the heavy lifting they're the ones
that are controlling what code gets
fired and what code doesn't so if you're
putting the code in tag manager tag
managers controlling the code think
about it that way and let's show you an
example of what that looks like so here
I am I'm in tag manager I just went to
tag
manager.google.com and here I could see
a list of tags so in our conversation
we're talking about tracking Facebook
and we're talking about tracking Google
analytics well Google analytics is easy
because it's a Google product so here if
I look at all the different tracking
code I have on my website through tag
manager let's just take a look at Google
analytics so if you're going to use Tag
manager you might as well put the Google
analytics code in here so here I can see
I have Google analytics as a tag in tag
manager now for Facebook if I'm running
a Facebook campaign well I can take that
pixel tracking and put it in GTM as well
and here I can see Facebook pixel that
is that code is added to GTM I just
basically took what Facebook gave me and
put it in the Google tag manager so you
can see I can add Facebook and Google
analytics and again I can't stress it
enough any tracking code from any
platform I can add to Google tag manager
in order to track the behavior from
those sources so let's take a little bit
deeper dive into how tag manager works
so I just showed you an example of how
you could take Facebook and Google
analytics code and put it into tag
manager but if you're not familiar with
tag manager then how do I do that well
let's talk about the structure and how
tag manager works so when you have a tag
manager account you have a container
remember I mentioned Toy Box earlier you
have a bunch of toys if they're they're
code and you're tracking different bits
of code from different platforms like
Facebook think of those as toys and you
have a toy box okay well that's what
this code is and that's what a container
is the code is the code and that's going
to go into the toy box or container and
so the way tag manager works is you have
tags triggers and variables so if I take
my Facebook tracking code and put it
into a container I need to set up a tag
and a trigger okay so let's take a look
at what that is so first if I go back to
tag manager I'm going to have an account
and if I have an account I'm going to
have a container so here I'm just going
to click on an account with a container
and a container is nothing more than
what website you're adding the tracking
code to okay that's all the container is
we're just letting tag manager know this
is the website we're adding all the this
code too so you have tags triggers and
variables that's the structure of tag
manager so tags are just what it says
tags what are we trying to quote unquote
tag well if it's Google analytics that's
easy here I could see I have Google
analytics added so if I click on Google
analytics here's my tag and if I take a
little bit of a deeper dive there since
Google analytics is a Google product it
integrates already with tag managers
it's pretty easy I can just choose
Google analytics then I'm going to check
page view and that's my tag now every
tag needs a trigger okay so I need to
tell tag manager how or when to fire the
Google analytics tracking code so in
this case I'm going to tell tag manager
to fire on all pages so if I get
somebody a visitor to my website
analytics is firing on all pages so
whatever page that visitor lands on
Google analytics is gonna fire so that's
really what it comes down to is I have a
tag and I need to tell tag manager when
to trigger that tag that's really what
the structure of tag manager is it's
tags triggers and variables and
variables we're going to talk about here
in a couple minutes but do you have a
piece of code you're going to go ahead
and put that into tag manager you're
going to tag it and then you're going to
fire that trigger so let's take a look
at another example here if I go back
here you can see Facebook well here's my
Facebook pixel okay that's my tag so
when is it gonna fire well it's gonna
fire on a specific domain or subdomain
that's basically what we're doing we're
trying to tell GTM when to fire that
particular tag so those are the three
main components a tag okay which is
going to contain the JavaScript code
that you get from say Facebook work the
trigger so you're going to go into tag
manager and tell tag manager want to
fire that code that's the trigger and
then you have variables and so variables
are basically just additional
information that tag manager may need
for your tag and Trigger to work so
that's what a variable is it's there to
get the tag and Trigger to fire so
variables are divided into built-in and
user-defined variables so common used
variables include say page path or page
URL or hostname or click class again
they're there and these examples I just
gave you are there to get your tag and
Trigger to work think about it that way
they're just that's a component and if I
go into tag manager here and here on the
left side I can see variables so
remember I have built-in and user
defined so built-in means that tag
manager already built these for me so in
case I need to get my trigger to work
with my tag I can use a variable so
those are built in and then I have user
defined so these are what I Define these
are what I created and again the
variables are there to get the tag and
Trigger to work okay so that's the job
of the variable the job of the tag is to
host that JavaScript code okay in the
case of Facebook or analytics that's
where we're putting our code so here if
I click on AdWords remarketing again
it's a Google product so I don't really
need to even deal with code I'm just
going to select Google AdWords for
marketing okay so you can see GTM
integrates nicely with some of the other
Google products but let's just say you
have a Facebook pixel tracking code
you're going to choose custom and you're
going to put the code here so that's
part of the tag and then the trigger
again is there to get the tag to fire so
you're telling GTM when to fire the tag
and the variable is there to help you
make sure that that trigger and that tag
work together so that's how all three
kind of work together you need the tag
to put the code you need the trigger to
tell GTM when to fire the tag in code
and the variables there to help you
define when that tag and Trigger should
work or how it should work so again
review tags are they're just small codes
of JavaScript or tracking pixels on your
website and so tags are allowed to
manage events like scroll track and
remarketing clicks downloads files play
buttons you name it even clicks on
external links for example let's just
say you have a click uh or a Facebook uh
icon on your site and when somebody
clicks on it they go to Facebook you
want to maybe track that you're going to
create a tag okay the trigger is there
because you need to tell GTM when to
fire that tag so it's a certain
condition whether it's you know fire the
tag if the URL equals facebook.com or
some other condition so the tag can not
be created until the creation of the
corresponding trigger so tags and
triggers go together you can't just
create a tag and not have a trigger
otherwise your tag will never fire and
the variable is there again it stores
the information when defining a trigger
or transferring data to tag so a
variable has a variety of data okay so
you pick and choose the variable you
want to use with that trigger okay so
you're making sure that by defining a
variable you're making sure that you're
telling GTM how that trigger should be
fired so let's take a look at another
example here of how all three play
together if I'm in this account I'm in
this container if I look down here I can
see Google optimize that's another
Google product so what I'm doing here is
I just chose Google optimize as my tag
it's already integrated so what does
that mean I don't even need to deal with
any code I'm just going to select
optimize well we we have the tag Google
optimize but we need to tell GTM how to
fire that and so here we're going to
tell GTM to fire it on all pages so
that's basically a very simple example
because we're firing it on all pages so
if I want to look at something specific
again Facebook here's my tag here's my
code what's my trigger well my trigger
is it's going to fire on specific Pages
how do I know that well if I look at the
trigger here I could see the trigger is
a page view but I'm telling it to fire
on this particular hostname so the tag
and Trigger go hand in hand
[Music]
so how to get started with tag manager
so first things first you have to create
that account so you're going to go to
tag manager.google.com or you can do a
search for Google tag manager and you're
going to create your account and then
when you create your account what's
going to happen is you're going to set
up a container and when you set up a
container you have choices so you could
set it up for your website for an app on
iOS or maybe Android or you can even set
it up for amp except an accelerated
mobile page so most people by default
are probably going to set up tag manager
for their website and so when you do
that when you actually select website
what's going to happen is you're going
to get some Google tag manager code in
return and so the whole idea here is
you're going to do a swap what you're
doing is basically you're saying Okay
Google I'm going to take this Google tag
manager code and I'm going to put it on
my website I'm going to put it on every
page in my website so notice tag manager
has two scripts one goes in the head as
high as possible the other goes into the
body tag as high as possible and so what
you're doing is you're making a deal
you're putting this tag manager code on
your website and in return every code
you deal with whether that be Facebook
or analytics or optimize or remarketing
or whatever it is is gonna go in GTM
okay it's going to go into the Container
you created so you need the tag manager
code on your website in order for tag
manager to work okay so when you add
this code to your website then you're
free to start adding all sorts of tags
to your container but if you don't have
this tracking code on your website then
none of the tags you add to your
container are gonna work so that's the
idea behind the container and then one
thing I wanted to mention on the account
is it's a Google account so when you
create your account then make sure it's
the same account you use with say Google
analytics or some other Google product
that's a good best practice is always
use the same email address when you set
up your account so that it integrates
nicely across all the different
platforms meaning you can go from say
Google analytics right to Google tag
manager in one browser without having to
log out or log in okay so when you
create the account you're going to
create your container if you choose web
then you're going to be asked to place
code on your website and when you place
that code on your website then you are
free to start using tag manager and that
means you're free to start adding tags
so if you want to know more information
about installing Google tag manager then
what I would recommend is visit the
quick start guide website of GTM so
again if you're curious as to where that
code is located in Google tag manager
well when you create an account account
and you create a container that
container is going to have a specific ID
so if I click on that specific ID here's
where I can get my code okay so again
when I'm logged in to tag manager I'm
going to click on workspace but in the
top navigation I'm going to see my
unique GTM ID if I click on that that's
where my code is going to be located and
so again your code needs to go in the
header and there's another script that
needs to go in the body and if you're
not sure how to add the code to your
website well you can always click on the
quick start guide here okay and that'll
take you to a quick start guide page a
reference page related to Google tag
manager so let's talk about creating a
tag so once you get tag manager
installed I'm sure you're excited to get
going and create that first tag so let's
talk about how to create a tag in tag
manager so when you're in tag manager
all all you need to do is basically
you're looking at all your tags if you
click on tag in the left side navigation
you'll see all your tags and there's a
new button there so you just click new
and so basically what you're going to do
is you're going to create your first tag
and so what I would recommend once you
get tag manager installed on your
website I would recommend setting the
first tag up as Google analytics so that
will get you going with tracking page
views on your website when some when
somebody visits your website okay so
ideally that's what you want to do you
want to get Google analytics as your
first tag and tag manager so what I'm
going to do is because analytics is a
Google product it's already integrated
nicely with tag manager so I'm just
going to click on Google analytics it's
going to be a page view that's what I'm
tracking and now I have to set up a
variable and so what it's going to do
it's going to ask me to set a select a
variable and so what you're going to do
is you're going to select new variable
and what you're going to do is you're
actually going to go and add your
tracking ID here that's going to be your
variable so where do I get my tracking
ID and analytics well if I'm in
analytics I'm going to go to admin and
then under property settings I'm going
to see my tracking ID and all you need
to do then is go to tag manager and
paste copy first you got a copy over
that tracking ID then you're going to
get a tag manager I'm going to paste it
and then that's going to create a
variable for you and then when you
create that variable you're going to see
it in the drop down here so I've already
created it and basically that's your tag
with a variable then what are you going
to do you're going to set up a trigger
so see I have some triggers already set
up you're going to see a default trigger
already set up for you and that's going
to be all pages so ideally what you want
to do is you want to select all pages in
order for analytics to fire on all pages
so that's what we're doing we're setting
up a trigger we're basically telling tag
manager hey if I get a visitor to any
page on my website then I want you to
fire Google analytics so that's
basically in summary how to set up your
first tag and my recommendation is your
first tag should be Google analytics and
when you set up analytics you're going
to have to set up a variable for the
tracking ID and so you get the tracking
ID again from admin property settings
copy and paste that tracking ID over
save it you have your variable that
variable is going to be included in with
the tag then your trigger is going to be
all pages and there you go you have your
first tag you have your first variable
you have your first trigger so that's
basically what you want to do and once
you've added that tag once you've added
that trigger then the only thing you
need to do now is basically publish the
tag and so anytime you save a tag you're
going to go ahead and submit it so that
way it gets published so again what
you're going to do is let's take a step
back here you're going to choose new tag
you're going to choose analytics from
the drop down menu you're going to
choose page view then basically you're
going to add your tracking ID so you can
set up the variable and then basically
that's what you need to do okay you're
going to add that tracking ID and then
voila that's your tag with a variable
and then once you've done that then
you're going to click submit so when you
click submit you're basically saying Hey
I want this tag to go live now this tag
and Trigger and once you've done that
then analytics is ready to go and
anytime somebody goes to your website on
any page tag manager is going to fire
Google analytics so the great thing here
is you have something called Google tag
assistant and that's an extension that
works with chrome and so when you've
actually add a tag manager to your site
or or you have analytics running in tag
manager you can confirm if those tags
are firing properly so let's take a look
at how Google tag assistant works okay
so if you just do a search for Google
tag assistant you're going to see here
that it's basically just an extension
that works in Chrome and unfortunately
it only works in Chrome browser it
doesn't work in any other browser so go
ahead and install that extension into
Chrome and when you do that you're going
to see this nice icon here in your
browser and now if you go to any website
and I click on Google tag assistant and
I click on enable Okay so basically I'm
loading Google tag assistant and now
once I refresh the page I can see that
this particular site has Google tag
manager installed and not only does it
have tag manager installed I can see
that it's also has Google analytics
running I have also Google optimized
running and I have Google ads remarking
tag running and tag manager so that's
what tag assistant does it allows you to
see if one tag manager is on the site
and if it is great what other tags are
firing on this particular site so tag
assistance telling me I have these
particular tags firing on that site and
they're firing within tag manager so tag
assistant is a great way to confirm if
one tag manager is on the site and two
what other tags are firing on the site
now another way you could confirm if tag
manager is firing on the site is you can
go into preview mode so even before you
submit and publish your tag and Trigger
you can click on the preview mode so if
I click preview in tag manager so
basically that's going to put me in
preview mode and so what does that mean
well that means that now I'm free to go
to my website and see if those tags are
firing and so let's take a a look at
what that looks like so if I go to the
website and just click refresh then
what's going to happen is tag manager is
going to load in preview mode just as
you see here okay so that's going to
take a second couple seconds to load up
and now what can I see in preview mode I
could see that I have GTM firing but I
also have some other text fine on this
page remarketing I have Google analytics
I have Google optimize I have some other
tags firing as well and so the preview
mode shows me what tags are firing on
any given page and I can also see what
tags did not fire okay so here I have a
number of tags already in GTM but they
didn't fire on this particular page so
let's just say I clicked on the Donate
Now button I'm still in preview mode so
I'm going to be able to see what tags
fired now I could see I have a couple of
tags that I've fired on this particular
page and then I can see what tags to not
fire on this page okay so that's the
preview mode you can use the preview
mode before you even submit a tag and
Trigger to see if it fires and that's
the great benefit of tag manager so if
you're not sure if something's going to
fire or not then you can always go into
preview mode um and if you are sure it's
gonna fire then you can go ahead and
submit it so you can leave preview mode
and just go ahead and submit that
particular tag and Trigger so here I'm
going to leave preview mode and now once
I'm done and I'm sure the tag is going
to fire and go ahead and submit all my
changes that I've worked on in terms of
setting up tags and triggers so that's
really GTM in a nutshell so I have my
tags okay my tags are just Snippets of
code that I'm going to put in whether
that be Facebook or vet tracking or any
other Google product like optimize or
page view then I have my triggers my
triggers are there to tell G GTM when to
fire that tag and the variables are
there to help those tags and triggers
work together so remember that
particular variable we set up for Google
analytics okay so here it is right here
because we want to tell GTM what
property to specifically fire in Google
analytics so that's why we set up that
variable but there are all sorts of
variables Google tag manager has built
in or variables already created for you
or you can specifically Define a
variable so variables are there to help
the tags and triggers work together so
when you set up a tag you set up a
trigger you use a variable you can
always go into preview mode preview it
by going to the website seeing if it
fires if it fires then voila you can go
ahead and click submit and that will
publish the tag and Trigger and you're
good to go that's pretty much how tag
manager works and again I can't stress
that there is an unlimited number of
tags you can add to tag manager there's
no limit so you got everything from
anything from Google to non-google to
event tracking okay to Facebook to
anything that you want to track you want
to be able to put into tag manager and
again there's versioning that's one of
the great benefits of tag manager so if
I want to go back to an older version I
can simply do that so here you can see
I'm on version 32. that's how tag
manager works and I can't stress that
you know tag manager is there to help
you track interactivity on the site
because if you have a site that's
interactive that has a video that has a
download button let's just say you know
you have all sorts of newsletter
sign-ons Facebook YouTube buttons on
your website just like this website does
and you won't be able to track how many
people click on that particular button
well you're gonna need tag manager and
when you have tag manager you're going
to be able able to track all of these
button clicks and interactivity on your
website with that tag manager it's going
to be hard to do that if you are looking
to become an SEO professional then look
no further than simply runs postgraduate
program in digital marketing so don't
miss out on this opportunity Find the
course Link in the description for more
information let's get started before I
tell you how to bring traffic to your
website let me tell you why this is so
important okay why do we want to bring
users to our website I mean it has to be
on equal ground as web development and
design is somebody who goes to your site
and then does something when they get to
your site so you have users and when
those users get to your site they're
generating page views and traffic and
you want to turn that traffic into
engagement okay so each Page's traffic
is configured independently of all their
pages so when you go when somebody goes
to your website they look at a page
that's a page view and certain pages on
your website you want to turn that page
view into a a conversion okay whether
that be you know looking at a video or
purchasing something so think of these
pages on your website as salespeople
they're trying to convert visitors who
come to your website but first we need
to get the visitors to your website so
when you get visitors to your website
again you can generate sales which means
revenue or you can increase brand
awareness or you can earn Revenue
through sponsored posts and
advertisements so if you have for
example a lot of content on your website
you can turn that in to revenue by
hosting ads on your website so when
somebody clicks on that ad you're going
to earn a percentage of that click okay
what that click is worth so having a
website means a lot of good things for
you but first you got to get the traffic
there and so what we're going to do is
we're going to tell you how to drive
traffic to your website so there's lots
of different ways in which you can bring
traffic to your website well the first
is paid advertising so paying to
advertise your products services with
ads is one of the easiest ways to drive
traffic to your website so some of the
options available are search ads social
media ads or display ads so search ads
or ads that are displayed in the search
engine results so when a user types in a
keyword a query you want your ad to show
up based on that keyword query okay so
an example is digital marketing course
somebody types in digital marketing
course and simply learn is the first ad
that shows up how do we know it's an ad
because you can see the word ad next to
the domain so when somebody clicks on
that link simply learn is going to pay
Google so that's how search advertising
works okay the next is social so social
media marketing involves increasing
traffic or engagement or brand awareness
lots of different strategies but you're
instead of doing this on search you're
doing it on a social media media
platform okay so for example you can
advertise on any particular platform and
the way you advertise could be with an
image it could be with a video so in
this case you could see cobrio is doing
a sponsored ad here how to succeed with
Google ads and then another form of
advertising is display so display means
creating ads that are placed on specific
websites so with display unlike search
you have a choice in the ad format with
search you only have text ads but with
display you have text Edge image ads
rich media ads video ads so you have
lots of different options in which you
can advertise on other websites so the
idea here is to get your ad in front of
the Right audience when they could see
your display Banner your banner ad then
it's going to be more visual more
appealing generate some brand interest
and hopefully you can get somebody to to
click on that ad and over to your
website so that's paid advertising again
through search through social through
display but you can also promote your
site on social media so once your
content has gone live you could take
advantage of different social media
platforms I mean it really depends on
what you're trying to promote because
what you're trying to promote needs to
align with the appropriate social media
platform so Facebook is best suited for
Industries like food and Beverages and
news and media and if you're selling a
product so you fall into one of those
categories and Facebook could be the
right platform for you if you're
involved in again beauty or food and
beverage or e-commerce then you can also
leverage Instagram which is part of
Facebook's ecosystem so if you advertise
on Facebook you can also advertise on
Instagram and or Instagram so it doesn't
have to be and Facebook and Instagram it
could be Facebook or Instagram you also
have LinkedIn as a platform LinkedIn is
great for B2B so if you're trying to
promote industry news or or tips and
best practices or job postings then
LinkedIn is the place for you it's a B2B
platform it's great for targeting
specific Industries targeting specific
job levels or job descriptions okay so
LinkedIn is great if you're into B2B
focusing on the business side of it so
you also have YouTube now YouTube is
part of Google's ecosystem YouTube is a
video platform okay so it's great if
you're trying to promote gaming or
entertainment if you're a vlogger okay
so YouTube's a great way to promote your
site by getting your product out there
in the form of a video and then you have
Twitter Twitter to me encompasses a lot
of different Industries Beauty and
fitness news and media entertainment
okay you have limited number of
characters but a lot of people are
active on Twitter and it's a great way
to generate some awareness and get some
clicks over to your website so these are
just some of the most popular social
media platforms of course there are
plenty more out there the third way in
which you can drive traffic to your site
is guest plus blogging so most of you
already know what blogging is all about
well if you're blogging for your own
site you can jump on somebody else's
site and blog on their behalf so having
the opportunity to guess post on another
website can be very helpful because one
that other blog could have lots of
traffic and have a a well-known brand so
if you're blogging on another blog it's
going to build your brand awareness and
potentially increase traffic to your
blog or website so it exposes to you to
targeted traffic so if you're going to
guest blog guest blog on a site that's
very relevant to your business or
industry that way you're targeting the
Right audience okay you can expand your
personal Network so getting yourself out
there getting your brand out there in
front of a different audience and then
obviously for serves because it
generates a backlink so serps search
engine ranking Pages means that hey if
you want to rank organically you're
going to have to generate some backlinks
so guest blogging isn't a way to
generate some backlinks to your site and
in effect that's going to help you get
your pages ranked higher because Google
is going to recognize the relationship
from one blog to your blog and build up
your relevancy so some other benefits
here to guest blogging is you can grow
your social media following because you
can then promote that on social media
that you're guest blogging okay again
you can improve your online Authority
okay because when you're guest blogging
and you have recognition on that guest
blog if it's a popular blog then it's
going to help your domain and Page
Authority for SEO and then the end
result is going to improve your backlink
score so a lot of benefits to guest
blogging to me at the end of the day
it's just about reaching out to your
audience using another platform to do
that in the form of a Blog and the
results of that is going to mean more
brand awareness for you and turning that
traffic from that other blog into
qualified leads so you can also
interview industry thought leaders so
that's another way an interesting way to
generate traffic to your site so
reaching out to thought leaders for
interviews okay could generate some
credibility for you and the other person
so it's reciprocal so it means that
you're active in the industry that
you're in and it allows you to engage
with other leaders in the industry and
the indirect net result of that could be
increased traffic because if you do the
interview and you record it or if it's
via video then you can obviously post it
on other platforms and that could in
turn Drive traffic to your website
obviously just like guest blogging it's
going to increase your reach so so
getting yourself out there nobody knows
who your brand is and they know who the
thought leaders are and they say you're
interviewing the thought leaders then
that's going to put you in front of
these people and so it's going to
increase your reach another way to drive
traffic to your website is just to make
sure your website's responsive and what
do we mean by responsive well we mean
does it work on multiple devices
specifically mobile so depending on the
device your website hides shows shrinks
enlarges or moves content so that it
conforms to the browser that that
person's looking at on your web for your
website so if somebody's looking on
mobile at your website you want to make
sure that your website adjusts
accordingly so you want to be able to
you know test to make sure it's
responsive and so as content arranged
based on importance okay does it work
across different browsers on different
devices into the images text and
everything else align just like it does
on desktop so there are plenty of tools
out there on the web all you need to do
is just do a search for you know check
my website for responsiveness you know
so you you can use plenty of tools to
check to see if your website is
responsive towards multiple devices why
is that important because if somebody
goes to your website Via Mobile and your
site doesn't align properly or the
content's all stretched out and somebody
has to maneuver their browser just to
see your website then chances are
they're not going to come back chances
are they're not going to convert okay so
you want to be able to revise your
device browser combinations you want to
make sure that everything works
accordingly you want to be able to test
those fonts make sure they look good and
then you also want to make sure that
people can navigate so if they're on
mobile are they going to navigate just
as easy as they can on desktop and if
you have any pop-ups you want to
probably make sure they're removed so
that way when somebody's looking at your
website they're not getting interfered
with on mobile and then of course you
want to make sure that these Pages load
okay so they load just as quick on
desktop as they should on mobile and
vice versa so this should not take a
long time to load so moving on from
responsiveness a mobile to building a
brand community so brand community
refers to a group of people who identify
your brand and use your brand as a
platform to exchange ideas and
contribute content some advantages of
having a brand Community are promoting
brand evangelism and loyalty it can be a
source of feedback loyalty and ideas so
build a community build a brand
Community who you know identify with you
okay so continue to you know treat these
people as loyal customers okay maybe
give them a promotion uh to use
specifically just for them that they can
use on your website or talk directly to
them because you know that their
followers they're repeat customers they
purchase for you multiple times so talk
to them differently as well you know who
these people are and that's what
building a brand is all about it's about
identifying your brand with other people
okay and identify people who identify
with your brand and messaging and
talking to them as if they're part of
your own Community your own family so
you can use user generated content that
provides future marketing strategies so
the feedback you get from your own
Community could it be in turn used to
promote or used in future marketing
strategies I.E advertising I.E post on
social okay it can also provide PR
opportunities so it's a chance for you
to you know put out press releases based
on the community that you built so any
brand regardless of who it is should be
able to identify with your audience
chance their target audience and that
target audience eventually going to
become part of a community these are
group of people who identify with you
what you're trying to sell what your
cause is what your mission statement is
what your services they identify with
you so leverage them and reciprocate
identify them talk to them separately
give them the what they deserve the
respect and loyalty that they deserve as
well because they're communicating and
they're following you as a brand so the
next thing you could do to drive traffic
is Be Active in the comments section so
engage in relevant and thought-provoking
conversations on other blogs and sites
it doesn't necessarily have to be
another blog per se it could be other
sites like Reddit or Cora or Mania sites
that have a lot of content that are
broken out by industry that allow you to
engage in conversation and allow you to
either upvote or share or respond Bond
okay so be active because when you're
active people are going to see that hey
you're a leader in the industry you know
what you're talking about you have some
some brand Equity you have some thought
and some knowledge on the specific topic
and subject so it just puts you in a
better light when you can respond and be
active on these different platforms okay
let's turn our attention to search
engine optimization also known as SEO or
organic search so in order to drive
traffic to your site you're going to
have to implement an SEO strategy why do
you want to implement an SEO strategy
because it can help you improve your
overall searchability and visibility on
search engines and obviously that comes
with advantages one of those advantages
is obviously more traffic to the site
search is still King in terms of volumes
of people using search on a daily basis
so you have a great opportunity found it
also builds trust and credibility
because still a majority of the people
who do a search click on an organic
search listing and so if you're found
organically and you're ranked number one
then chances are somebody's going to
click on your listing and it provides
increased engagement and traffic and so
what that means is more traffic more
engagement and engagement is something
you define it could be again a download
of a document or the clicking on the
play button of a video or or submitting
a form or signing up for a newsletter or
calling these are all forms of
Engagement so the the amount of traffic
you drive from organic search to your
website is only going to improve
engagement okay so you can also provide
and improve user experience and what do
we mean by that well if you're getting
lots of traffic from organic search you
have a really good opportunity to do a b
testing and when you do a b testing you
can improve user experience meaning
you're showing one variation against the
other from people coming from organic
search and so this is helpful in that
you know if you're running an A B test
the variation has a chance to improve or
outperform the original and if it
outperforms the original you're
improving user experience and then it
helps Target quality traffic so SEO to
me or all search is the only medium in
which you're meeting somebody halfway
you're you're addressing what they're
looking for so somebody's looking for a
pair of red women's Nike shoes the 2019
model and you have that particular
product to offer well you have a chance
of showing up via organic search
somebody types in you know women's red
Nike shoes size whatever at the year
2019 model then of course they're gonna
probably likely click on your list
testing because you have what they're
looking for and and that goes with any
keyword any industry any business any
segment any type of product you're
selling so again you have a chance to
really be visible for what people are
looking for and so that's the beauty of
search engine optimization you have a
really good opportunity here to meet
people halfway to drive quality traffic
to get them to enjoy a good user
experience all the while generate an
engagement and along with SEO we want to
be able to build backlinks so SEO is a
two-pronged approach meaning you have
two strategies in one on page and off
page and so off page involves
backlinking so backlinks are just links
that direct users from other websites to
your own website so with that inherently
it's going to drive traffic qualify
traffic to your website because if
somebody's on a relevant website that's
linking to yours and they click on that
link and go to your website it's likely
going to be qualified meaning they're
going to be relevant and so backlinking
because it's an off-page strategy why
isn't an off-page SEO strategy because
if Google crawls that other site that
has a link to you then that's going to
give you credit because Google will say
hey this site's getting some links from
some relevant sites we must think
they're relevant and therefore we're
going to trust the site so by Google
trusting your site it's going to improve
your organic ranking and with the
organic rankings being approved meaning
it's going to mean faster indexing so
what does that mean so you want to be
indexed by the search engines and so the
quicker Google can find your pages even
if it's on somebody else's site then
that means they're going to follow that
link go to that page on your site and
take that page back to their servers to
be indexed okay so the quicker you can
get index the quicker you can get found
and then it helps with referral traffic
so again we notice that our efforts are
on SEO organic search but if you're
getting traffic from another website hey
that still counts that's referral
traffic okay so that's a side advantage
to having backlinks is good traffic from
other sites okay so those those are
inherently the some of the reasons to do
backlinking okay never hurts I mean
there's brand awareness reasons to being
on other sites as well there's industry
leadership meaning if you you post
content on Reddit okay you're coming
across as an industry leader but yet
generating a backlink which helps with
SEO and referral traffic so there's a
lot of benefits to building backlinks
and the opposite of backlinks are
internal links so you want to do
internal linking and that just means
connecting one page on your site to
another and why is that beneficial
because it can help direct visitors to
other Pages they wouldn't normally
otherwise find via your navigation so if
you're active on a Blog do don't be
afraid to include multiple internal
links you want to move people through
your site you want the flow of traffic
to go from one page to another to
another and so when you do internal
linking just like with backlinks it's
going to improve the indexing of your
website Google's going to follow those
links and index those pages and Google
does give credit from an SEO perspective
from an internal linking perspective so
if one page is linked to another and
that page has really good relevance in
the eyes of Google then the other page
is probably going to benefit from that
the other reason we want to do internal
linking again you want to move people
from your one page of your site to the
other and when you do that it's going to
reduce bounce rates so bounce rate is
simply the rate at which people land on
a page and then leave so if I have a
hundred people in on my home page and
only one person went to another page and
the other 99 left the site then that's a
99 bounce rate so by putting internal
links in in place you're helping people
move from one page to the other and thus
reducing the bounce rate and that's what
you want you want to keep people on your
site you want to be greedy it also
drives traffic to older posts so again
when we say older posts we're really
referring to blog posts so if you have a
relevant blog post and you're writing a
new blog post then link the two together
if it's relevant link it I don't you
know regardless of how old it is you
know you want to show Google that these
older blog posts just because they were
written a year ago doesn't mean they're
outdated and old-fashioned okay or
useless you want to keep them alive by
linking to them so to me that's a good
strategy for internal linking link to
older blog posts you know show people
you're an industry expert you've been
doing this for a while and then you have
lots of content to share okay so the
longer you can keep somebody on your
website the more likely it is they're
going to engage and convert and some
other inherent benefits improves page
rank so what we mean by page rank is
simply just a rank that Google gives
pages so the more internal linking you
have the better off you are and then it
helps spread link juice across websites
and what we mean by link juice again
just like backlinking it builds
relevancy so just keep all these
inherent benefits in mind to internal
linking the end result is keeping the
flow of traffic on your site and all
these other benefits will fall into
place okay so another way in which you
can really hone in on traffic to your
website is long tail keywords and long
child keywords to me are more than just
one or two keyword phrases okay so there
are usually three or longer keywords in
a phrase okay so long tail keywords
really nowadays account for most web
searches people really take the time to
even post questions as a search query
it's a likely somebody it's unlikely
somebody's going to go into search and
just type in the word shoes they might
type in red shoes but that's unlikely
what they're probably going to type in
is you know red Nike running shoes 2019
or some variation of that okay that's a
long tail keyword and some of the
advantages of using long tail keywords
to be found for are less competition so
if you're using broad keywords like red
shoes then who doesn't want to be found
for Red Shoes well you don't necessarily
you don't want to be found for red shoes
because it's too broad you don't know
what type of shoes somebody's looking
for you just know they're looking for
Red Shoes it could be running shoes it
could be work shoes it could be you know
boots it could be slippers okay it's too
broad so long tail keywords help narrow
it in and the more narrow and focused a
keyword is the less competition is going
to have and when something's not
competitive in the form of a keyword
then that means your chances of ranking
for that keyword are going to be greater
and the chance of you ranking faster are
going to be greater and then of course
if somebody's looking for exact exactly
what you have to offer then you have a
higher chance to convert that person so
if you have exactly those 2019 red Nike
women's running shoes and somebody does
a search for that and that's a long tail
keyword and they click on your organic
listing if you have the right price then
they're probably going to convert so you
have a really good chance of converting
somebody using long tail keywords so my
point here is if you're looking for
keywords to use focus on longer tail
don't focus on one or two keyword
phrases what it also does is it brings
targeted traffic so even if somebody
doesn't convert hey they could be back
because it's exactly what they're
looking for and if you're focusing on
longer tail keywords like I just
mentioned stay away from the shorter
ones it's just easier to optimize your
page for SEO so remember SEO is a
two-pronged approach on page and off
page we talked about off page with
internal linking and backlinks on page
is all about making sure there's
keywords you choose are are integrated
in with the page you want to be found
for and so if you're using a long tail
keyword it's just easy to work that
keyword in so it enables easier on-page
optimization okay let's switch away from
SEO to email marketing so let's focus on
email marketing as a form or method of
driving traffic to your website so email
marketing has been around a long time in
terms of digital marketing why because
it provides an effective way to convert
leads into sales why because you can
send personalized emails to a target
audience so when you send an email to
somebody on a regular basis you know who
that person is so what are you doing in
the email you're writing a specific
message to that person well email
marketing is the same thing except
you're just sending an email to a larger
group of people and when you send an
email to a larger group of people you're
still going to personalize the message
right you're not going to send a generic
email to 1 000 people okay nobody's
gonna do that so make sure your email is
targeted if it's targeted it could be
cost effective why because sending large
amounts of emails or let's just say an
email to a large amount of people or a
large group of people is going to be
cost effective it's not cost per click
you know it's not cost per open okay so
email usually depending on the the email
provider you're using really is a flat
fee so just really depends on how many
emails you're sending or how how many
people you're sending the email to as
well so but your email generally tends
to be more cost effective than other
forms of marketing so look at the email
content provider you're using and just
get a sense of what they charge but if
you look at it and do a comparison email
generally is cheaper than say doing
pay-per-click because with pay-per-click
you're paying for each click okay so
that could be expensive depending on the
keywords so email marketing is also time
saving okay a meaning it's a one-time
thing and done so once you send the
email it's just a matter of you know
watching and looking at the metrics and
learning what's going on so you don't
make the same mistakes again but it is
time conducive meaning you send out one
email and that's it with pay-per-click
you're constantly measuring and managing
the campaigns and it provides real-time
marketing so when you do send the email
more than likely a majority of the
people on day one or the day you send
the email are gonna be able to view it
open it click on some of the links and
convert so that's normally what happens
in email majority of the people open it
on day one and it kind of tails off from
there so think about it as real time so
when you send that email and if you have
a thousand people on your email
recipient list break it up send the
first 500 first with a different subject
line and then you can see the data come
in and if you don't see the good results
from the subject line or the body of the
email or you know the page they're going
to then make adjustments before you send
the other email to the next 500. so
that's a great thing about emails you
can break up the email into two groups
the first group and then the second
group with different subject lines and
you can probably send them a little bit
of time apart that way you can learn
from the first email because with email
you are generally going to get results
right away okay within the first 24
hours so that's a great thing about
email okay so the other thing about
email it's less intrusive so normally
people who are going to get the email
are the ones who sign up for the email
so they're almost expecting your email
so when they get your email again as
long as you're not sending an email on a
daily basis normally most companies send
it monthly or bi-weekly it's not going
to be as intrusive okay and then it also
helps build credibility increase
visibility and brand awareness meaning
you're going to build your brand in that
email you're going to put content in
that email that's going to show off your
credibility meaning you could put some
testimonials in the email you can put
some good affiliations you can put a
good article to an industry article you
just wrote so email is going to
inherently continue to build brand
awareness for you okay and it's an easy
way to track Roi so if your e-commerce
it's pretty clear you send the email
somebody opens it clicks on it checks
out and purchases something it's easily
trackable because you could track it
right from that email so one thing I
want to say there is just if you do send
an email make sure you're tracking that
campaign and you want to be able to use
an analytics program like Google
analytics okay if you use Google
analytics you're going to be able to
track when you send the email who clicks
on it and who converts so you want to be
able to measure an Roi for these emails
and you can and that's the beauty of
email marketing okay let's move away
from email marketing to webinars so
webinars great method for for Effective
social media promotion it's a great way
to bring traffic to your website so why
do we recommend webinars well because it
provides direct content contact within
your target group what do we mean by
contact with your target group well
you're going to host a webinar and
you're going to invite this targeted
group of people who are interested in
your product or service so if you have a
Facebook Community you can do a Facebook
live event or you could do a YouTube or
you know you can even set up a webinar
and another platform but promote it on
social media and if you're pronouning
something on social media you're
probably promoting it to people who are
already following you or like you and so
that's what we mean by direct contact
with your target groups you're you're
going to be able to create a webinar and
talk directly to that group and that's
going to help build brand awareness and
credibility and the great thing about
webinars is you don't need some fancy
software I mean I'm talking to you on a
webinar right now now and so webinars
are free all you need is a video camera
and a recorder that's all and that's all
built in with software so there's plenty
of software out there that allows you
just to do a webinar really quick and
easy there's lots of opportunities in
software so and a lot of them are very
cost effective so if you want to build
create a webinar you can do that by
spending very little money in webinars
again allow you to talk to your your
targeted group your community maybe
prospective clients it helps build
credibility and in effect Drive traffic
to your website and when somebody does
attend a webinar they're likely going to
be highly engaged because you're
inviting them they're going to opt into
the webinar and the great thing about
webinars is even if they don't attend
the webinar the day you have it it's
going to be recorded so they can always
go back and watch it so whoever watches
the webinar is going to be engaged
because it's going to be a topic they're
interested in and then users are likely
to be com prospective customers so
having a webinar talking about something
inherently interesting to maybe a larger
group of people you can promote that on
social media and potentially get
prospective customers to sign up and
watch the webinar and if you do they're
going to be engaged and then take the
next step oh I like what this guy this
person has to say they seem to be
credible I like their personality I like
their brand I like their product I'm
gonna go check their web out their
website okay so webinars allow you to
kind of pull in more people as well as
just your community because you can
promote the webinar and you can promote
it in advance and you can leverage
social media for that okay so something
related to webinars incorporating video
content so videos have been proven to be
a really good way to attract new
visitors and it just it makes your
website very engaging when you have
videos on your website as well so if you
create video you have an opportunity to
post it on various video platforms like
YouTube or Vimeo okay there's plenty of
video platforms out there or just
embedded in a blog post or embed it in a
Facebook post or a tweet okay so you can
do a lot with video and having video on
your site is going to increase
engagement okay when you increase
engagement good things happen that's
going to lead to increased conversions
and sales or or Roi or just like we
mentioned the webinar can help build
trust with your audience even that
webinar you could post on your website
so you want people to engage by watching
this video they watch the video they're
going to gain trust in you because
you're talking directly to that person
that user that audience that visitor to
your website and when you get Bell trust
it's going to increase engagement and
that's the beauty of video unlike text
or imagery videos really do engage with
the audience and so the more video you
could do the better off you are because
again you can leverage social to draw
attention to your brand and product and
service and then you can have that video
on your website to increase engagement
which in turn increases conversions and
sales and improves Roi so always think
video there's plenty of video software
out there that you can leverage and the
great thing about video two is hey most
people are using mobile phones these
days smartphones and so video works just
as well on mobile as it does on desktop
so keep that in mind you know video is
going to be engaging regardless of what
device somebody uses and then of course
if they're watching the video on
Facebook or YouTube then chances are
they're going to share that particular
video which is going to bode well for
your brand and traffic okay so video if
somebody likes a video it's very easy to
share video especially from a mobile
phone so YouTube just makes it so easy
easy to share or like or subscribe to a
channel it just it becomes that much
easier things can go viral and chances
of them going viral with video are going
to be greater okay so other ways to
drive traffic to your website is submit
your content to content aggregators so
what's a Content aggregator well content
aggregators like Reddit that provides a
great platform for you to post your
content so that's what a Content
aggregate is really a site like Reddit
or medium or quora where you could post
content to a large number of people okay
so with Reddit people are either going
to upvote it or download it so the more
upvotes you get are thumbs up or likes
or people who encourage that content the
more of a chance it has to be found and
so first thing out of the gate if you do
provide content to a Content aggregator
like Reddit make sure it's good quality
content that's interesting and that
should be a case the case around across
the board whether it's a social post or
blog post make sure the content's unique
professional and interesting and then if
you do say put something on medium or
you do put something on Cora and it is
professional and interesting and thought
provoking then people are going to react
to it and then that again could lead to
traffic but even if it doesn't lead to
traffic it helps build brand awareness
so if you have content just like videos
leverage it put the content out there
okay and when you put content out there
it's only gonna especially if it's good
content put it's going to put you in a
good light so don't be afraid to share
your content on the likes of Reddit or
medium or core or some of these other
content aggregator websites because good
things are only going to happen and
again referral traffic SEO brand
awareness conversions so all these are
inherent benefits of just sharing your
content okay and then finally we want to
learn from analytics okay so what do I
mean learning from analytics so there
are plenty of analytics platforms out
there one of the most popular is Google
analytics so you want to make sure
you're tracking traffic on your site
with Google analytics so all you have to
do is just go to Google analytics via
search sign up add the analytics code to
your website and voila they're doing all
the heavy lifting they're going to track
traffic coming your website and not only
are they going to track traffic but
they're going to tell you how that
traffic engaged and so the benefits of
it Google analytics is hey you could
figure out where users are coming from
are they coming from that email campaign
that I sent out to a thousand people are
they coming from YouTube based on that
video I posted or are they coming from
Reddit based on the content I just
posted there or they come in from
organic search it is so Google analytics
can help us understand how much traffic
we're getting from organic search so
it'll help us measure our SEO efforts
and then with Google analytics you could
segment so we could segment by mobile we
can segment by desktop returning user
new user by campaign by Page by Language
by city by region I mean there's so many
ways in which to segment your audience
and segmenting simply is breaking up the
entire group of people who come to your
website into different segments based on
what you want to say so if you want to
look at you know females between the
ages of 18 to 24 who come from mobile
via organic search that's a segment and
you can look at that information and
analytics if that's your target audience
then you can see how they're performing
okay so Anna there are a lot of benefits
to Google analytics definitely want to
take advantage of segmenting in Google
analytics you could look at your
competition so there's a benchmarking
report the great thing about Google
analytics you can also look at content
and how your content is performing once
somebody lands on your website are they
what page are they spending time on what
page are they engaging on the most okay
what pages have the highest bounce rate
or the lowest time on page so you can
really determine what pages work best
and then of course the end result in
analyzing all this data is you want to
be able to fine-tune your website so
take advantage of the data that Google
analytics or any other analytics
platform has given you by learning once
you learn what's going on with your
website you can make adjustments to your
website to improve user experience okay
so we went over a lot of different ways
to drive traffic okay you can
incorporate all this to your website
immediately
let's talk about how to measure your SEO
performance so all that hard work you've
done with on-page SEO
coupled with all the work you've done
with off-page SEO are eventually going
to net results and positive results and
we want to be able to measure that as
you're actually doing the work as you're
putting forth the effort on on page and
off page and so we want to be able to
measure that and so you want to be able
to understand what to measure and where
to measure it and so when we talk about
SEO we really want to hone in on three
high level core metrics and that's
ranking traffic and conversion so when
we talk about ranking traffic and
conversion we can break that down into
this list here what kind of traffic are
we getting from organic search what kind
of traffic are we getting from mobile
devices remember mobile is very
important because as we talked about
with on-page SEO as we talk about with
local SEO a lot of searches start with
mobile devices we want to look at
keyword ranking remember keyword
research is the first step in the SEO
process even before we do any work with
on-page and off page you know we want to
look at the local visibility if we have
local SEO results we want to look at
engagement metrics so all that traffic
we're driving from organic search we
want to be able to measure how they're
performing and behaving on our website
we also want to measure some form of
progress on off-page SEO and that's in
the form of backlinks so all of these
are different metrics we can measure
using different tools so let's talk
about how to go about looking at these
metrics and where to go look at them and
measure them and so really monitoring
all this Behavior will help us
understand how we're performing how SEO
is performing and so really what we we
want to do is start with Organic traffic
and so we can look at that on a
month-to-month basis we can look at it
from a geographic perspective we can
look at it in terms of how many new
visitors we're driving versus returning
and then again more importantly
conversion rate and so to me the best
place to start to look at that traffic
from organic search is Google analytics
and Google analytics is a free tool it's
simply there to measure website
performance so if you go into Google
analytics we can actually go in and we
can look at all sorts of data based on
website behavior and so if I'm in Google
analytics and I go under acquisition and
then I go under all traffic channels
over a given period of time let's just
say the last seven days for a particular
website I can see what traffic is coming
from organic search and then I could see
the amount of new users that are coming
from we're going to search I can also
see engagement metrics bounce rate for
example so I want to be able to see if
somebody's typing in a query clicking on
our Link in the organic search results
and then coming to our website are they
actually engaging with our website or
are they leaving the website after only
visiting the page they landed on so
that's all and these are all important
metrics to measure and I can measure all
that right here in Google analytics if I
wanted to I can even take it a step
further and break that down by country
so if I type in country as a secondary
Dimension now I can see what country is
driving traffic from organic search so a
lot of your organic traffic information
is going to be centrally located in
Google analytics so we also talked about
Mobile Traffic a majority of searches
take place on mobile phones versus
desktop so Google basically is reporting
the nearly 60 percent of searches now
appear from mobile devices and so if we
go back to Google analytics and we can
also look at a mobile report so if I go
in Google analytics under audience under
mobile overview I can see a breakdown of
the amount of traffic coming from
desktop versus tablet versus mobile and
so you'll find as time goes on that your
mobile device is likely going to drive a
majority of the traffic from organic
search and so you can compare device
information with channel so if I just
type in Channel and Google analytics as
a secondary Dimension and look at the
default Channel groupings versus device
category I could see that you know
mobile from organic search just driven
traffic over the last seven days this is
something you want to keep an eye on
because a lot of people tend to begin
their searches on mobile devices so
mobile ranking is different than desktop
ranking the because with mobile ranking
it's based on a responsive website and
with that responsive website basically
response of being that the website's
going to adapt to the mobile device so
it's going to respond to the device that
somebody's on and so therefore the
metrics or the engagement metrics are
going to be different but if I look back
to Google analytics I can see again
bounce rate I can see pages per session
average session duration so if I look at
line three I could see all the different
engagement metrics compared to those
metrics from other devices and other
channels okay so you want to be able to
do a comparison because if behavior is
not up to par engagement is not the par
on mobile then you want to do something
about that so you want to hone in on
Mobile Traffic specifically from organic
search because the behavior is going to
be different you know people start their
searches on mobile well the site's going
to be different and so therefore it's a
different experience altogether so make
sure you track the behavior and more
importantly make sure you track that
page speed so earlier we talked about
on-page SEO when we honed in on page
speed so just as a reminder if I'm back
in analytics and I go back under
Behavior then if I go to site speed then
if I go to overview I'll be able to see
the average page load time on my website
I can also look at specific page timings
and I should be able to see that by
device so if I type in device category
I'll just be able to see how each paid
loads per device and so this allows me
to understand which pages are loading
fast which pages are not loading as fast
and address those pages accordingly to
improve engagement metrics so we want to
keep an eye on page speed as well as
overall user behavior from mobile
devices you can also use other tools
that are out there like agency analytics
there are plenty of tools out there I
tend to use Google analytics because
primarily it's free and Google analytics
is a Google product so it works with
other Google platforms like Google
search console we want to keep an eye on
ranking so remember when we do our
keyword research we're choosing keywords
that have high relevancy high volume and
low competition so we want to be able to
track keywords that we choose that have
high relevancy high volume and low
competition and so the tool we use or at
least I recommend using is Moz so I
mentioned Moz earlier with on page and
off-page SEO so if we go into Moz and we
know what keywords we're trying to rank
for we can go ahead and add the Namaz
and what Moz does they actually track
where these keywords Rank and so if I go
into Mods and I click on rankings I'll
be able to see on a weekly basis or
monthly basis how are keywords are
ranking and for what page is the ranking
so for whatever keyword I choose to to
optimize for I want to make sure I put
those keywords in Moz because when I put
them in Moz Moz is going to on a weekly
basis tell me where these keywords Rank
and for what URL they're ranked for so
that way I can keep an eye on ranking
over time because in theory the higher
you rank the more traffic you're going
to get and so we want to be able to see
the trend in which keywords rank okay so
if I click on a particular keyword in
Moz it's going to give me over a period
of time where that keywords ranked be
able to see Improvement in ranking for a
particular keyword the whole idea behind
SEO is to choose keywords that are
relevant optimize for those keywords so
that you can be ranked for those
keywords in order to get the traffic and
conversions so Moz is a good platform
that helps us monitor rankings for
particular keywords now if you don't
want to use Moz as an alternative you
can turn your attention to Google search
console and so remember we talked about
Google search console earlier when we
talked about sitemaps we also talked
about mobile usability with search
console we also talked about links to
your site with Google search console so
Google search console is a good tool to
help you understand how you're
performing with Organic search and so
there's one tool in particular which is
performance that helps us understand
what keyword queries people are actually
typing into Google search and so here I
could see the actual query and so with
this particular website valleyfig.com I
can see that dried fig recipes over the
course of the last three months had
5414 Impressions that means that one of
my pages either one or multiple Pages
appeared in Google search engine results
5414 times and over the course of those
5414 impressions I received 1100 clicks
so Google search console is going to be
able to tell me not only you know how
many Impressions I received for a
particular keyword but they also going
to tell me how many clicks and if I
wanted to add more metrics to that I can
add them like the average ranking
position for keyword the click-through
rate so I can add multiple metrics to
this report to give me an understanding
of hey or any of my target keywords
being used or queried and if they are
where am I ranking and I am I showing up
and am I getting clicks so search
console serves as a good alternative if
not primary tool or platform for you to
measure how your organic search results
are showing so for local visibility this
metric is important for you know
maintaining local SEO so remember on the
local SEO we talked about uh Google my
business so if I go back to Google my
business I can go into my account and so
Google my business is going to be able
to show me some metrics so if I go into
Google my business and I click on
insights I'm going to be able to see a
number of different metrics over the
course of a month I can see exactly you
know what queries were used by how many
users and when I appeared so I'll be
able to see how many views I receive not
only on search results but on maps then
I can also see what actions people took
when they saw my results in maps or in
search did they visit my website did
they request directions that they call
so I can actually see engagement metrics
right in Google my business I could see
a Breakout by ZIP code I could see phone
calls by day of the week I could see how
many people even viewed my photos so
there's a lot of insights into local SEO
on Google my business so that gives you
an idea of how you're performing
organically on local search and remember
you want to be able to use Google my
business to hone in on your specific
audience so all these metrics help you
align with whether you're getting in
front of the Right audience and whether
that audience is actually behaving the
way you want them to meaning you know
are they actually contacting you are
they going to your website are they
calling you so local visibility and
understanding the metrics involved with
local SEO is very important so Google my
business is where you want to turn your
attention so overall engagement metrics
are important they play an important
role in determining rankings for example
we talked about bounce rate to bounce
rate is the rate at which people go from
organic search to your website and then
leave after a scene one page and not
going any further so if they land on a
page and then leave the website after
landing on that page it's considered a
bounce and so bounce or bounce rate is a
good indication of how people are
receiving our website or the content
that they're reading on our website
there are other metrics involved like
average session duration or pages per
visit all of these are engagement
metrics and let's not forget about page
speed so page speed is also a good
engagement metric all of these metrics
affect or determine rankings so we want
to be able to make sure that if we're in
Google analytics and we're looking at
engagement metrics that our metrics are
good because if somebody comes to our
website for organic search and there's a
high bounce rate then what does that
tell us that there's a disconnect
between what that person's querying and
then the content that they're reading
and so we want to be able to address
those engagement metrics so that we can
continue to not only drive quality
traffic but keep the traffic engaged and
then in turn drive up conversions last
metric we want to look at is backlinks
so content having more backlinks from
good good domains will effectively
improve your SEO performance we talk
about backlinks with off-page SEO and
remember quality over quantity and so we
can measure backlinks going back into
Moz we can use moz's Link Explorer tool
so remember if I type in a domain Valley
fig I can get some metrics related
off-page SEO including my domain
Authority but more importantly I can see
what links are pointing to my site in
this case valleyfig.com so I can see
they're 575 link domains I can see
there's 7900 inbound links and so just
by clicking on that I can get an idea of
the types of websites that are linking
to my site and their domain Authority
and their spam score Google search
console so if you go back into search
console you can also just click on links
and we should be able to get an idea of
you know what websites are linking to
our site and more importantly we want to
be able to see not only what sites but
what pages they're linked to remember we
want our backlinks pointing to Interior
Pages not necessarily the home page so
here I could see the top link page for
valleyfair.com it's slash recipes so we
want links pointing to our interior page
is not necessarily the home page that's
what's going to help your performance
your rankings for all your pages not
just your home page so having quality
back links pointing to Interior Pages
help boost the domain Authority and the
page Authority for that particular page
so again using Moz link Explorer tool or
using the links report and search
console are good sources for you to
identify backlinks so when we look at
these these reports we want to look at
the Domain authority of these sites that
are Link in ours the number of outbound
links to the site or specific pages on
our site we want to be able to look at
the ratio of Link distribution you know
we want to be able to look at how many
follows and no follows so most of this
if not all of these metrics are in Moz
so if I go back to Moz I can actually
see you know which ones pointing which
ones are followed the total quality of
the link that's pointing to our site
again bam so Moz link Explorer report
tends to give us all the information we
need in order to measure and get a sense
of our backlinks that help us with
off-page SEO so there are other tools
out there there's hrefs again search
console there's other SEO platforms out
there that'll help you measure backlinks
if you are looking to become an SEO
professional then look no further than
simply runs postgraduate program in
digital marketing so don't miss out on
this opportunity Find the course Link in
the description for more info mission
let's get started with keyword research
so basically what we want to do is
Center our keywords just like our
website we want to Center our keywords
around or our content around good
keywords so the videos on YouTube are no
different than the web pages on our
website so if we have somebody who
states YouTube is the world's second
most well well-known engine well it is
because it's right behind Google it's
not a search engine per se it's a video
platform but if it was a search engine
it'd probably be second right behind
Google so YouTube is pretty popular
majority people use YouTube search every
day to watch videos on a number of
different topics so they can find these
videos in Google but because YouTube's
so powerful and so popular people go
directly right into YouTube for their
searches and so the whole idea behind
YouTube being the second most well-known
search engine is centered around
keywords so if you have the the right
keywords for your video then the chances
of you ranking higher increases on
YouTube so we're gonna share with you a
few easy ways to do keyword research
this is the most important step in
getting your videos to rank on YouTube
just like for those of you who watched
any of the SEO videos we produced it at
simply learn you know that keyword
research is so essential to getting your
web pages to rank on Google well it's no
different keyword research and choosing
the right keywords is just as important
for your videos as is for your web pages
so we're going to go into a few things
to do here to find the right keywords so
we have the search suggestion you can
look at your competitors we have
different tools we can use some other
factors involved in Google itself so
let's start talking about some of these
ways to really hone in and do some good
research on your keywords to align them
with your videos so first thing is
search suggest so YouTube has a feature
called autocomplete so if you've done
any searches on Google it's very similar
if you're typing something in to YouTube
search then YouTube is going to suggest
other related popular keywords so let's
take a look at that if we go back to
YouTube for a second and I just type in
machine learning YouTube is going to
populate on the autocomplete in the
search bar some other popular keywords
that we can potentially use or in this
case if I Choose You Know machine
learning tutorial I'm going to see a
video about machine learning tutorial so
here you can see simply learns rank
number one for machine learning tutorial
but there are other videos that show up
in my search result so we want to be
able to use the search suggestion box in
the search box field so when we're
typing in something you know YouTube
just like on Google is going to give us
those suggestions so if we're focusing a
video on machine learning then you know
we have have some ideas of some other
keywords that we could center around
because these are our popular keywords
these are key words that people are
using to search on YouTube so that's one
suggestion looking at competitors is
another suggestion so we could search
for keywords used by our competitors in
their video and title and description so
let me talk a little bit about that what
you want to do is you want to go to that
particular channel of your competitor so
when you go to your particular
competitors YouTube channel you want to
be able to click on the videos tab when
you click on the videos tab then you're
going to sort by most popular and then
what you could do is see a list of
videos and then when you look at a list
of videos you're going to choose a video
and then what you're going to do then is
take a look at the keywords used in the
title and description and then once you
do that you're going to have a list of
keywords that you can use yourself for
that video so for example let's go back
to YouTube so if I go to type and simply
learn here's our Channel page just by
clicking on simply learn if I click on
videos ever wonder if there's so now I
can see all the videos ever wonder if
there's an easier way go back so here I
can see all the videos sort by most
popular once they do that then I can
choose a video this is the most popular
video right now for simply learn if I
click on that video it's automatically
going to start playing but what I could
do is simply just look at you know the
content description so just by clicking
show more I can see all the content that
align with this video that's one way to
do it is simply by looking at your
competitors now what you could also do
is look at the tags associated with the
particular video and so what you want to
do is you want to look at the HTML and
so that means looking at the page source
so just like web pages what YouTube does
is they look at meta tags so if you call
from SEO in order to get your pages to
rank you need to have a title tag and a
meta tag description so videos are no
different what we're doing for YouTube
is aligning certain keywords with the
video so if you take a look and do a
search for keywords by viewing the page
Source you're going to see all the
keywords associated with a particular
video so for example if I go back to
YouTube and I look at the page source of
a video Let's just say this video here
Facebook's ad tutorial I'm going to pull
up the page source and all I need to do
is control F and type in keywords and
now for that Facebook video I can see
all the keywords associated with the
video so you can see there's a lot of
different keywords we're aligning with
this video and so why do we want to do
that because we want you know our video
to show up for keywords that people may
type in and so if you use that YouTube
autocomplete it's going to give you
those ideas this most popular keywords
so if they're related align those
keywords words with the video so here
you can see Facebook marketing Facebook
ad strategy Facebook ads for beginners
so forth and so on so there's a lot of
keywords we've aligned here with that
particular video and again all you need
to do is look at the page source so
right clicking view page Source do a
control F for keywords and you'll be
able to see the keywords aligned so you
could do that for your competitors
videos as well so you can see what
keywords your competitors using for a
video that's most popular for their
Channel and is also ranking on YouTube
and on Google so using the autocomplete
gives you those keyword ideas looking at
your competitors videos also gives you
some other ideas for keywords that you
can align with a video that's relevant
that you want to rank for so let's look
at some other ideas here so you can
install plugins and there are plenty of
plugins available on the Chrome browser
that will help you see the video tags
associated with a particular video so a
couple of examples are vid IQ and
tubebuddy those are extensions that work
in Chrome and what they do is they give
you the exact tags that a particular
video is using so for example if I go
back here and I look at a video on
YouTube let's just say the machine
learning Basics video I have vid IQ
installed on my Chrome browser so just
by clicking on that vid IQ is going to
give me a lot of information about that
video you're just going to give me an
overview of their particular metrics
they're going to give me some other
information associated with Facebook
some engagement metrics really what I'm
interested in is those keywords so if I
scroll down a bit here I can see the
video tags associated with the machine
learning Basics video so vid IQ is
telling me is these keywords are
associated with this video and not only
does it show me what keywords are
associated I can also see where they
rank so for machine learning Basics this
particular video ranks number one if I
go down I could see what is machine
learning and how does it work I can see
it's rank number two here I could see
machine learning algorithms it's ranked
number nine so I can get some ideas of
the types of keywords that are being
used as tags for that video further down
I can also see some Channel tags but
really this is the video tags or the
idea place I want to be able to look to
get an idea of the types of keywords
that are associated with the video that
are also ranking or not ranking so
that's another way for you to really get
an understanding of what keywords to use
at the particular video so autocomplete
you can look at the page source of a
competitors video or you can use a
Chrome extension in this case I'm using
vid IQ to give me some information about
the video tags for a particular video so
according to an industry study you using
keywords and video tags will help you
rank well on YouTube so you have to use
keywords and video tags if you want your
video to rank there's been a lot of
studies YouTube is so popular and videos
are so prominent in today's world where
if you have videos and you're going to
upload them to YouTube then associate
the right keywords with those videos so
some important factors when we look at
keywords what we want to do is look at
search volume we want to look at
competition we want to look at relevancy
we want to look at the primary and
secondary keywords that we want to use
so well chosen keywords will help you
rank so we just gave you some ideas on
how to do some keyword research again
those ideas were really to use the
autocomplete on YouTube or Google
they're going to give you some popular
keywords you can look what your
competitors are doing by looking at the
page source and just looking at the
keywords that are aligned with that
video or you can use it third party
extension in Chrome in my example I use
vid IQ that gave me the keywords
associated with that video so you have
ways to get the keywords so what we want
to do is we want to make sure we choose
keywords with high search volume they're
going to drive more traffic to your
video however we want to balance it out
with keywords that have low difficulty
and are easier to rank for so you don't
want to choose something very broad
that's just going to be very difficult
to rank for and of course we always want
to go with relevancy so for talking
about machine learning Basics then we
want to choose keywords associated with
that and that's where that autocomplete
comes in handy because what Google's
going to do and YouTube's going to do is
give us keywords that are very closely
related to the video that we're trying
to optimize for and so we have a number
of different keywords at our disposal
that are relevant that we can look to
see if they have good volume and low
competition and so the whole idea is we
want to choose a keyword that defines
the nature of the content and then what
we want to do is support that with
secondary keywords so we want keywords
that are highly relevant to the primary
keyword so that's the way to go about
aligning your keywords you want keywords
that are high volume low competition or
relevant and you want to choose that one
keyword that is really what the
content's about and then those secondary
keywords that support the primary so if
you have a machine learning video you
could choose your primary keyword as in
this case the machine learning Basics
video so well chosen keywords help you
rank well on YouTube just like the
machine learning Basics so if I go back
to our video our machine learning Basics
video if I just type in machine learning
Basics I'll be able to pull it up and so
here it is if I click on it I'm going to
go to YouTube and so here I can see this
keyword we know humans learn from is
well aligned because it's in the title
it's in the copy and it's a line is a
keyword tagged with the video so we know
that that keyword has good volume low
competition is relevant because that's
what the video is about the basics of
machine learning it's an introduction to
machine learning so instead of honing in
on just introduction and machine
learning primary keyword is machine
learning Basics and then we supported
that video with those secondary keywords
what is machine learning because
somebody who doesn't know machine
learning is probably going to type in
that keyword and then introduction to
machine learning is a good secondary
keyword because it's explaining the
basics of what machine learning is all
about so primary keyword machine
learning basic secondary keywords what
is machine learning and introduction to
machine learning so that's the whole
idea behind choosing keywords you want
that keyword that really is going to
define the content and then support that
with those secondary keywords so
remember when you're performing your
keyword research choose keywords for
your videos that Google show those on
the video results page so what I mean by
that is your video can get more views if
you rank on Google as well so the whole
idea is not necessarily to be found on
YouTube it's also to be found on Google
so if I go back to Google and I just
type in data science for beginners and I
type in videos then you could see we're
ranked number one so even if you're not
looking at the videos clicking on the
videos link on Google search you can
always just when you do a search what
Google's going to do is also put in the
videos here on par as part of the search
results so what they're going to show
you is the top videos that are ranking
for that particular keyword and so we
may not rank overall for data science
for beginners but we're ranked number
one in the videos category and so if
somebody's looking for a video that's
important and you can see here that
these first two are ads so what Google
is doing is they're saying hey this is
so relevant this particular video for
the keyword query data science for begin
scanners that we're going to show it
above the organic listings even though
it's a video so the whole idea is to be
found on YouTube and Google because
you're increasing your visibility you're
increasing your chances of getting found
on both search platforms so according to
backlinko google Ranks videos with
keywords like how to tutorials so you
know a lot of the videos that you find
on YouTube are going to be instructional
based and so what Google's doing is
they're saying hey if somebody types in
how to or tutorial or an introduction to
anything that's going to signal to
Google that it's instructional it's
going to help you rank so when you
search for machine learning tutorial or
how to become a machine learning
engineer you're going to get results
related to that because if you look at
these examples we have machine learning
tutorial in our title or how to become a
machine learning engineer so keep that
in mind if you're creating a video video
and it's educational in nature you know
use those key terms like how to and
tutorials in the video title because
that will help you rank so let's move
over now to video title so we want to
use our Target keyword in the title of
the video and again we want to make sure
if it's educational to include that
keyword tutorial or how to so for every
video title YouTube has a limit of a
hundred characters so we really have to
pick and choose really wisely so if we
look at the video that we were focusing
on a couple of minutes ago so machine
learning Basics here we could see under
100 characters we have machine learning
Basics what is machine learning
introduction to machine learning and
then the brand name so that is the title
of this particular video so it takes
into account the primary keyword the
secondary keywords and the title and it
also includes that really the key term
that really Google and YouTube like and
that's what is machine learning so it's
helping us Rank by having our keywords
in the title with that key phrase what
is okay so that's a good tidbit on
creating a good video title is to align
it with the right keywords your primary
and your secondary and so we want to use
those catchy words and numbers to gain
High click-through rates just like you
would on the title tag of your web page
we want to do the same with our video
title because the video titles what's
going to show up in search so if I go
back to you know search here we could
see you know data science tutorial data
science for beginners so we want to make
sure in this case you can see data
science in five minutes so that was
purposely done so that hey I don't have
time to watch a video I only have a
couple minutes data science in five
minutes okay great I'm going to click on
the video and now I have an opportunity
to watch something and learn something
under five minutes so choose using the
right words in your video title is going
to help you get that click-through rate
up remember click the array is clicks
divided by Impressions and an impression
is how many times your video shows up
and the search results on YouTube or
Google so we want to keep our
click-through rate high and in order to
do that we want to be able to write some
really good title tags for our video so
use catchy words like a number or how to
or what is because that's going to
resonate with people when they're
searching now for the description what
we want to do is we want to use the
target word at the beginning of the
description the title and the tags
itself so if I go back to my video here
machine learning Basics we know it's in
the video title and right off the bat if
I look at the description of the video
here I can see this machine learning
Basics video will help you understand
what is machine learning so our primary
keyword is in the first sentence right
in the introductory of this description
and so that's going to bode well for
optimizing our video the description
length is 5 000 characters so we have a
lot of characters to work with so if I
go back to my video I click show more we
have a lot of characters to really
describe what the video is about okay
there's no shortage no shortage of
including keywords into the content so
you have 5 000 characters go ahead and
see if you can work in naturally your
keywords but one of the key tips here is
just make sure that first sentence
starts out with that keyword that's a
good tip of course you always want to
make it sound natural as possible you
don't want to stuff it with keywords at
the same time work them in naturally
work in your keywords naturally and then
include hashtags in your description to
help the audience find your video is
easily so if I go back here you know we
want to be able to include hashtags so
hashtags it's like anything else she
would use on social media it just
signals to the end user hey this is what
the video is all about and if I go ahead
and type in that keyword then it's our
video has a better chance because it's a
line with that hashtag and then there's
Target keywords and LSI keywords latent
semantic indexing keywords we want to be
able to use those keywords as Target
keywords with our video so if you recall
the example I gave a few minutes ago we
used the Facebook ads tutorial as our
example here I could see all the target
keywords associated with that particular
video so don't be afraid to use those
LSI related keywords meaning keywords
that are related to the content use them
as Target keywords with the video so
between your LSI keywords Target
keywords and then using our primary and
secondary keyword in the title tag using
our primary and secondary keyword in the
description and then using in hashtags
in the description the combination of
all of that if we chose the right
keyword then we should find that our
video will eventually rank on YouTube so
just doing these small tidbits with our
keywords really help get our video to
rank so at the end of the day we want to
be able to use the tools available to Us
YouTube Itself by looking at our
competitors those extensions like vid IQ
the autocomplete to really find our good
keywords and then incorporating those
keywords into you know the title tag the
description as Target keywords hashtags
we should really be off and running with
our video on YouTube so at simply learn
if I go to YouTube and I just type in
machine learning you could see we're
right here is the first organic video on
YouTube for machine learning if I jump
over to Google and I type in machine
learning Basics you can see where number
or number one for machine learning
Basics under videos if I click on all
we're also ranked here as well under the
video section on organic search results
another example data science for
beginners we ranked number one for that
if I look at another keyword data
science interview questions okay we'll
rank number two for that so we're
ranking for a lot of videos and why are
we ranking for a lot of different
content and videos on Google Search and
on YouTube well we put a lot of work in
behind the scenes of creating the video
and that's what we want to show you so
part of that has a lot to do with you
know how our audience engages and sees
our video so for example we're looking
at the machine learning Basics video
here and we can see that it has over 221
000 subscribers for this video 234
000 views we've had over 2 000 people
like the video and we have had over 270
plus comment on the video so when we get
our our videos to rank then we can see
there's a lot of Engagement and so
that's the whole idea is when you do a
video and you want to show up on YouTube
you want people to enjoy you want people
to share it you want people to like it
you want people to comment on it and
that's part of the whole ecosystem of
YouTube It's you know we're going to
show you behind the scenes of what it
takes to get your videos to rank and
then we're going to show you some of the
metrics involved with some of these
videos to help you stay ranking so
without further Ado let's go into how to
get your videos to rank on YouTube so
we're going to talk about keyword
research for YouTube we're going to talk
about some ways to create high quality
videos so the importance of user
engagement just as I showed you with the
machine learning Basics video all the
shares all the commenting all the views
and subscriptions then we're going to
get into how to promote your content and
then we're going to just review a little
checklist for you and sum it all up so
let's get started with keyword research
so basic quickly what we want to do is
Center our keywords just like our
website we want to Center our keywords
around or our content around good
keywords so the videos on YouTube are no
different than the web pages on our
website so if we have somebody who
states YouTube is the world's second
most well well-known engine well it is
because it's right behind Google it's
not a search engine per se it's a video
platform but if it was a search engine
it'd probably be second right behind
Google so YouTube is pretty popular
majority people use YouTube search every
day to watch videos on a number of
different topics so they can find these
videos in Google but because YouTube's
so powerful and so popular people go
directly right into YouTube for their
searches and so the whole idea behind
YouTube being the second most well-known
search engine is centered around
keywords so if you have the right
keywords for your video then the chances
of you ranking High higher increases on
YouTube so we're gonna share with you a
few easy ways to do keyword research
this is the most important step in
getting your videos to rank on YouTube
just like for those of you who watched
any of the SEO videos we produced it at
simply learn you know that keyword
research is so essential to getting your
web pages to rank on Google well it's no
different keyword research and choosing
the right keywords is just as important
for your videos as is for your web pages
so we're going to go into a few things
to do here to find the right keywords so
we have the search suggestion you can
look at your competitors we have
different tools we can use some other
factors involved in Google itself so
let's start talking about some of these
ways to really hone in and do some good
research on your keywords to align them
with your videos first thing is search
suggest so YouTube has a feature called
autocomplete so if you've done any
searches on on Google it's very similar
if you're typing something in to YouTube
search then YouTube is going to suggest
other related popular keywords so let's
take a look at that if we go back to
YouTube for a second and I just type in
machine learning YouTube is going to
populate on the autocomplete in the
search bar some other popular keywords
that we can potentially use or in this
case if I Choose You Know machine
learning tutorial I'm going to see a
video about machine learning tutorial so
here you can see simply learns rank
number one for machine learning tutorial
but there are other videos that show up
in my search result so we want to be
able to use the search suggestion box in
the search box field so when we're
typing in something you know YouTube
just like on Google is going to give us
those suggestions so if we're focusing a
video on machine learning then you know
we have some ideas of some other
keywords that we could center around
because these are are popular keywords
these are key words that people are
using to search on YouTube so that's one
suggestion looking at competitors is
another suggestion so we could search
for keywords used by our competitors in
their video and title and description so
let me talk a little bit about that what
you want to do is you want to go to that
particular channel of your competitor so
when you go to your particular
competitors YouTube channel you want to
be able to click on the videos tab when
you click on the videos tab then you're
going to sort by most popular and then
what you could do is see a list of
videos and then when you look at a list
of videos you're going to choose a video
and then what you're going to do then is
take a look at the keywords used in the
title and description and then once you
do that you're going to have a list of
keywords that you can use yourself for
that video so for example let's go back
to YouTube so if I go to type in simply
learn here's their Channel page just by
clicking on Sim learn I click on videos
ever wonder if there's so now I can see
all the videos ever wonder if there's an
easier way go back so here I can see all
the videos sort by most popular once
they do that then I can choose a video
this is the most popular video right now
for simply learn if I click on that
video it's automatically going to start
playing but what I could do is simply
just look at you know the content
description so just by clicking show
more I can see all the content that
align with this video that's one way to
do it is simply by looking at your
competitors now what you could also do
is look at the tags associated with the
particular video and so what you want to
do is you want to look at the HTML and
so that means looking at the page source
so just like web pages what YouTube does
is they look at meta tags so if you call
from SEO in order to get your pages to
rank you need to have a title tag and a
meta tag description so videos are no
different what we're doing uh for
YouTube is aligning certain keywords
with the video so if you take a look and
do a search for keywords by viewing the
page Source you're going to see all the
keywords associated with a particular
video so for example if I go back to
YouTube and I look at the page source of
a video Let's just say this video here
Facebook's ad tutorial I'm going to pull
up the page source and all I need to do
is control F and type in keywords and
now for that Facebook video I can see
all the keywords associated with the
video so you can see there's a lot of
different keywords we're aligning with
this video and so why do we want to do
that because we want you know our video
to show up for keywords that people may
type in and so if you use that YouTube
autocomplete it's going to give you
those ideas this most popular keywords
so if they're related align those
keywords with the video so here you can
see Facebook marketing Facebook ads
track strategy Facebook ads for
beginners so forth and so on so there's
a lot of keywords we've aligned here
with that particular video and again all
you need to do is look at the page
source so right clicking view page
source to a control F for keywords and
you'll be able to see the keywords
aligned so you could do that for your
competitors videos as well so you can
see what keywords your competitors using
for a video that's most popular for
their Channel and is also ranking on
YouTube and on Google so using the
autocomplete gives you those keyword
ideas looking at your competitors videos
also gives you some other ideas for
keywords that you can align with a video
that's relevant that you want to rank
for so let's look at some other ideas
here so you can install plugins and
there are plenty of plugins available on
the Chrome browser that will help you
see the video tags associated with a
particular video so a couple of exams
samples or vid IQ and tubebuddy those
are extensions that work in Chrome and
what they do is they give you the exact
tags that a particular video is using so
for example if I go back here and I look
at a video on YouTube let's just say the
machine learning Basics video I have vid
IQ installed on my Chrome browser so
just by clicking on that vid IQ is going
to give me a lot of information about
that video I'm just going to give me an
overview of their particular metrics
they're going to give me some other
information associated with Facebook
some engagement metrics really what I'm
interested in is those keywords so if I
scroll down a bit here I can see the
video tags associated with the machine
learning Basics video so vid IQ is
telling me is these keywords are
associated with this video and not only
does it show me what keywords are
associated I can also see where they
rank so for machine learning basic this
particular video ranks number one if I
go down I could see what is machine
learning and how does it work I can see
it's rank number two here I could see
machine learning algorithms it's ranked
number nine so I can get some ideas of
the types of keywords that are being
used as tags for that video further down
I can also see some Channel tags but
really this is the video tags or the
idea place I want to be able to look to
get an idea of the types of keywords
that are associated with the video that
are also ranking or not ranking so
that's another way for you to really get
an understanding of what keywords to use
at the particular video so autocomplete
you can look at the page source of a
competitors video or you can use a
Chrome extension in this case I'm using
vid IQ to give me some information about
the video tags for a particular video so
according to an industry study using
keywords and video tags will help you
rank like well on YouTube so you have to
use keywords and video tags if you want
your video to rank there's been a lot of
studies YouTube is so popular and videos
are so prominent in today's world where
if you have videos and you're going to
upload them to YouTube then associate
the right keywords with those videos so
some important factors when we look at
keywords what we want to do is look at
search volume we want to look at
competition we want to look at relevancy
we want to look at the primary and
secondary keywords that we want to use
so well chosen keywords will help you
rank so we just gave you some ideas on
how to do some keyword research again
those ideas were really to use the
autocomplete on YouTube or Google
they're going to give you some popular
keywords you can look what your
competitors are doing by looking at the
page source and just looking at the
keywords that are aligned with that
video or you can use a third-party
extension in Chrome in my example I use
is vid IQ that gave me the keywords
associated with that video so you have
ways to get the keywords so what we want
to do is we want to make sure we choose
keywords with high search volume they're
going to drive more traffic to your
video however we want to balance it out
with keywords that have load difficulty
and are easier to rank for so you don't
want to choose something very broad
that's just going to be very difficult
to rank for and of course we always want
to go with relevancy so for talking
about machine learning Basics then we
want to choose keywords associated with
that and that's where that autocomplete
comes in handy because what Google's
going to do and YouTube's going to do is
give us keywords that are very closely
related to the video that we're trying
to optimize for and so we have a number
of different keywords that are disposal
that are relevant that we can look to
see if they have good volume and low
competition and so the whole idea is we
want to choose a keyword that defines
the nature of the content and then what
we want to to do is support that with
secondary keywords so we want keywords
that are highly relevant to the primary
keyword so that's the way to go about
aligning your keywords you want keywords
that are high volume low competition or
relevant and you want to choose that one
keyword that is really what the
content's about and then those secondary
keywords that support the primary so if
you have a machine learning video you
could choose your primary keyword as in
this case the machine learning Basics
video so well chosen keywords help you
rank well on YouTube just like the
machine learning Basics so if I go back
to our video our machine learning Basics
video if I just type in machine learning
Basics I'll be able to pull it up and so
here it is if I click on it I'm going to
go to YouTube and so here I can see this
keyword we know humans learn from is
well aligned because it's in the title
it's in the copy and it's a line is a
keyword tagged with the video so we know
that that keyword has good volume low
competition is relevant because that's
what the video is about the basics of
machine learning it's an introduction to
machine learning so instead of honing in
on just introduction and machine
learning primary keyword is machine
learning Basics and then we supported
that video with those secondary keywords
what is machine learning because
somebody who doesn't know machine
learning is probably going to type in
that keyword and then introduction to
machine learning is a good secondary
keyword because it's explaining the
basics of what machine learning is all
about so primary keyword machine
learning basic secondary keywords what
is machine learning an introduction to
machine learning so that's the whole
idea behind choosing keywords you want
that keyword that really is going to
define the content and then support that
with those secondary keywords so
remember when you're performing your
keyword research choose keywords for
your videos that Google shows on the
video results page so what I mean by
that is your video can get more views if
you rank on Google as well so the whole
idea is not necessarily to be found on
YouTube it's also to be found on Google
so if I go back to Google and I just
type in data science for beginners and I
type in videos then you can see we're
ranked number one so even if you're not
looking at the videos clicking on the
videos link on Google search you can
always just when you do a search what
Google's going to do is also put in the
videos here on par as part of the search
results so what they're going to show
you is the top videos that are ranking
for that particular keyword and so we
may not rank overall for data science
for beginners but we're ranked number
one in the videos category and so
somebody's looking for a video that's
important and you can see here that
these first two are ads so what Google
is doing is they're saying hey this is
so relevant this particular video for
the keyword query data science for
beginners that we're going to show it
above the organic listings even though
it's a video so the whole idea is to be
found on YouTube and Google because
you're increasing your visibility you're
increasing your chances of getting found
on both search platforms so according to
backlinko google Ranks videos with
keywords like how to tutorials so you
know a lot of the videos that you find
on YouTube are going to be instructional
based and so what Google's doing is
they're saying hey if somebody types in
how to or tutorial or an introduction to
anything that's going to signal to
Google that it's instructional it's
going to help you rank so when you
search for machine learning tutorial or
how to become a machine learning
engineer you're going to get results
related to that because if you look at
these examples we have machine learning
tutorial in our title or how to become a
machine learning engineer so keep that
in mind if you're creating a video and
it's educational in nature you know use
those key terms like how to and
tutorials in the video title because
that will help you rank so let's move
over now to video title so we want to
use our Target keyword in the title of
the video and again we want to make sure
if it's educational to include that
keyword tutorial or how to so for every
video title YouTube has a limit of 100
characters so we really have to pick and
choose a really wisely so if we look at
the video that we were focusing on a
couple minutes ago so machine learning
Basics here we could see under 100
characters we have machine learning
Basics what is machine learning
introduction to machine learning and
then the brand name so that is the title
of this particular video so takes into
account the primary keyword the
secondary keywords and the title and it
also includes that really that key term
that really Google and YouTube like and
that's what is machine learning so it's
helping us Rank by having our keywords
in the title with that key phrase what
is okay so that's a good tidbit on
creating a good video title is to align
it with the right keywords your primary
and your secondary and so we want to use
those catchy words and numbers to gain
High click-through rates just like you
would on the title tag of your web page
we want to do the same with our video
title because the video titles what's
going to show up in search so if I go
back to you know search here we could
see you know data science tutorial data
science for beginners so we want to make
sure in this case you can see data
science in five minutes so that was
purposely done so that hey I don't have
time to watch a video I only have a
couple minutes data science in five
minutes okay great I'm going to click on
the video and now I have an opportunity
to watch something and learn something
under five minutes so choosing the right
words in your video title is going to
help you get that click clicked your way
out remember click the array is clicks
divided by Impressions and an impression
is how many times your video shows up
and the search results on YouTube or
Google so we want to keep our
click-through rate high and in order to
do that we want to be able to write some
really good title tags for our video so
use catchy words like a number or how to
or what is because that's going to
resonate with people when they're
searching now for the description what
we want to do is we want to use the
target word at the beginning of the
description the title and the tags
itself so if I go back to my video here
machine learning Basics we know it's in
the video title and right off the bat if
I look at the description of the video
here I can see this machine learning
Basics video will help you understand
what is machine learning so our primary
keyword is in the first sentence right
in the introductory of the description
and so that's going to bode well for
optimizing our video the description
length is 5 000 characters so we have a
lot of characters to work with so if I
go back to my video I click show more we
have a lot of characters to really
describe what the video is about okay
there's no shortage no shortage of
including keywords into the content so
you have 5 000 characters go ahead and
see if you can work in naturally your
keywords but one of the key tips here is
just make sure that first sentence
starts out with that keyword that's a
good tip of course you always want to
make it sound natural as possible you
don't want to stuff it with keywords at
the same time work them in naturally
work in your keywords naturally and then
include hashtags in your description to
help the audience find your video is
easily so if I go back here you know we
want to be able to include hashtags so
hashtags it's like anything else you
would use on social media it just
signals to the end user hey this is what
the video is all about and if I go ahead
and type in that keyword then it's our
video has a better chance because it's a
line with that hashtag and then there's
Target keywords and LSI keywords latent
semantic indexing keywords we want to be
able to use those keywords as Target
keywords with our video so if you recall
the example I gave a few minutes ago we
used the Facebook ads tutorial as our
example here I could see all the target
keywords associated with that particular
video so don't be afraid to use those
LSI related keywords meaning keywords
that are related to the content use them
as Target keywords with the video so
between your LSI keywords Target
keywords and then using our primary and
secondary keyword in the title tag using
our primary and secondary keyword in the
description and then using hashtags in
the description the combination of all
of that if we chose the right keyword
then we should find that our video will
eventually rank on YouTube so just doing
these small tidbits with our keywords
really help get our video to rank so at
the end of the day we want to be able to
use the tools available to Us YouTube
Itself by looking at our competitors
those extensions like vid IQ the
autocomplete to really find our good
keywords and then incorporating those
keywords into you know the title tag the
description as Target keywords hashtags
we should really be off and running with
our video on YouTube that's our turn our
attention to creating high quality
videos and some of the best practices
around that so along with everything we
mentioned about choosing the right
keywords we always need to keep in mind
that the videos we create need to be of
high quality so the content itself in
addition to the keywords is a primary
factor in ranking so so in order to have
keywords we need to have content and in
order to rank we need to have you know
good content so let's talk a little bit
about creating content and what's
involved with that and what we really
mean by high quality videos so if you
have a video content that is not
informative or irrelevant to the topic
it won't rank so that's just common
sense so you need to create content
that's aligned with the topic obviously
and then that way you have keywords that
are aligned with the content so but if
you have content it really isn't aligned
with the topic then you're not going to
rank no matter how much you've optimized
that video so just keep that in mind so
there's a couple of things we want to
look at here so high quality content is
determined by really two metrics so
we're not sure about how good our
content is and how good of high quality
video we created we want to look at
audience retention and user engagement
so on audience retention when simply the
percentage length of your video that the
audience has watched It's the percentage
your audience has watched so focusing on
audience retention is important for
people who want their videos to rank
high so if you want to rank you need to
optimize for the keywords but got to
keep in mind content so content is
related to audience retention and user
engagement so audience retention
percentage length your video of your
video that the audience has watched and
for example it can be both absolute in
minutes or percentages so audience
retention can be the average view
duration or percentage of the audience
that watched then we have user
engagement so yours engagement viewers
who are engaged with your content and so
that means they're either sharing it
subscribing commenting or liking so
those are all forms of Engagement so the
percentage of users who watched or how
long they watched versus engage
management or in combination with
engagement are two factors for ranking
so let's talk about some tips for
creating high quality videos so we want
to publish longer videos and so what do
we mean behind longer videos so what's
the reason for longer videos let's just
suppose we have two videos one shorter
in length and one longer in length first
video is 15 minutes long the second
video is seven minutes long so on
average if viewers watch about 40 of
both videos then video x which is 15
minutes long will have more than twice
the watch time of the video that's seven
minutes long so remember duration we
want you know people to watch our videos
longer so if the video is longer in
length if it's 40 then it's gonna have a
longer audience engagement audience
retention so that's one of the reasons
you know from a metric standpoint so
even when viewers watch you know both
videos the time is going to differ so we
want to take into account longer videos
for primarily that region is because you
know it gives an end user an opportunity
to watch the video longer and then it's
going to help us rank our videos longer
so when we talk about watch time so if
one video has higher watch time than the
other watch time is just the number of
views times the average view duration so
another tip is we want to plan our video
script so we want to keep the content
organized my recognition is you know
create an outline first and once you
create an outline of how the video is
going to flow then start populating with
content and so to me that's how you can
keep the flow organized okay is really
with an outline starting out with an
on-pound there's no videos are no
different than say a presentation if
you've done a PowerPoint presentation
you always want to start out doing an
outline and then we want to upload a
high resolution videos hi resolution we
don't want to create videos that you
know a small resolution like say you
know 400 by 400 resolution or something
you know something really small we want
to create something a very high res so
according to back or link Oaks more than
50 of videos on the first page of
YouTube are high definition so high
definition videos of higher quality are
going to be shown on the first page of
YouTube more often than not so high
resolution videos organizing the content
publishing longer videos are examples of
creating high quality video we also want
to make sure that content is relevant to
the title so if we're talking about
machine learning Basics you know
obviously the content is going to be
about you know intro to machine learning
or what is machine learning and then the
title should reflect that content so
aligning the title sets the expectation
for the end user so when they see a
title what is machine learning then when
they watch the the video if they're
expecting to learn about machine
learning and what it is so if it meets
expectations then the chances are that
person who's watching the video is going
to watch it longer and that means it's
going to fulfill the viewers
requirements and when you align
everything accordingly keywords titles
content then at the end of the day the
user is going to watch it and the more
they watch it the higher the engagement
the higher the engagement the better
chance you have to rank some other tips
that you could use to create high
quality videos so we want to be able to
you know use examples to clarify our
content so you don't be afraid to go
into another screen like I am if I want
to I'm talking about videos jump into
the machine learning Basics video which
I've done throughout this session I can
simply do that by keeping the user
engaged here this video is about machine
learning Basics well the titles align
with the video we made sure that we have
have a nice description about what the
video is about and we're aligning the
expectations so not only that I'm
showing you example within the video
itself so we want to use examples
throughout your video to keep the user
engaged it will also help clarify what
you're trying to express in the video
itself so we want to make it visually
appealing so visually appealing means
imagery or examples in the video and
then when we talk about imagery you know
you want to use good images in your
video so use public domain sites that
are available to you like Shutterstock
or flat icon I mean there are plenty of
those sites out there so feel free to
use any one of those sites to use high
quality images in your video give more
information to your audience okay giving
maximum relevant information can help
gain more reviews and so when we talk
about more information again it goes
back to you know the examples you use
there's no should be no shortage of
examples Hey their description use all 5
000 characters at your disposal imagery
we want to build up as much information
as you can in the video itself to keep
the end user the viewer engaged we also
want to create original content so
always create original content you could
certainly get ideas from YouTube if you
want to create a video about machine
learning see what else has already been
done do searches on YouTube itself but
you know when you're going to create a
video yeah you can create another video
about what is machine learning but just
make sure it has your own take on it
you're the subject matter expert when
creating the video create it with your
own original content have high audio
quality and video effects so just like
you see here on this video we have
effects in it and the audio is of high
quality meaning no background noise no
Distortion and we want to be able to
speak clearly in the video so you want
to speak clearly loudly concise just as
I'm trying to do now so that you can
understand what I'm trying to say or
what the viewer is trying to to
understand when they're watching the
video so watching and listening are two
of the components and you want to make
sure both of our high quality avoid
distractions we don't want to pause you
don't want to ramble on a particular
Point too long we want to keep users
engaged so you always want to move from
one point to the other intermix it with
examples those are ways to keep the
users engaged we want to include
transcripts or subtitles for your video
so transcripts is just more content
that's aligned with the video and the
search engines will be able to pick up
that content and help your video rank so
to me that's a key component to creating
a good video is having the necessary
content that go along with the video
that outline I referenced earlier in
terms of organization you always want to
have a Content outline so what topics
are you going to cover in the video
that's why you need the outline to point
that out confirm that before you
actually start creating the video okay
focus on the initial 15 seconds so
that's key you know somebody's going to
click the play button of your video and
if you don't catch them in the first 15
seconds then they're likely going to
pause the video or just go ahead and
close it out all together so you want to
be able to capture somebody's attention
right off the bat and even before they
click on that play button you want to
make sure again you're exceeding
expectations that title is aligned with
the content so in your first 15 seconds
it basically needs to be catchy but also
setting the expectation of what the user
is expecting so in this example here we
want to pay close attention to the first
15 seconds that's when viewers are most
likely to drop off so we can look at
audience retention and YouTube so use
the options above the graph to view
absolute audience retention or relative
audience retention so audience retention
is basically how many views a video
received and the percentage of the total
number of video views and that includes
every moment of the video as a
percentage so we'll show you an example
of what that looks like so here if we go
to the machine learning Basics video we
can look at the audience retention
report and this is since it's been
uploaded the lifetime audience retention
so here we can see a nice graph the
percentage of people who viewed it and
how long they viewed it so in percentage
so here for example I can see you know
43 44 percent watch the video for at
least two minutes here I can see 28.6
percent wash it for six minutes plus so
that that's the audience retention it
gives us an idea in terms of percentage
how many people or percentage of people
watch the video at what length so that's
audience retention so we want to keep
that number high at the very initial
stage of the video and we want to keep
it high throughout and that's why you
always want to create high quality
content using those examples using
imagery making it organized content not
pausing you know going from one point to
the other those are all best practices
to keep the viewer engaged and then we
want to add resources from well-known
sites so throughout this video we've
used backlinko there are other sources
we've used so if you have a source go
ahead and put it in your video to add
credibility and then we want to use
cards to your videos so this cards is
basically a feature that recommends
relevant videos to your audience so in
addition to machine learning Basics
there could be other videos about
machine learning that we can recommend
or you two can recommend to the audience
so set up end screens you want to make
sure that with end screens you can use
relevant videos to your audience towards
the end of your video so you can
recommend relevant videos towards the
end of your video you can also create
playlists so this is a feature that
keeps your audience engaged with
relevant content by Auto playing the
next video so if you enable this feature
it's going to go from one video to
another pattern interrupts keep the
audience engaged so basically it allows
for your audience to stay within one
video without having any interruptions
involved and so going back to the did
you know audience retention report helps
you analyze how well your videos are
engaging to the audience so what do we
mean by that well if I go back again to
my audience retention report how
engaging was it well I could see 42
percent 43 percent watched it on average
of 3 minutes and 21 seconds so to me
that's pretty good of course we always
want a hundred percent of the video the
video is seven minutes long if almost
half of our audience saw over half of
the video then I would say that's pretty
good people were engaged so audience
retention just is a good report to start
looking at to help you understand how
engaging is my video and if your video
is not engaging you know you can always
go back and edit it or fix it or tweak
it so remember the average view duration
for all videos and top performing videos
listed by all time we can look at that
information as well in addition we can
look at demographics so we can get an
overview of the age gender and location
and we can look at playback locations
report and what the playback locations
report does is it helps us determine the
platforms where our videos are being
streamed from within YouTube look at the
traffic sources where did the viewers
come from devices did they look on
mobile or tablet and so if there's any
doubts you know if you have any
questions please drop a comment below
but especially if you have any doubts on
the metrics so if we go back into
YouTube we can look at analytics and if
we're looking at analytics we can see
more and then this is going to show us
everything we need to see from device
type so if I click on more I can see my
playback location so this will show me
where the video is watched it was on a
watch page or a channel page I could see
the traffic sources I could see the
gender and age so if I click on the
viewer age report I can see the
percentage of views by age so I can get
a lot of information
about my video and how it's performed
who's watched it what they've done with
it where they come from all the
information they need to know and so
it's all within YouTube analytics so
again if you have any questions about
that you know just drop a comment below
especially if you're new to YouTube you
may have some questions but just know
that every video you publish to YouTube
high quality align with your keywords
you're going to be able to view the
metrics by looking at YouTube analytics
so let's talk about the importance of
user engagement so engagement is as we
mentioned important because basically we
can't rank without engagement our videos
won't rank unless we have engagement so
that's why it's important so engagement
is somebody liking the video commenting
sharing it or subscribing each one of
these is important to ranking so yes you
need to line keywords yes you need to
have high quality content so when you do
both of those and you upload your video
then it's up to the viewer and so the
hard work that you put out for the video
is hopefully going to pay dividends with
engagement so you want people to do one
of these four okay so let's talk about
what that means so how do I get
engagement so we already talked about
creating engaging content so there are a
lot of tips to creating engaging content
and so according to wordstream if your
content is entertaining then over three
quarters of the users are going to share
it so that's part of keeping uh users
engaged is keeping it entertaining is
part of getting a high quality video so
remember on that high quality video when
we say entertaining the audio portion
has a lot to do with it examples has a
lot to do with it quality of the video
itself has a lot to do with it so a lot
of components so all those components on
a high quality video are going to lead
to engagement so parts of what you could
do in your videos is conduct a quiz so
meaning the quiz itself is a way to keep
people engaged in your video so that
also help you get some more comments so
according to backlinku video comments
help and rank in your video higher so
just as I mentioned the last segment
about YouTube analytics and all the
different reports available on YouTube
hey if you have questions on those just
go ahead and add a comment so that's a
way to entice your users or your viewers
to add comments is if they have
questions because you know with videos
you're not going to be able to cover
every detail or every minute detail
about a particular topic you can only
cover in some cases the topic at a high
level so users are going to have
comments or questions naturally and so
the comments section is a good way to
remind viewers hey if you have a
question or comment go ahead and put in
the comment section because that will
lend to engagement as well so we want to
add sources from high quality websites
that'll help with engagement okay use
humor in your video we want to be able
to basically you know make it human
based we don't want to be robots so we
want to be able to sound like you know
we know what we're talking about but at
the same time talk to the viewer not
necessarily at the viewer or looking the
other way and just going through the
motions so adding humor adding
personality never hurts at the end of
the day we are all human adding that
clear call to action at the end of the
video will also lead to engagement so if
we win the video with hey leave your
comments on this video or hey feel free
to share this video with colleagues who
are interested then that's a call to
action that's likely going to lead to
more engagement reply to your comments
as well so if you have comments we
always want to reply to them likely
those comments are going to be questions
because again as I mentioned even in
this video about how to rank your videos
on YouTube okay there's a lot of
information and a lot of information
sometimes doesn't get covered in its
entirety and so we want to make sure
that if we miss something because we're
only human that we're able to respond in
the form of an answer to a question that
somebody leaves in the comments section
so more comments also lead to higher
rankings because it's engaged engagement
so when you're getting high engagement
and your video starts to rank well you
know you're going to start feeling
really good and what is that going to do
look at that feel good is going to lead
to confidence which in turn is going to
probably lead to more videos and that's
exactly what we do at simply learn I
mean we're in the education business but
we're in it to not only educate but
making sure that our videos are shown to
as many people as possible so that we
can educate as many people as possible
so it's all it's contagious so getting
ranked feels good and then once you get
ranked then you know you probably have
good engagement okay let's talk about
how to promote your content so once
you've done all the hard work getting
your video done high quality content
optimized with keywords and then publish
to YouTube we want to let everybody in
the world know about it right so we want
to promote it we've done all the work we
want to promote it now so is it
necessary to promote it I would say yes
because once your video is published you
want to reach out you want to reach
reach out to your audience not
necessarily on YouTube but on different
platforms so if you're active on
Facebook or Twitter that's an
opportunity for you to post or tweet
something about the new video so when we
say different platforms I am talking
about you know social media platforms so
it depends on what you're active on so
if you're active on Facebook yeah go
ahead and post some of you're active on
Twitter go ahead and tweet something it
could be you know on LinkedIn group if
you're part of a LinkedIn group about
you know machine learning then go ahead
and post something to that group to
promote the video so that's going to
help Drive traffic to the video and then
help with engagement so we want to
engage with our audience on those social
media sites so it really depends on what
you're active on so if you have a large
following on Twitter then go ahead and
you know share that YouTube video link
on Twitter with the Tweet that's going
to drive traffic from Twitter to YouTube
Remember You know you're going to be
able to see audience engagement or
retention by getting people to watch the
video so you're going to be able to see
right away by promoting the video and
driving traffic to the video how
engaging it is remember the more people
you have watched the video the more
engaging it becomes the better it's
going to rain so it's an ecosystem and
promoting your content is part of that
ecosystem so it all starts with social
media if you're active on whatever
platform that is go ahead and promote it
so you can also look at you know content
based social media sites or social media
content based platforms like Reddit or
Flickr for example so you can
participate in a forum discussion on
Reddit so in this example here it's
about machine learning so we want to be
able to post something about machine
learning with the link to our video so
we can also go to content-based sites
that are q a uh related like quora for
example Cora is a really good site where
you know if you go there post
information about machine learning or
the basics of machine learning with the
link back to the video it's going to
help because not only is it going to
drive traffic but it's going to signal
to Google hey you get a lot of traffic
coming from quora this is going to bode
well for this video in terms of ranking
so here's an example you know if you
find a question that you can post on
core then you're going to get people to
click on your video and respond
accordingly on quora or you can act as
the person responding to a question
that's already there so somebody already
asked a question about what is machine
learning you can respond with your video
as the answer so you can just simply
embed your video URL as part of your
answer that'll help Drive traffic so you
can also create your own blog and embed
your video so in the case of machine
learning here we have an example machine
learning what is it and why it matters
so this goes nicely with the video so
here you can see the person the author
of this blog went ahead and embedded did
the relevant video in the blog post so
they play off one another nicely you can
also opt in for influencer marketing
meaning hey you can reach out to
somebody in this example here you know
Katie nuggets posted information about
machine learning so in this case why
choose machine learning as a career well
they get information and then what do
they do they went ahead and embedded the
video about machine learning Basics and
so working with you know influencers in
a particular category or topic will help
Drive traffic to the video you can also
create a YouTube playlist so playlists
tend to rank high in YouTube searches so
if you find yourself doing a lot of
videos we'll go ahead and you know go to
your channel and simply on your channel
you can go ahead and create playlists so
when you create playlists basically what
you're doing is you're organizing the
content into different playlists no
different than say the music you have
set up on your you know or your iPhone
or iPad or or iPod whatever it is you're
using so you're just creating different
videos in a particular category and it
YouTube likes it it's organized it's
going to help you get your videos found
quicker and easier on YouTube Itself by
putting your videos in a playlist so
here you could see we have entire
playlist on machine learning trending
Technologies cloud computing Big Data
digital marketing project management so
a lot of different playlists very
organized if somebody goes to the
channel they're going to be able to go
to the playlist that's interesting to
them and see all the videos there so it
allows not only the end user to find
what they're looking for but it's good
for YouTube because YouTube likes those
playlists so we want to engage our
Audience by posting your video link on a
community page so you could do that
within YouTube and you can prefer to
link your YouTube channel in your email
so you can also do that so for example
if I go back to YouTube and I'm looking
at out a YouTube video you know I can
always Click Share so here I'm gonna get
a particular URL that's associated with
the video and I can just embed that so I
can embed the whole thing in my email I
can embed it on a web page or a blog
post so just by clicking share I can
also immediately share it onto the
social media platforms that we mentioned
Facebook LinkedIn Reddit okay Tumblr so
there's a lot of ways to embed the video
not just on a blog post or influencer
blog post but in our email and on social
media as well so here's an example of
what we can do with the YouTube
discussion so we can also bookmark the
video on a popular bookmarking site you
know like stumbled upon or Reddit or you
know there's lots of other ones out
there so there's plenty of sites that
you'll be able to go to and bookmark
that content so that people can find it
and you can always opt for backlinks so
that means that hey if there's a blogger
out there that blogs about machine
learning you can always you know ask
that blogger to create a link back to
the video and you could reciprocate do
the same thing so that helps increase
the authority of the video so a lot of
things you could do to promote your
video so let's do a quick review on
everything we talked about in terms of
ranking your video on YouTube it all
starts with the keywords so we want to
identify a list of keywords that are
relevant to the video so we can use
tools to choose our keywords but
remember we want to choose keywords that
have high volume and low competition and
so where can we go to choose those
keywords well we can use the
autocomplete on YouTube we could check
out our own competitors videos or you
know we could use vid IQ or tubebuddy or
any of these extensions in Chrome to
help us look at the keywords that are
tagged with a particular video video so
remember we want to have a primary
keyword that's aligned with the content
then we want to choose LSI keywords as
our secondary keyword or keywords that
are related to the primary keyword so we
want to create high retention videos
meaning that first 15 seconds of the
most important but throughout the video
we want to use examples we want to keep
it interacting by adding quizzes imagery
good audio good video quality so we want
to focus on the user experience and we
also want to optimize our video content
what does that mean well those keywords
that we chose we want to use them in the
title we want to use them in the
description we want to use them as
hashtags we want to use them and tag
them with the video themselves so we can
add keywords to our meta tag okay we
don't want to overdo it but we want to
add a handful of keywords that are
associated with the video so we want to
be able to write eye catchy video titled
and descriptions so remember use some of
those key phrases like like a number or
a question like what is machine learning
so we want to use relevant meta tags for
the videos and we want to use popular
YouTube tags so we want to be able to
tag our videos appropriately to watch
the length of your meta tags so there
are links involved remember keywords at
the beginning of the title Target
keywords in the title description and
tags we want to use interesting
thumbnails to increase our click-through
rate ensure that thumbnails are relevant
meaning when I say thumbnails I mean the
actual title tag itself or The Meta
description we want to use hi-res videos
we want to create you know videos with
good high audio quality don't be afraid
to put in video effects like some
animation don't be afraid to use
examples and then you know obviously
look at the draft of the video before
you publish it so does your video follow
an outline is it organized so these are
all the things to take into account and
there's there's plenty more you can do
you know you remember once you create
and optimize that video you want to
promote it you want to make sure that
you're sharing it on social media you
create a complimentary blog you know
generate backlinks from say other blog
posts so there are lots of things you
can do to promote your video so before
you promote it you want to organize the
content create good quality content
align it with keywords once you publish
it you know keep organizing it by
creating this playlist and then reach
out on social reach out on different
communities related to the topic and all
those things combined will help you to
get your YouTube video ranked so again
some key takeaways here use the keyword
research Available to You on YouTube you
want to basically you know watch your
descriptions you want to be able to
align your keywords with your title and
meta tag description you want to be able
to promote your content on social media
on social bookmarking though and I can't
stress enough great high quality video
first 15 seconds are important but
you're gonna know if you have good
quality video because every video has
analytics associated with it so we want
to keep in mind the engagement so just
by looking at the video itself so here I
can see this blockchain in seven minutes
it was just posted just yesterday the
27th so basically already 42 likes 33
comments 378 views so these are all
engagement related metrics so you'll be
able to just look at the front of any
video and see how well it's performing
from an engagement standpoint so the
better the engagement the better you of
a chance you have to rank if you are
looking to become an SEO professional
then look no further than simply runs
postgraduate program in digital
marketing so don't miss out on this
opportunity Find the course Link in the
description for more information
now when we're talking about the trends
there are significant shifts happening
in organic search the first of which is
machine learning uh that is more
artificial intelligence analyzing search
queries and developing new algorithms
within the machine learning to serve up
results determine intent which is the
primary goal of machine learning and to
return not only the results but the
information you need as well as
predicting information you might need in
the near future
uh the second is voice search more and
more voice assistants are becoming
popular through your smartphone through
your laptop through home assistance and
people are asking for information and so
it is completely happening at an
auditory level not in visual level and
so how that is happening and how that
affects SEO reporting is really going to
be a factor moving forward and then also
as I'm sure if you've been doing any
search engine optimization for any
length of time you are familiar with the
struggle uh that has happened ever since
Google decided to strip keyword data out
of any analytics reporting that took
away really the number one way that you
were able to measure the effectiveness
of gaining keywords in the search
engines
now to hit each one of these just to
explain them a little bit more so that
you know exactly what's happening and
what it looks like as it affects your
current level of SEO work as well as
reporting uh as an example of machine
learning uh if you go into Google
AdWords right now and you were to set up
a campaign looking at maybe like auto
body or Auto work or something like that
if you typed in a few keywords into
Google what's happening is Google is
only reporting one phrase that might
cover two or three or four phrases based
on
for example Auto Body being is it one
word or is it two words Google here is
providing it as two words so even if I
type in auto body as a single word this
is where the machine learning is coming
in realizing that these are the same
queries and so rather than treat them as
individual queries what is happening is
through machine learning is they are
trying to figure out what is the intent
of the search and then grouping the
intent into single categories or single
searches and then all the variations
would be included in that now if I do
keyword research at a third party such
as word tracker or something like that
now what I'm going to find are multiple
different ways that people search uh
they're going to put in locations
they're going to put in details they're
going to you know use one word two words
and so in a third party keyword research
format we're going to see a lot more
variations because those are tracking
what people are actually typing in what
Google is doing from the machine
learning standpoint is condensing
everything and trying to group it into
as I said similar forms of intent
now What's Happening Here It means that
phrases or words that are plurals
acronyms
typical variants uh
such as words that may mean the same
thing uh but then they're different
words so they're going to group them
together and then also as you saw there
words with spaces or without spaces uh
conjunction words as well as hyphens and
apostrophes a lot of these are going to
fall out of what you're able to bid on
also in the paid search side and it will
all go into a particular group of words
under a primary heading so that's where
voice search is taking us is really a
condensing of the language into intent
what are people searching for and how do
we give that their in how do we give
their information back to them now
obviously this isn't perfect I've worked
with a number of clients where they may
offer a service and because of that
service Google is trying to then
associate them with another service uh
and it's not relevant and so because of
that machine learning sometimes uh what
we're seeing is a difficulty in trying
to get unique businesses new ideas or
something that just isn't a part of that
overall big picture uh they're trying to
force it into neat little boxes but as
we know business is not full of neat
little boxes uh it's messy it's fuzzy
it's it's all kinds of different types
of businesses suppliers industries that
are going to have some level of
uniqueness about them so hopefully this
can continue to improve uh but it does
at this point still need some human
intervention
the second aspect is voice search and
maybe some of you have uh maybe the
Google home or the Alexa Appliance in
your home and you've been playing around
with it and seeing what it can do uh but
also everyone's phone uh and then also
Cortana is on uh any Microsoft operating
system desktop and so being able to
search from your phone simply by a voice
command uh now this is affecting our
ability to report because this does not
show up uh as a search now if you're
using Google now and you are searching
on Google or a Google app it will show
up as a search referral however if
you're using Cortana if you're using uh
Siri it's going to use the
search engine of the operating system
and so in that case and I'm going to
address this a little bit later it shows
up as a direct visit rather than uh a
search initiated visit and so this is
affecting the reporting of SEO metrics
uh but at the same time it is also
changing the search landscape entirely
right now uh Amazon is probably Google's
biggest competitor for most searches
especially for electronics uh especially
for uh what you would consider things
for home uh and garden Amazon and right
now it has taken about 40 percent of the
market share away from Google in terms
of electronics and Home Products because
people are going to Amazon first and
they're using Alexa to do this so how
voice search it really is going to be uh
a volatile industry to follow over the
next five years
and then as I mentioned before probably
the biggest frustration of anyone doing
search engine optimization or wanting to
measure the effectiveness of
optimization or where they stand in the
marketplace is the keyword not provided
uh now there's a number of reasons why
Google has gone about this the first
reason that they gave was for privacy
reasons uh that they wanted people's
searches to be private but at the same
time if you are doing paid search you
have full access to keywords uh and also
if you are advertising through Google
you can Target People based on their
Search terms so we know the Privacy
thing uh was really kind of a smoke
screen I think what's going on here is
that this was really the first step to
getting people away from thinking of
individual keywords or key phrases and
focusing on one or two phrases that
there that would describe their business
by taking away the vast majority of
keywords that you're going to see in
your analytics it will force you to look
at other words it will force you to
think bigger picture rather than those
one or two words that most people
believe that's what my business needs
this is where I'm going to focus my
attention and in in so in some ways this
has been good by making people forcing
people to think Beyond a single word or
a single phrase about their business and
looking into the bigger picture this
also plays into the machine learning
because as I showed you before machine
learning is condensing all of these
keyword phrases trying to determine
intent and what better way to really
assist that than to start taking away
keyword data in the search engines
however when you take that away you have
then taken away the number one reporting
fact
of SEO and that is what keywords am I
ranking for what keywords are bringing
in not only visitors but business and so
by taking away the number one factor
we're forced to look at a number of
different methods that we can use then
to develop better campaign metrics
now one of the first things about uh
metrics is the expectations whenever I
work with a company I want to know
specifically what are your expectations
for the campaign what are you trying to
get out of it what do you expect uh I'll
never forget I was uh Consulting with an
agency about how they are developing
their SEO campaigns and how they were
reporting them to their clients uh and I
went with them oops to one of their
client meetings and after some of the
agency people left
um I asked if I could talk with a client
for a bit after the meeting and because
the main reason was on this white board
in the corner of their office they had
visits this month and visits last month
and the client asked me about the agency
um you know what I was doing for them
and what they what the agency was trying
to do and then they said that they had
concerns and the reason why they had
concerns is that the visits last month
uh were higher than the visits this
month and that over the past few months
the number of visits had been going down
and because of that they were having a
lack of confidence in their agency
now this was really kind of surprising
because this goes right to the heart of
client expectations
uh no when I had asked that client then
after that you know towards the end of
the conversation is how how is your
business how are leads how are your key
performance indicators how are the
conversions on the site
basically asking them how's business uh
and the response to that was well
business is great business has been
improving over the past few months
however the primary metrics they were
looking at was visits rather than the
business oriented metrics and so this is
where establishing expectations of what
campaign metrics we're going to follow
and what those campaign metrics mean to
a business this is a conversation that
must take place rather than just
reporting basic information the same
charts and graphs every month or every
quarter that really might not
communicate the information that
everyone needs and so a conversation
between agencies and clients about what
are the expectations of this SEO
campaign what do we want out of that and
what constitutes success that
conversation needs to take place and
then that will determine how the
campaign metrics are then developed and
presented and the discussion that will
happen around them
now one thing that I think has been uh
you know I would say both a struggle as
well as what needs to happen the the
first thing about SEO metrics is the
myth of the number one ranking once in a
while I'll still run into this where
someone will
hinge the entire success of a campaign
by seeing the number one ranking they
want a single word or a tooth word
phrase to rank number one in Google and
that is their only standard of success
uh unfortunately I you know anymore I
will not even work with that kind of a
client because it's an unrealistic
expectation and it also shows a complete
ignorance of how search works and what
it the power of what it can bring to
your business that this is much bigger
than a number one ranking and if that's
all you want then give me a budget and
we'll pay for it uh but I would say for
the most part we've moved Beyond a
number one ranking uh and now what we
have to educate people on is that
rankings are really a personal metric
that you the rankings you see are
probably going to be slightly different
than everybody else and I'm going to
walk through why that happens and so you
can help educate people within your own
organization of why ranking is a
personal metric now rather than a
universal metric
and then of course as I had mentioned
before it's on the expectations
campaign metrics need to focus on the
business objectives not just on the
external factors of rankings and and
somewhat invisibility uh we want to look
at the visibility of a company but
ultimately what we need to look at is
how is your search campaign
delivering on your business objectives
because that's the point of it all is
what are we what are we trying to
accomplish and how is it being
accomplished
see it's when I see charts like this
that still make me a little queasy and
still make me roll my eyes this was done
uh about two years ago asking people
what are you measuring and unfortunately
there hasn't been much change since this
initial survey that the vast majority of
people are measuring the number of
visits to the website
uh and then they're measuring social
sharing time on site and less than half
are still measuring SEO rankings
um now that still boggles my mind
because that's what I'm going to walk
through here is why we can't measure SEO
rankings it is a completely undependable
metric and so
what what really surprises me shocks me
is that 35 percent of people are
measuring subscriber growth and 27 a
little more than a fourth of businesses
surveyed here are measuring sales leads
this is what it shows so shocking and
surprising especially when we come to
campaign metrics and expectations of a
client and that is what are the business
objectives what is it that you want to
grow because the last column here sales
leads is what makes business grow that
is a direct contributor to revenue
and subscriber growth well that builds
my list and marketing to my list is a
direct contributor to revenue
and so as I said this is just so
mind-boggling because the two things
that directly contribute that have a
direct impact on Revenue are the least
measured in this survey the four things
that have an indirect impact uh meaning
that you can have is as I mentioned
before an incredible number of website
visits but absolutely no Revenue coming
in as a result of that
these are all key performance indicators
visits sharing time on site those are
key performance indicators they're not
business objectives and so part of the
expectations of developing campaign
metrics is understanding the difference
between a key performance indicator and
a business objective because it's easy
to get sidetracked especially with
search metrics especially with these
types of things of you know visits time
on site page views rankings but they're
all indirect which is why they are under
the key performance indicator uh
grouping whereas we want to look at the
business objectives of subscribers sales
leads downloads getting information into
people's hands engaging with them and
moving along the customer Journey when
we can develop metrics that focus on the
experience of a prospect or a customer
then
and tie that to our SEO performance now
we're developing how our Campaign Will
directly impact the business and the
customer
now I want to just go off to the side
for a little bit here and talk about
rankings and this is the whole concept
of rankings are personal not Universal
now you'll notice on this this is the
this is a uh a rankings report from 2008
and compared to 2006. I had to go back
really far to find this screenshot and
this is a uh if you were doing a search
for the keyword latest news this would
show you who ranked number one uh and
the change in the rankings over the past
two years and it also we're looking at
it in Google and MSN for some of you
this may look really familiar because
what this did is you put in the domains
that you were tracking the keywords
and you would get a report about who
ranks where for what keyword now this is
back in the day and even around 2008 uh
we were still seeing some or we were
starting to see fluctuations in rankings
based on where you are searching from as
well as some history coming in but we
weren't seeing it to the extent that we
see it today
you see now today your rankings that you
see are largely based on your search
history
it's based on past searches it's based
on content preferences uh what types of
content you tend to search on click on
or visit uh what business or industry
you tend to uh search on as well as any
behaviors such as your predilection to
click on ads paid ads display ads or
anything like that and so what's
happening here is this has been actually
going on for the past 10 years is that
more and more of your rankings are going
to be personalized to your unique
history and the words the sites that you
visit the words you use the types of
queries that you make all of this is
being developed in order to provide you
the most relevant personal results
ultimately it's also being done in order
to focus the paid search ads
specifically to you and your behavior
and the industry that you're in because
that's how the search engines monetize
so the better they understand you and
what you're looking for and again it all
comes down to intent if they can figure
out your intent and provide you results
that are relevant both paid and organic
then that's the goal that's what they're
trying to do and so simply based on your
history we're seeing that rankings are
going to vary from person to person and
maybe even from computer to computer to
smartphone depending upon how you use
them
the second thing is Regional results uh
if you search for specific things in one
region
it's going to show up differently in
other regions if I search for right now
if I go to Google and type in Ford
dealership I'm going to see the one
that's near me and I'm not going to see
one that's out in another state or
another region because based on the
localization that search engines are
providing it's going to look at that
query as a localized result and serve it
to me specifically So based on location
now sometimes we will see things brands
are more Global however if I'm looking
for something that is specific to my
region that can be based on my IP
address my country my city my state even
into a zip code uh local results
targeted results can be limited to a
small area to only show to people who
are within that area or searching in
that area
and so more and more based on
localization we're seeing that affect
the results and that has been highly
impactful especially over the past two
to three years as local search has just
gotten miles better uh in all of the
search engines and it's only going to
increase as well
uh but then also based on the different
types of media based on language based
on the type of search uh the intent of
search or what words you might use uh as
well as here we have the machine
learning come in uh what you'll notice
here is simply if I do a search for
something in Spanish as compared to
English I get different results I get a
completely different results page uh
there's more videos on the Spanish
results uh from the Spanish search then
the English uh also the makeup of the
page is completely different so the
words you use how you structure the
query the language those are all going
to affect the type of results that you
see and then also you can see here is
that the organic results you know we're
seeing videos uh taking over results how
to's uh actual uh you know multiple
things happening in the search engine
and results page and so it's no longer
just a list of 10 links and running a
ranking report to see where you rank
because What's Happening Here is we're
seeing multiple videos being served
prior to even seeing any what you would
call a traditional link or traditional
website snippet here showing up in the
search engine results page so as you can
see all of these things are just
completely transforming
a individual's rankings and so if you
were to measure rankings what you're
measuring is unreality uh you're you're
measuring something that doesn't exist
uh and as I like to say it's a it's
extinct before it's even run because no
person will ever see a ranking report
they will see that reflected in their
results it's going to be personalized
and unique something also to throw into
the mix that even based on your device
you are going to see different results
primary reason is because if you're
using a smartphone it knows your
location and so you're going to have
location results mixed in also based on
contracts with different search
providers uh with different uh
you know licensing from Google licensing
from YouTube uh the results will be
different based on the phone you use
based on the provider that you have uh
and based on uh simply just being mobile
as opposed to desktop
so results are different based on the
device uh so hopefully if anyone uh was
hoping to run a simple ranking report as
an SEO campaign metric uh just this
little side light here has shown it's
really a non-starter anymore the
traditional ranking report is extinct
and we have to move beyond that so how
do we move beyond that because there's
also now that I just shared the the
difficulties of a traditional ranking
report we also have a couple other
obstacles thrown at us that are
specifically uh both from a search
engine standpoint and from a user
standpoint
the first obstacle that we're running
into is from a search engine standpoint
this is what Google is doing if I do a
search for top car reviews in 2017 at
the very top of the results
I get a snippet of information
uh pulled from Consumer Reports now
what's happening here and you may have
seen this as well if you type a question
or something like that that Google is
not only displaying websites but they're
displaying the answers and they're
pulling the content from these websites
now when they do that that does not show
up as a visit and it doesn't show up as
a ranking to Consumer Reports Consumer
Reports has no method of tracking this
visibility and it's incredible
visibility so at one point Google is
providing information to the searcher
but the owner of this result is having
its content displayed by Google without
any knowledge that it's happening unless
someone has gotten in in order to see
that
so
this is a significant amount of
visibility that right now goes
unreported because there's no way to
integrate this into any metric
calculation uh other than a visual
inspection to see what's happening with
this we're going to see more and more of
this Google is presenting more and more
answers through the search engine
results page rather than just the
website
the main reason is Google has seen the
more they do this the more they deliver
the answer in the search engine results
page rather than having people click
through to go to a website
they find that people are more likely to
come back and use Google again
and what's happening here is that Google
essentially is eliminating The Click
through
they're trying to keep people on the
search engine results page as long as
possible think about some of the
searches you've done recently if you
search for weather information you
search for flight information if you
search for sports scores on Google uh
those types of things you're going to
get your answer in the search results
page you don't even have to click
anywhere else to get the information
it's right there
this is going to not only grow under
Google but this is really the big
question mark as to what is the whole
purpose of Google and what are they
doing and how does it benefit me as a
website being in these results when I
can't track this and when Google is
trying to keep people on their site on
their property as long as possible this
is the big question mark moving forward
for SEO metrics
the other side of this is from a
consumer standpoint and this is what we
call dark search dark search are
searches that originate from a
non-traditional search engine for
example if you do a search from your
computer for example Cortana or if you
do a search from your operating system
in uh in apple you can do a search uh
almost on the uh the desktop through the
spotlight search and it will bring up
search results
if you go through that it's using
basically the search engine capability
built into the operating system but it
doesn't get reported as a search engine
referral
instead what's happening is it's sending
you to that site as a direct traffic so
anything that's from an operating system
a search that comes through an app now
if you're using the Google app this is
kind of a kind of a gray area
um but it does happen uh so you
basically have to install the Google
Search app or use something in the
browser but if you're in an app with a
search function and the app is not a
search engine app it will show up as
direct traffic uh your voice based
searches that's using the operating
system uh now you can use a voice based
search in the Google Search app and that
will show up as a search referral I know
this might get a little confusing uh but
this also is you know this is sort of
the dark search of what's going on uh
and then also Amazon like I said is
stealing a lot of business away from
Google but there's no way to really know
what your Amazon ranking is for a
specific product or query uh so in that
way you're kind of losing some of
whatever Amazon is taking we're also
losing some of that data
so those are some of the obstacles that
we're running into in terms of getting a
big picture of campaign metrics
so like I said
we need to start with a business goal
when we start developing campaign
metrics this is where the expectations
need to be very very clear uh and I kind
of like the acronym of clear here that
we need to clearly State what is the
business purpose what are we trying to
ultimately accomplish and how will
search help to accomplish that
based on that we create a set of goals
we lay out the goals of a campaign what
do we want people to do and then carry
that over into how does that accomplish
the purpose
we then explain how and define success
explain how success is accomplished as
people meet those goals how does that
fit into the customer Journey where is
that in the customer Journey how does it
move them from one stage to the next how
do we measure that and how do we Define
that as success then we align metrics to
that strategy we don't just start with
the metrics we start with the purpose
the goal defining success and then
aligning metrics as we have our strategy
and then the final stage is the ideal
customer experience how do we relate
that through these metrics how do we
explain that our customer has seen this
and then they did this or they looked
for this information and it was a
successful visit now what will they need
this is where we look at the overall
customer journey and how search is a
part of that Journey
now getting into some very specific
metrics that will assist this one of the
things that I like to look at and this
can be a part of the reporting if I'm
looking at just the cold hard facts of
of SEO campaign metrics one of the first
things I'm going to look at is that
audience overview and I'm going to look
specifically at my organic traffic now
one of the things I need to caution is
making sure and I'm I'm surprised I
still have to say this is comparing like
time frames you can compare year over
year if you're comparing the entire year
quarter to quarter example is I'm
looking at first quarter 2017 compared
to first quarter 2016. I want to compare
like time frames I am amazed at how many
businesses still look at month to month
to month to month and there's such a
drastic difference between month to
month you have to compare this quarter
to the same quarter last year this month
this year to let that you have to
compare the like time frames going month
to month is is a is chasing your tail
so from here I want to specifically just
look at my organic coverage at this
point what I'm looking at here is with
the audience overview I'm looking at my
total number of sessions this year
compared to last year and I can see that
it's higher uh and in some areas I've
seen some dips uh but then when I went
to go look at specifically in Google
this year or this first quarter compared
to first quarter last year where am I at
in terms of sessions new users bounce
rate conversion rate and transactions
that's what's going to help me as far as
getting the first step in my SEO metrics
the next is looking at total organic
visits this is anything that comes
through search now again this is part of
the conversation this is everything we
can track
uh because there are things that are
completely outside of this uh
this might be a good time to say this I
was talking to an analytics provider a
couple of years ago and in comparing
different analytics systems and I asked
them what makes your analytics more
accurate than your competitors it was
very interesting because this is the
lead engineer and he sort of shushed me
this was on the trade show floor and he
says in analytics we don't talk about
accuracy
he says what I like to say is that our
analytics are less inaccurate than our
class than our competitors
and that is really the case when it
comes to analytics if you've ever
compared analytics from two different
systems and looking at the same metrics
they never agree I'm always amazed at
how many people try to make their Google
analytics line up with their omniture
analytics and it will never happen or
they'll look at multiple different
packages or they'll tell me my agency is
reporting these numbers but these
numbers are what I'm seeing and they're
using two different systems
that's because
Analytics it's tracking what it can
track and what is unclear an algorithm
tries to
organize it or an algorithm tries to
assign things that are unclear to
different areas so each analytics
program kind of has its own methodology
of organizing the information and
interpreting it based on that that's
where you come up with the we're less
inaccurate than our competitors so when
we're measuring organic coverage we're
measuring what we can based on this
system it may not agree with another
system don't try to make it agree
because it just simply won't
now here I'm looking at my total organic
search visits and I can see compared to
the the year prior this quarter is up 18
in visits I can look at total
conversions and I can see that it's up
30 percent uh and then also what I want
to do is look at landing pages and my
keyword Concepts now this is a sense
because the search engines don't provide
us any keyword data what we can do is
look at our landing pages and the amount
of visits those landing pages are
generating
then it doesn't take much to kind of
look at those landing pages and see what
what are they basically about what are
those keyword Concepts now you can go to
Google Search console you can go to Bing
webmaster tools and you can see which
keywords uh are driving traffic to your
business through those webmaster portals
and you can get the concept of what
keywords are driving traffic now one
thing I do like about Bing webmaster
tools is that Bing webmaster tools will
not only show me which keywords I'm
ranking for and which ones are sending
traffic to my website but they will also
show me which Pages or the recipients of
those keywords so they are able to tie
together the keywords and the landing
pages and so I'll do that in bing uh on
also Google search console will do that
to an extent
but to some degree this is still a
manual process of looking at my landing
pages and comparing them to the keyword
Concepts as I said Google's trying to
push everything together into intent and
so evaluate your landing pages in terms
of intent what would someone be
searching on in order to get to this
page and utilize Google search console
and Bing webmaster tools maybe some of
your analytics in order to figure that
out
also what I like to look at are
comparative metrics uh when I'm looking
at the success of an SEO campaign as
tied to other types of campaigns I also
want to show the value of search engine
optimization and what it's providing and
so in looking at a source medium I'm
using Google analytics here what I can
do here is for this time frame look at
the overall numbers of sessions
generated through each Channel as you
can see there Google on its own is about
67 of all visits Yahoo is providing
about
[Music]
1.28 percent of visits and then we can
see a little less than 20 percent are
direct visits so comparatively I can see
where my search engine optimization is
contributing in comparison to all the
other channels and I can get a sense
there and terms of I can run a revenue
report by Source where I can see where
my search is responsible for the
greatest amount of revenue for the
greatest amount of orders and also when
I look at uh one interesting thing here
I can also do a value per session
breakdown and what this shows me is uh
the email campaigns those by far have
the highest value per session visitors
coming through the blog are next in
value per session and then we can see
our search visitors showing up there as
a significantly high value per session
um
and one thing that might jump out to you
there is you can see that Bing has a
four pound 27 value per session compared
to Google with a one pound 77 that's
normal I
over the past 15 years it has been a
really interesting phenomenon that
visitors from Bing or MSN have a higher
value even though I will get uh just
sheer numbers and higher revenue from
Google but they are higher value visitor
uh than Google visitors uh that's just a
phenomenon that we've just observed for
more than about 15 years and really kind
of interesting there uh so from a metric
standpoint I like doing comparative
metrics to see here's how search
compares to your other channels here's
what it's driving compared to your other
channels in terms of visitors in terms
of Engagement in terms of Revenue and
revenue per user
again I I kind of mentioned this
associative metrics using Google search
console uh to see some of the keywords
that Google is driving uh Google my
business I'm going to show that uh as we
get into here before we wrap up Bing
webmaster tools as I said they will show
you the keywords as well as the
associated landing pages analytics uh
getting into analytics and looking at
your organic traffic I showed you a few
reports there uh but that is where
people need to live in order to
understand what's going on with their
search traffic and more and more
um alongside analytics I'm seeing a CRM
integration with analytics really
becoming a a different standard because
within the CRM integration I can then
look at the entire customer journey I
can track the initial touch point of a
consumer I can then see how that spreads
into different searches so maybe they'll
find me first from a paid ad but then
how does a subsequent organic searches
contribute to different touch points and
then maybe there is a retargeting touch
Point uh and so I really like what I'm
seeing with modern CRM systems and
tracking more of the customer journey
and how search is a part of it and that
really then gets to the point of looking
at that customer Journey that ideal
customer experience and it immediately
puts it in the context of the purpose of
the campaign uh and the goals of the
campaign focused around the user
experience
when I'm talking with a client laying
out expectations really my first
question is what makes you money because
that's what we want to track there's our
purpose we want to look at sales and
leads and so I want to look at this
prioritized outcomes this gets back to
what is the purpose of the overall
campaign
then we need to look at what are
performance goals now not all of these
goals
carry the same amount of weight what I
mean by that are inquiries support uh
people viewing videos on like chat
subscribes downloads those are all a
different level of Engagement than a
typical like or retweet or a pin
um that's what I call you know it
these are much more active if someone
makes an inquiry that's a lead if they
contact support if they're viewing
videos about new cars that's a
performance goal that means I'm engaging
somebody and I'm answering their
questions uh we can look at people
subscribing and asking for more
information downloading brochures
downloading information this is where
we'll attach different value to
different actions because some actions
will contribute much more in terms of
value in the customer experience than
others and so we want to look at the
performance goals and establish a level
of value around them and then explain
clearly the difference between a
performance goal and a performance
indicator
performance indicators visibility visits
time on site Pages viewed bounce rate
these are all good performance
indicators but they are removed from a
direct impact on the business goals it's
an indirect factor in fact they can even
be misleading if that's what you're
using because you could see that
business goals are excelling while these
numbers might go down or they might go
up and business goals go down because
it's what are you doing with the
information and how are you focusing
your efforts
I want to focus uh real quickly before I
wrap up here on uh Google my business
and this is something that Google has
done more and more of I'm using actually
a local landscaper that I've been
helping out simply because I love the
numbers that are showing up on this
um and it's really cool because you just
put your business in and then you set
the service area so it can be a zip code
it can be a radius uh and then you can
view the insights this is just on the
left side is the login panel and it will
show you how many searches your business
has shown up for in the past month as we
can see here we're over we're almost at
about six and a half thousand searches
where
people searched for uh their business we
we can see about 8.3
000 views of their local listing and
about uh 16
000 actions uh so we can see here this
now
this probably right here is probably
going to be I think the future of SEO
metrics the main reason is this is what
happens when you do a search for a local
business and the business box shows up
in the results and that business box has
a picture of the business a description
hours uh pictures
and phone number and what can happen
here just like with the information
where Google is showing all the
information and you don't even have to
click through it
this is tracking that type of visibility
this is showing you how many times
simply your business information showed
in the search results and so now from
here we can look specifically on uh what
customers how they viewed your business
and we can see how many times the
business showed up in Search and how
many times it showed up on maps in the
top graph in the lower graph and this is
where I think this is I I think this
where reporting is really going to be
moving is from that business box in the
search results
we're now showing in the past month how
many total actions people have taken and
that is how many people visited the
website from the the inbox information
box how many people requested directions
and how many people called from that
business listing and the far right graph
shows you how many people uh the dark
green so maybe a little over a fourth of
people were looking for the specific
business name
a little more than or a little less than
three quarters of people we're looking
for related keywords and because of that
saw the business information
so from a visibility metric standpoint
within Google search results I love what
Google my business is doing because it's
providing me a view of how many people
are seeing my listing without even
clicking on it but then because of the
interactions available through
smartphone searches local searches map
based searches I can track a lot of this
local activity and how people are then
integrating uh or engaging with my local
search result on google.com
uh so reporting has changed it will
continue to do so that is the only uh
that is the only hard and fast rule here
uh and so metrics need to focus on uh
emphasizing conversion rates optimizing
landing pages and it requires analytics
expertise much more than ever and
ultimately what we want to get to is a
measurement of the user experience like
I said that big picture of the user
experience did they find what they
wanted uh doing task-based user testing
where they have to find a specific bit
of information uh from the search to the
site uh and from that you can gather an
understanding of how quickly they're
able to find it how they can navigate
there both in a desktop and a mobile and
this gets to the the micro moment
assessment when people are searching for
things such as can I afford it uh show
me the new cars
where can I get Finance those types of
micro moment questions that people type
into the search box or speak into their
phone that's where we want to assess the
experience of what do they see what do
they find how easy is it for them to
accomplish their objectives and then
integrate that into a campaign
measurement if you are looking to become
an SEO professional then look no further
than simply runs postgraduate program in
digital marketing so don't miss out on
this opportunity Find the course Link in
the description for more information
okay so the first question that you
might be asking interview is
differentiate between do follows and no
follows okay so if you take in or listen
to my SEO courses on YouTube for SEO we
we talked a lot about do follows and no
follows and and simply put I mean do
follows are just signals to the search
engines to follow the link so there's a
link on a pointing to site B we're going
to basically tell Google Bing and some
of these other search engines hey go
ahead and follow that link now I know
file is just the opposite so no follow
link doesn't allow the search engine
crawlers to follow it so if we have a
link on our site site a pointing to site
B we could put a nofollow tag in there
and what that's going to do it's going
to signal to the Crawlers hey don't
follow this link so in the end of the
Crawlers don't follow the link then
there's not going to be any link juice
passed and so Google is not going to
give you credit or give that site credit
for having a link pointing to it or
pointing to another site or from another
site and so it's all about linking so we
can control if there's links on our site
whether we want the Crawlers to
recognize those or not simply with no
follow tags so just a reminder link
juice is the reputation or Equity pass
from one way website to another so if
you have a link on another website and
that website is of high quality meaning
their page Authority their domain
Authority is high they have a lot of
content you know they're not spammy
they're really rich and they're relevant
then you may want to make sure that the
link pointing from that site to your
site is a no follow so that way that
Google can recognize the link from that
side to your site and basically that
reputation is going to be passed on to
you okay so that's a do follow versus a
no follow and why would we do a nofollow
well it just pens it really depends a
lot of social media platforms like
Facebook have no follows if you have a
lot of content you may not want to be
pushing out a lot of do follows it could
actually look bad from an external
linking standpoint and so a lot of sites
are really particular about who they
want to pass link juice on to and give
credit for the link so it's a business
decision at the end of the day there's
really no hard fast rule here care
except from an SEO perspective if I have
a site and I have a lot of external
links pointing outward to other sites
I'm going to be particular about who I
allow the search engine to follow and
what links I allow not to follow okay so
here's an example of what they look like
so do follow is simply just the href
notice the nofollow has the the tag
appended to it the href tag with a
nofollow so if the search engine's
crawling your site and they see that no
file there they're not going to follow
that link and vice versa if there's a
link on another site pointing to yours
and there's a no follow there you're not
going to get credit the search engines
aren't going to pick up that link okay
so question two what is 301 redirect and
how is it different from a 302 redirect
so three one redirects tell users in the
search engine specifically that an
original page has been moved and this is
the keyword here permanently so
permanently moved we're going to explain
that in a minute so it's just move from
one page to another and so if we don't
have a page anymore we have a new page
let's just say you built a new website
with new URLs you want to make sure the
old page is pointing to the new page
with a 301 redirect so for 301 redirect
is permanent then a 302 is temporary so
we want the search engines to recognize
that we have 301 permanent redirects in
place why because if we have temporary
then it might alert Google to not keep
that page in its search engine rankings
because it's temporary so why would
Google want to keep a temporary page or
even a page that is pointing to another
page on a temporary basis so they may
remove both pages from its index okay
but if we have something permanent in
place Google may say okay this page is
permanently linking to another page or
redirecting to another page therefore
it's stable it's permanent we're going
to keep that new page in the index and
eventually remove the old page so really
something permanent is more stable in
the eyes of the search engine something
temporary may not be as stable in the
eyes of say Google and if they don't see
it as stable then they may remove both
pages from the index okay so the idea is
we want to be found in Google search
index and we get it sometimes Pages go
away for a variety of reasons and if it
does go away just make sure you have a
new page for it and that new page is a
301 permanent redirect okay so question
three why are backlinks important in SEO
well we kind of hinted on that a bit
with the nofollow because if we have a
link from another website pointing to
ours and that link from that other
website is really relevant and and it
has a high page and domain Authority
then it's going to benefit us and so
backlinks are important because if we
have backlinks from Qui quality body
sites it's going to improve the
credibility of our site especially if
it's a do follow tag so the search
engines are going to recognize the
relationship between the site that has a
link pointing to us okay so it's just
going to build our credibility it's
going to increase increase our domain
Authority and then the net effect of
that is if we're credible and we have
high domain Authority then that's going
to increase the rankings of our pages
and when the pages increase in ranking
then we're going to get a more of a
Lion's Share of the traffic for certain
keywords that our pages are found for
and if our pages are found in getting
traffic then because we have increased
rankings we're likely going to have
increased traffic and then it's just a
snowball effect so more traffic leads to
more engagement and conversions so the
whole idea for SEO is remember you have
an on-page strategy and an off-page
strategy building external links is part
of an off-page SEO strategy and we want
to make sure that you know we are
relevant in the form of a link or in the
form of content on other high quality
sites being on a high quality site only
benefits us because again increases
their domain Authority Google sees this
is more relevant therefore pages are
going to benefit by ranking higher and
therefore when we rank higher we get
more traffic so it's a snowball effect
so having backlinks is important because
it snowballs all the way through to
conversions okay so what are the best
practices to rank your videos on YouTube
this is a great question really great
question given the importance of videos
especially with SEO because videos are
found YouTube in itself is a search
engine so if we have a video how are we
going to get it to rank on YouTube well
first things first you never want to put
a video out there and want it to rank if
it's not engaging or informative so make
sure you go ahead and follow the best
practices of having engaging an
informative content in your video now
once you have that video in place you
want to optimize it and then some of the
key factors for optimizing a video are
you want to choose a title that has high
search volume in low difficulty just as
you would keyword for example for web
page you want to choose a title with a
keyword in it that has high volume and
load difficulty IE low competition okay
so you want a nice ratio there and you
know what you want to choose a title
it's going to get people to watch the
video too so it's not all about just
choosing a title just for the sake of
high volume you also have to choose
something that's relevant that's going
to be catchy as well and then with that
title goes the description so you want a
description that's very relevant to your
title okay because most people aren't
going to click on a video just for the
sake of a title they're going to want to
probably get a sneak peek via the
description of what it is so again you
want to optimize that description but
make sure the description is is just as
snazzy as the title okay you also want
to use accurate and relevant video tags
just as you would on Twitter Facebook
tag these videos okay so make sure your
title tag length doesn't exceed 100
characters because it will get chopped
off so again that goes back to just
writing something really short and to
the point that's going to grab
somebody's attention Okay you also want
to upload a captivating thumbnail
something that's relevant then that's
gonna grab somebody's attention and then
again we set it similar to the video
tags we want to use relevant hashtags
again just as you would with Twitter and
Facebook go ahead and throw some
hashtags in there that people could see
because people search via hashtagging
and then this goes about saying you did
all the work created a really great
video it's engaging it's a formative you
optimized it feel free to promote your
video on other social media platforms
okay don't just stick with YouTube per
se so the best benefit here is if you
post it on Facebook or LinkedIn or
whatever platform of your choice and it
gets engagement people click on the link
go to YouTube they're gonna like it and
then other people are gonna see that
engagement they're going to see how many
people liked it or how many subscribers
you have so promote your videos to help
you with the ranking of the video on
YouTube so that does play into it so go
ahead and promote it so other people can
watch it like it comment Etc and that's
going to engage other people to want to
do the same so what is mobile first
indexing this is a really important and
timely question mobile first indexing
means Google's just using mobile
friendly content for indexing and
ranking websites so in other words
Google for example has two Bots they
have the traditional desktop bot and
they have a smartphone bot and
eventually everybody that has a website
is going to be migrated over to the
smartphone up and so if that smartphone
bot goes to your website and starts
crawling what do you think they're
looking for their smartphone bot they're
looking for mobile friendly content if
it's not mobile friendly meaning the
page isn't designed for a smartphone
browser or let's just say the images are
way too large or you have to expand the
text just to read it you know a lot of
these these issues that somebody would
have just simply trying to read
something on a web page on their mobile
device Google's not going to grab that
content so you want to make sure it's
mobile friendly so it gets indexed and
so if your website has a responsive
design Google will rank your website
based on its performance on mobile
devices okay so you want to make sure
that your website is mobile friendly and
if you're in an interview and somebody
asks this question you can even take it
a step further and say look I'm going to
measure how friendly my wall my website
is for mobile devices and Google search
console because Google search console
has a report that will show you what
pages on your website are not mobile
friendly and it's not a guarantee but I
could tell you if I'm Google and I'm
crawling your site with my smartphone
Bob and that page or one of my pages is
not mobile friendly I'm probably not
going to index it or rank it so you want
to leverage that report in Google search
console to see what pages are mobile
friendly so that's a little bonus for
you to really impress the interviewer
who asks you this question because how
are you going to know if one of your
pages is mobile friendly or not if you
don't look at a report so keep an eye on
Google search consoles mobile usability
report okay number six list down the
most important local SEO ranking factors
okay so organic local ranking is just as
important as anything else in organic
search because if you have a local
business you want to use the likes of
say Google my business to show up when
somebody types in you know looking for a
florist or you're looking for a coffee
shop so what you want to do is you want
to create a web page for every product
and service okay you also want to opt
for your business listings on Google my
business and and there are plenty of
other local business directories out
there like Yelp for example or Bing even
has one so go ahead and also make sure
you have a business listing as well but
since Google in the United States has a
huge market share you want to start with
Google first you want to update your nap
citations on your website maintain
consistency of your nap okay so nap is
name address phone number so you want to
make sure that that's current and
consistent so if you have a number on
your website make sure it's the same
number on Google my business okay you
can embed a Google map on your website
it could certainly optimize The Meta
taxing content not only on your web
pages but within your Google my business
directory so you can add your business
to other local directories like I
mentioned Yelp and then also just as
important opt for reviews and ratings
okay so the more reviews The Hat you
have the better off you are okay so I
always say this with with local search
three of the main factors in showing up
for local search on say Google is
obviously the keyword the second is the
proximity of where that person is and
then third is the reviews so you can't
really control the proximity but you
can't control the keyword and you can
control the reviews to some degree so
work hard at getting reviews for your
business but at the same time you can
certainly work in some keywords let's
just say for your product and service
pages on your website but also you can
translate that over to Google my
business okay so working in those
keywords making sure you're you're not
number your address your name they're
all consistent and and really just
spreading your the the business out on
other directors that's really all these
are really key factors for local SEO
okay so question number seven how to
avoid duplicate content and getting
penalized for duplicate content so for
example if you have two different
versions of a web page you may result in
a duplicate content issue so it's just
SEO 101 you never want to have two two
or more pages with the same content so
what do we do well we can avoid this and
having Google penalize us by again
setting up a 301 redirect remember three
or ones are permanent we can also use
what they call canonical tag and a
canonical tag basically alerts the
search engines as to which page is the
original okay so if we have an original
page we want to point to that page with
a canonical tag and the third option is
opt for preferred domain and Google
search search console okay so if you
have multiple no names make sure you set
up a primary one in search console so
those are ways to work around it of this
three I would always go with the
canonical tags because that's just a tag
that's going to sit on the page it's
going to alert Google as to what the
original is just in case they get their
hands on the duplicate so all the pages
that have the same content are going to
have the same canonical tag pointing to
one page so again three ones are
permanent you could simply just redirect
one to the other if you end up having
duplication or you could just tell the
search engines hey this is the original
page or you can go through search
console okay number eight what are the
tactics to increase a web page speed
okay so what are some of the tactics
well when you build a site especially
for mobile you want to keep it as simple
as possible and what I mean by simple as
possible really I mean hey use a simple
website design don't get overly creative
if you will most websites all website
sites have images you're not going to be
able to get around that but just make
sure you optimize your images made in
other words don't have such a large
image size if you don't need something
very large don't have it okay you want
to improve server response time and what
do we mean by that well your site's
sitting on a server somewhere you can
own that server or you can be renting it
out from say Amazon web services or
let's just say GoDaddy as your register
they also have web hosting well if you
have it on say GoDaddy server you may be
sharing that server with other
businesses and at certain times of the
day other businesses may get a lot of
traffic and suck up a lot of bandwidth
what is that going to do that's going to
reduce the server response time for your
site and so you want to make sure you
have an idea of you know what server
your web page your website is on and you
want to be able to have some control
over that because if your server
response is slow that's going to slow
down everything else in terms of loading
in the browser and that's not going to
be good for SEO okay optimize your code
what do you mean by optimize minifying
when we see mimifying we mean get rid of
some of the Redundant code if you have
CSS you know get rid of chop some of the
get rid of the JavaScript you're not
using so that's what we mean by
optimizing code readies redirects okay
ideally you just want to have one
redirect in place you don't want to
create a daisy chain so to speak of
redirecting and redirecting after that
that's never going to bode well and it's
going to slow things down as well enable
browser caching so if you enable browser
caching basically if somebody comes back
to the page they've been on say two days
ago they're probably going to see a
cache version of that page and then opt
for the content delivery Network as well
so these are some of the ways to reduce
page speed now if you're curious about
the page speed of your website you can
always go to Google's page speed
insights tool and all you have to do is
just Google page speed insights or even
just something generic like Google page
speed and you're going to get this tool
page speed insights and all you need to
do is just plug in a URL when you plug
in the URL Google is going to analyze
the URL for both mobile and desktop and
so here we could see Google gives a
score so we can see the score from wall
ball and we could see the score for
desktop just by clicking on desktop and
so here I could see some of the issues
that the site may be having in terms of
page load time for their desktop if I
flip over to mobile you know here I can
see some other issues for example they
have a server static assets with
efficient cash policy now if you're not
sure what the heck that means you can
always just click on it and you can see
some specifics here and where you can
just always Google it as well uh here
you got the reduce the impact of
third-party code okay so that's another
thing uh reduce JavaScript execution
time so again going back to a lot of
some of the comments we made about
coding okay so sometimes too much code
or code not functioning as well as it
should will tend to slow down the site
okay so you can use page speed insights
you can always get a glimpse of how
pages are loading simply by also going
to for example Google analytics under
Behavior okay you can go to site speed
and if you click on overview okay Google
what Google does is they do a sampling
of pages over time and in this case
based on 89 Page views they have an
average page load time and so you can
get a sense of how quick specific Pages
load or your site overall simply by
looking at the site speed overview
report in Google analytics to get a
sense of how quick your pages are
loading now there's certain factors that
do affect load time so obviously the way
the page is built with the code the
images Etc but also the browser each
browser loads differently okay so you
want to take a look at it by browser
also by country every country has a
different network you can be in the
United States and have worse network
service than you do say and you know
Ivory Coast in Africa okay so it really
depends on the network you're on so and
also the page every page is built
differently so you want to get a sense
of what pages are loading quicker and
which pages are not you can simply just
go to page timings and Google analytics
you get a sense of what pages do not
load fast and which ones do and maybe
hone in on the pages that aren't loading
fast and address those pages first okay
so you have two tools at your disposal
one Google analytics and one page speed
insights okay so let's look at question
number nine here so when should an
individual Target short tail and long
tail keywords okay so remember short
tail are usually one to two key words
very Broad in nature long tail keywords
or maybe three four keywords in a query
or maybe an entire sentence those are
considered long tail keywords so usually
short tail keywords have higher volume
but also higher competition longer tail
keywords usually have lower uh volume
but also lower competition but the great
thing about long tail keywords the
conversion rate will tend to be a little
bit higher than say a short tail because
it's less vague and more specific so you
can use short tail keywords if you're
trying to drive a lot of visitors
because those keywords are going to be
vague or Broad in nature long tail
keywords are used for targeted Pages
such as product pages and articles so if
you have a specific product with a long
name you can certainly optimize that
page for that product name again the
product name may have low volume but
this somebody types in exactly that
product name you show up the chance of
you them converting are going to be very
high so you don't have to always be that
specific at the product name but try and
be as specific as you possibly can in
order to get somebody to click on your
link in the search engine results and
get them over to your site to convert
okay so those are really the big
differences short tail very broad very
vague a lot of volume but also a lot of
competition but hey if you're ranking
for short tail keyword you're probably
going to get a lot of traffic the
conversion rates may not be as high as
something say long tail where hey maybe
you're just honed in on a few set number
of products and you're not care you
don't care a lot about the traffic you
just care about getting the relevant
traffic to your site to convert okay
number 10 what are the important
elements to focus while developing a
website so we're talking in terms of SEO
okay so if somebody asks me this
question in an interview what am I going
to focus on When developing a website
well the answers are right here yes we
talked about mobile mobile is so
important because a lot of websites are
going to be indexed with Google
smartphone bot so mobile usability is
very important so we need to make sure
our website is responsive for mobile
just some basic practices when it comes
to site architecture navigation we want
to have a simple URL structure okay no
overly cumbersome the navigation should
simply be clean and need okay if you
have five products okay maybe you have
uh in your navigation you have something
called products with all five listed or
you have all five products in the main
navigation the key is you just want to
make it clean and neat and easy for
somebody to find the the rule of thumb
is if it's good for the end user
probably going to be good for Google but
if complicated for the end User it's
probably going to be complicated for
Google okay you always want to create a
site map now what is that sitemap a
sitemap is simply just a formatted file
with to that's includes all your URLs
and assets your images and your videos
they're going to be sitting on your
server as well so you want Google or
these these Bots to be able to find your
pages and assets and by the way you want
to take it a step further and make sure
you upload that site map which is
sitting in the root directory meaning
domain.com
sitemap.xml okay you want to take that
site map and make sure you input that
site map location in Google search
console that way Google search console
has a one-way ticket to grab the
elements in the sitemap another
important element to focus on while
developing a website is having a robot's
text file and all the robots text file
is it's like a lock I always say to a
house so if you lock a door in your
house nobody's going to be able to get
in that door so it's all a robots text
file is you're telling Google and these
other Bots that are coming across your
site what's locked and what's not locked
meaning what they have access to what
they don't have access to so you want to
be able to make sure you have a robot's
text file if you're trying to non-index
specific pages of your website because
if you tell Google don't crawl these
Pages or this directory they're not
going to get crawled and if they don't
get crawled they're not going to get
indexed so robots text file is an
important element to focus on while
you're developing your website and why
you're developing your website it could
be on a you know in a directory just
called new website so you probably want
to have new website as the directory in
the robots text file and just to let
Google know don't go into this directory
because it's my new website I'm not
ready to go live yet so you don't want
it indexed so there are a lot of reasons
to have robots text files that's the
main reason sitemap you want Google to
get these pages and assets quickly okay
you want to make sure that your site
architecture navigation is in order you
want to make sure your site is mobile
friendly and you also want to make sure
you have content on your website that's
the key because that's what's going to
keep people on the website and engaged
and when I say content I don't
necessarily just mean words I also mean
videos I also mean images you know
something interactive okay you want to
keep people engaged that's the key
behind it trust me if if an end user
finds your site engaging Google is
likely going to find your site engaging
okay so those are good brownie points to
bring up if somebody asks you this
question in an interview so just a quick
recap here it's important to have a
better site structure so the Bots can
easily access into next content okay
with a responsive design helps to make
your website mobile friendly and user
friendly would also increase the amount
of time a user spends on your website
which may improve your site's ranking
sitemap is simply just a file that helps
search engine Bots to understand the
structure of the website okay how many
pages are on your website and where are
they located along with the videos and
images okay and then the robots text
just instructs the search engine Chrome
dollars to understand what pages should
not be indexed here we wrap up with
Advanced SEO full course if you like
this video then hit the like button
consider subscribing to our Channel and
hit the Bell icon so never miss an
update for simply not till then keep
watching and keep learning
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
foreign